Jetzt sollte es eigentlich wieder funktionieren.
Ja, jetzt haben wir auch ordentliche Bitrate.
Jetzt sieht das Ganze auch nicht mehr so abartig, pixelig aus.
Jetzt ist es besser.
Real old one eyes.
Ja, ich vermute, du bist auch etwas älter.
Nicht wundern, dass ich mich so komisch an.
Ich muss mal kurz die Vorschau checken.
Ob alles gut eigentlich ist.
Alles gut.
So, nice.
Ja, du siehst hier das Game, in dem du dein halbes Leben verbracht hast.
Ich auch.
Mach dir nichts draus.
Ich habe eindeutig zu viele.
Liko Fletchens Coach.
What?
Who cares, man?
Ich wollte hier einen Ticken leiser machen.
Alles klar.
So, dann holen wir uns eine Runde Free Level ab.
Und dann machen wir die Epic.
Also wir haben heute tatsächlich einiges vor.
Nebenbei muss ich mal in Discord gucken, ob meine Leute on kommen.
Also will ich sagen.
Ach, meine Leute.
Stimmt.
Das sind nicht meine, sondern die Leute, mit denen ich immer zusammen spiele.
Wir haben da so einen Discord Channel, weil das ist wild verteilt.
Wir haben Franzosen, Italiener, Polen.
Das ist eigentlich alles dabei.
Glücklicherweise die meisten EU.
Guild Invite bräuchte ich auch mal.
Summoners Hall Explorer.
Ja, alles gut.
Ihr wisst, Dark PvE.
Braindead as fuck.
Also, wer Dark PvE was anspruchsvolles machen möchte, der hat Serious Max.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Also, wer Dark PvE was anspruchsvolles sucht.
Ey, wie ist das?
Ist der Game Sound so laut?
Ist das der Game Sound wirklich hier drüber?
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Außerdem muss ich After MSI Afterburner starten.
Okay, ich sollte nicht nach After suchen hier.
Wenn Windows automatisch Sachen.
Aus dem Internet einblendet.
Vielleicht taktisch nicht so geschickt.
Ich habe auf dem Streaming Accounts MSI Afterburner nicht installiert.
Ich kann keine FPS anzeigen.
Was sagt?
Weil ich habe zwar den übelsten NASA PC, aber Dark läuft, wenn so viel los ist, trotzdem kacke.
Das ist aber normal.
Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
So, ich cast mal ein bisschen Speere.
Ja.
Also, ich muss sagen, PvE ist zu 99% extrem braindead.
Also, du machst eigentlich nichts, außer Mobs umzergen oder, ja, gut, vieles vom normalen PvP ist auch braindead, wenn man nur BG spielt und alles umrusht, aber man muss sagen, wer zum größten Teil PvE spielen will oder PvM, also für den ist Dark jetzt nicht so das, man muss aber sagen, dass sie auf Eden das wirklich ganz gut gemacht haben.
Also, man kann als.
PvE-Spieler, sagen wir mal, nicht als PvE-Spieler, aber sagen wir mal, jemand, der PvP mag, aber auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen PvE spielen will, da haben sie es auf Eden ganz gut gemacht, denn auf Eden gibt es tatsächlich zumindest einen, sagen wir mal, relativ anspruchsvollen Group-Content-Dungeon und man kann auf Eden Tor-Encounter machen, allerdings ohne Artefakte und alles, rein für Reskins.
Was sehr nice ist.
Also.
Vor war ein Add-on für Dark von 2005, da gab es so Atlantis-Gebiete in Atlantis mit unter Wasser und sowas und da gab es halt, das war das Add-on, wo viele Leute keinen Bock mehr auf das Spiel hatten, weil sich das Spiel für viele dann zu Richtung, zu sehr Richtung, ja, so modernere MMOs orientiert hat, so mit viel PvM und, und, BG ist private, okay.
Und, äh, 24-7-gecrinede und sowas, da hatten viele keinen Bock drauf.
Deswegen ist Tor äußerst umstritten gewesen und auf Eden, also das ist hier dieser Reshot-Server, auf dem ich spiele, auf Eden haben sie es wirklich sehr clever gelöst.
Auf Eden kannst du Tor-Content machen, noch nicht alles, ich glaube, die schalten in Zukunft noch ein bisschen mehr frei.
Auf Eden kannst du Tor-Content machen, äh, bisher nur den Open-World-Tor-Content, also du kannst die ganzen, ähm, ML-Rates noch nicht machen.
Aber du kannst die, oh, oh, LAPS am Start.
Alter, die Alps, ey, das sind, das sind echt PvE-Profis vor dem Herrn, man.
Der Server ist vor, wie viel, vor drei Minuten neu gestartet und die sind schon am Start, man.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Ja, da können wir jetzt nichts machen, ne.
Tja, jetzt wäre es gut, wenn unser BG-Leader mal eine Ansage macht, was, was passiert.
Also, wir, wir werden...
Wir werden wahrscheinlich verrecken jetzt, ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch nur mal so, proaktiv schon.
Ich versuch mal durchzurushen, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, nach rechts.
Meist, bester, bester Weg ist meistens nach rechts, nach rechts durchrushen.
Oh, fuck, ich bin dead.
Okay, dead.
Deadge.
Okay, wir klumpen uns hier, nice, mal Effekte ausmachen.
Also, wir sind jetzt tot, die waren vor uns hier drin, da haben wir gelitten.
Das sind, das sind tatsächlich echte Gegner jetzt, ne.
Nur so.
Oh, nebenbei.
Nebenbei erwähnt.
Aber die waren halt schon vor uns drin, ne, deswegen werden wir gerade gefickt.
Ich caste mal ein paar AEs drauf.
Die ersten sterben schon, nice.
Das können wir im Leben nicht gewinnen.
Hab ich schon, hab ich schon, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Train? Hab ich schon TWF?
Hab ich schon, hab ich schon TWF?
Ich hab TWF? Ah, ich hab's nicht.
Moment, TWF?
F, F5?
Fuck.
Ich war zu lang.
Ich hab's noch gar nicht auf der Leiste gehabt, lol.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Unser, unser BG-Leader ist auch despawned, gefühlt.
War nix zu holen hier.
Das sind übrigens alles echte Spieler.
Das dürften so, na, ich denk mal so 100 Alps oder so sein.
Deadge.
Twitch-Maze, danke für den Sub.
Ja.
Der BG-Leader ist auch geil, jetzt flamt er die Leute.
Der hätte erst mal ne Ansage machen sollen, was passiert, wenn man Gegner trifft, ne?
Kannst nicht erwarten, dass spontan 120 Leute die gleiche Eingebung haben.
Ja.
Da ist die, die Leader-Diff am Start.
So, das war's.
Dann können wir das jetzt vergessen.
Dann kann ich meine Epic mit dem, mit dem Runi machen.
Und ich muss nebenbei mal ins Discord schauen.
Ob irgendwer Bock hat,
ein bisschen RVR zu machen?
Ja.
Ein bisschen RVR zu spielen.
So, mal in Discord gucken.
So.
Also, wir sind alle verreckt.
Sehr nice.
Wir haben keinen DF-Access.
Heißt im Endeffekt,
wir
sind dead.
Okay, nö.
Dann disbande ich jetzt einfach
und verpiss mich.
Dann mach ich jetzt mal kurz den ersten Step von meiner Epic fertig.
Mit dem Runi.
Weil ich muss den Runi umbauen,
unbedingt auf 50 kriegen.
Das geht zackig, überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich muss den unbedingt auf 50 kriegen.
Wenn es CL-Dungeon gibt,
muss ich mit.
Weil ich will gleich mit 50 CL5
und den Champion-Level starb.
Dementsprechend,
weil das ist die easy,
die einfachste Waffe, die was taugt,
die man auf die Schnelle bekommen kann.
Und ich hab schon ein paar Scrolls ready.
Um...
Ich hab auch kein Boot auf dem Char.
Naja, da müssen wir schwimmen.
Was?
Ähm...
Gut...
Der will jetzt Dragon Raid machen, da hab ich kein...
Obbei...
Gehen wir Dragon Raid...
Ich könnte...
Ich könnte
tatsächlich ein paar Scales
gebrauchen noch. Komm, wurscht.
Ähm...
Wir gehen Dragon Raid, aber mit nem anderen Char.
Wir gehen auf Shami, weil Shami
wird immer gebraucht.
Wir sind auf dem Chart, kommt man da gut auf Rente.
Easy. Richtig gut gemacht.
Also ganz im Ernst,
Eden ist mit Abstand,
also meiner persönlichen Meinung nach,
der mit Abstand beste Dark-Server
den Ziel gegeben hat.
Und das ist nicht etwa von den offiziellen Leuten,
die aktuell dafür verantwortlich sind,
sondern wir machen Dragon Raid.
Schamane.
Weil, die haben so viel sinnvolle Sachen
auf Eden eingebaut.
Unter anderem,
ich würd's dir zeigen, aber gerade muss ich
muss ich mal schnell porten.
So...
Uplands...
Wer hat die BG für
Dragon BG Join?
Wat? Ah!
Wer hat das? Wie hieß der Typ?
Igor? Ne, Igort.
Igort.
Schauen wir mal kurz rein.
Shaman, LFG...
So, wir müssen...
Alter, Instant Invite
als Shami
immer. Instant Invite, Alter.
So, dann warten wir mal auf
einen TP. Mulan, TP.
Nice.
Hast keine Arbeit mehr? Ne.
Heute nicht. Ich arbeite doch nur 80%
Teilzeit und montags hab ich immer frei.
By the way...
Ey, die Musik lautsteigt
jetzt, ist okay.
Zu anstrengend, das. Mulan,
TP. So, erstmal Self-Buffen.
So.
Also, ich erzähl dir jetzt mal was zu,
wie man auf Eden levelt.
Alter, wo sind wir hier denn gelandet?
WTF? Achso, hier oben.
Da ist der Rest.
Da steht der Rest schon oben. So, wir müssen
jetzt eh 2-3 Minuten warten, bis
gepult wird. Da kann ich dir auch was zu erzählen.
Also, ich buff mal.
Ich buff mal kurz meine Leute.
Wobei ist noch gar keiner da von denen.
Jax ist da. Der stand doch da oben irgendwo rum.
Okay, jetzt kommen sie.
Also, Leute mit
orangem Namen. Nur mal so für alle, die
gar nicht wissen, was wahrscheinlich die meisten sind.
Leute mit orangem Namen sind in meiner Group.
Leute mit grünem Namen sind in meiner Gilde.
Und blaue Namen sind so einfach
random Leute, die so rumrennen.
Guck mal hier, ein Herr-der-Ringe-Fan.
So, erste Neuerung
auf Eden, die extrem
nice ist für alle Klassen,
die buffen können.
Man kann sich Buff-Makros anlegen.
Also, ohne dass man irgendwas extra an das braucht.
So vom Game. Funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich klick jetzt unseren Skull hier an zum Beispiel.
Guck, wo der Typ steht. Da drüben steht der rum.
Dann geh ich auf mein Buff-Makro.
Über Tanks.
Drück das. Und ihr seht.
Ne, Moment. Ich hab die
also, ich hab die Effekte aus. Deswegen sieht man nix.
Dann geh ich hier hin. Guck.
Und ihr seht. Ich kann den komplett buffen.
So, wie das für einen Tank gehört.
Dann klick ich so einen anderen Typ an. Tank-Buff.
Guck mir den Spirit-Master an, der sonst wo rumsteht.
Nächster Skull.
Tank-Buffs.
Sag mal, wie viele Skull haben wir denn?
So, dann haben wir hier Spirit-Master.
Kriegt Caster-Buffs.
So, und der andere Typ, der steht da oben rum.
Der kriegt auch Caster-Buffs.
Also, man kann per Makro buffen.
Das ist extrem nice.
Das geht nur in PvM-Zonen.
Oder in
der jeweiligen Grenzfestung.
Aber es ist für alle Klassen, die buffen müssen,
enorm praktisch.
Also normalerweise würde das so aussehen, wenn ich jemand buffen muss.
Ich klick den an.
Geh auf meine Buff-Leiste.
Geschicklichkeits-Buff.
Constitution-Buff.
Und das mach ich 8x pro Gruppe.
Buff-Ports sind nicht erlaubt.
Generell sind 2. Counts nicht erlaubt.
Und
das machst du 8x pro
Typ in der Gruppe.
Du drehst durch.
Und jedes Mal, wenn du stirbst, musst du rebuffen.
Und früher war es sogar so,
jedes Mal, wenn du geportet bist, musst du rebuffen.
Das ist auf Eden auch nicht mehr so.
Auf Eden bleiben die Buffs erhalten, wenn du portest.
Du hast quasi nach jedem Port
und so immer eine halbe Minute bis Minute
gebufft und immer die gleichen Sachen gedrückt.
Das war super nervig.
Und jetzt kannst du einfach andrücken,
dein Buff-Makro drücken und gut ist.
Also sehr gute Neuerung auf Eden.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die das auf live nicht hinkriegen.
Aber es ist halt so.
Auf live ist das Game eh nur noch komplett auf
wie nennt man das so
Live-Support.
Also auf Eden passiert mehr.
Und dann, um deine Frage zu beantworten,
real old one,
wie man levelt auf Eden.
Also du kannst auf Eden auf
verschiedenste Arten leveln.
Ehrlich gesagt, jeder so wie er Bock hat.
Gibt ja Leute, die machen hauptsächlich
oldschool PvE in der Gruppe.
Dann hast du Leute, die wollen lieber
Quests machen, hast du Leute, die wollen lieber PvP machen.
Du kannst auf Eden potenziell alles machen.
Was auf Eden
tatsächlich im Vergleich zu live,
zumindest zu früher live
als Dark quasi noch
lief in Europa.
Auf den Servern
bist du ja meistens, hast du ja meistens
in Gruppe gelevelt.
Da hast du dich mit Leuten an einem Spot
versammelt und hast für
5 Stunden am Stück irgendwelche Mobs gekloppt.
Das war enorm langweilig und
super ermüdend auch.
Habe ich noch genug Platz
überhaupt im Inf?
Und super ermüdend.
Auf Eden hast du verschiedene Sachen zur Auswahl.
Du kannst auf Eden normal leveln
so wie du das kennst.
Mops machen, Mops bashen
und wenn du ein gutes Setup hast,
geht das auch verhältnismäßig schnell.
Wenn du keinen Bock hast
auf optimiertes
Level Setup oder
keinen Bock hast auf 8 Stunden
Mops kloppen,
dann kannst du leveln mit Killtasks.
Da kriegst du, da gibt's,
muss ich dir zeigen, da gibt's
ein Wiki auf Eden.
Und da siehst du die ganzen
Gebiete, sagen wir Midgard zum Beispiel,
je nachdem in welchem Reich du spielst,
spielst du Real Old One.
Letztendlich ist es aber ziemlich egal.
Gehen wir mal Albion von aus.
Viele Leute spielen ja Alb.
Da siehst du hier die Gebiete plus
in welchem Level Range
es Killtasks gibt.
Und sagen wir mal, du bist jetzt
Level 24 oder du bist Level 20
zwischen Level 20 und 25,
Level 20 und 24, da siehst du, okay,
du kriegst, einmal kriegst du Killtasks
im BG, hier kannst du
einen Dungeon machen, du kannst
hier in das Gebiet gehen, Killtasks machen,
Killtasks. Killtasks sind im Endeffekt,
du gehst zu einem, du gehst
mit, okay,
so, mit
gehst du hier zum Beispiel Porze nach Gotha,
macht's Killtasks, da gehst du zum NPC,
hip, okay,
ist im Prinzip überall das gleiche. Da gehst du zum
NPC, nimmst Quests an, da kriegst
du Quests, da steht dann drinnen, das sind
die 0815 MMO Quests, die man kennt,
äh, da kriegst
du auf deiner Map, kriegst du
dann rote Punkte, so wie hier,
da siehst du markiert, wo du, wo du's
Mobs gibst, dann gehst du hin, killst 10 Mobs,
gehst zum nächsten Spot, killst 10 Mobs,
dann gehst du zurück und
turnst das, äh, turnst das
in, ja, geiler,
geiler Denglisch-Satz, man, gibst die
Quests ab und kriegst EXP für.
Das ist super, um zu leveln,
wenn man keinen Bock hat auf PvP-Stress
und wenn man, ähm, trotzdem
mit Group leveln will, aber jetzt keine optimierte
PvM-Gruppe hat. Also wenn du ne Gruppe
hast, sagen wir mal, mit Speed
und, Speed und DPS
und vielleicht ein Heiler und random
Leute drinne, Hunter, SBs, alles
was du sonst nicht in Gruppe haben willst, kannst du super
mit Kill-Tasks leveln, geht,
wenn man ein bisschen Plan hat, in welcher Reihenfolge
man das macht, super schnell.
Zum Beispiel die, ähm, in
Mid ist es so, die,
es gibt ne super Questrunde,
äh, Skona,
Va-Vanan-Sumpf,
da kannst du
drei Gebiete
oder es gibt auch ne super Questrunde
hier in, äh,
in SI, kannst du beispielsweise
mit 45
kannst du, äh,
Faraheim machen, plus
Delingrater
plus Moderna, kannst du drei
angrenzende Zonen machen
und da kriegst du pro
Runde kriegst du so
drei, drei bis vier
Level, das dauert halt auch ein bisschen
aber du kannst halt, kannst das super machen
entweder solo oder eben auch mit
anderen Leuten. Sag mal,
wer, welcher Depp hat denn das Viech
gepult gerade? Das ist der, das ist der
mit Abstand der schlechteste Platz, das Viech
zu fighten ever.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli,
man. Man fightet das Viech hier.
Guck mal, der, Leute,
man kann den da gar nicht killen. Guckt's euch
mal an. Die Leute spielen das
Game seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren spielen
die das. Aber die Basics, die
sitzen nicht, ey.
Guckt's euch an, man. Die Noobs
fliegen den Heli.
Ich bin übrigens gleich dead, wenn ihr, wenn
mich das Viech hier angreift.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli, man. Guckt!
Alter! Ich renne jetzt raus.
Ich hab keinen Bock. Haben wir, haben wir
einen Heiler oder sowas? Ach, wir haben gar keinen Heiler.
Auch sehr nice.
Pog. Not Pog.
Guckt's, guckt's euch an, man. Man denkt, die haben das
Game noch nie gespielt. Oh!
Moment, Moment, Leute. Ich seh grad auf
dem Char hab ich den, den Chat
noch nicht komplett.
Ich glaube, ist der, ist der Chat weg?
Ja, so ist gut.
Okay. Die Leute, man.
Profis am Werk hier.
So.
Also. So, um dir das weiter,
um das weiter zu erklären. So, die zwei Sachen
kannst du, kannst du machen.
Zum schnell leveln. Und dann
gibt es bei Eden als drittes noch die
Möglichkeit, Battleground only zu leveln.
Ach nee, Moment. Es gibt dann
noch Quests, es gibt noch Killtask-Quests
in, in, im Grenzgebiet.
Die geben tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr XP
und glaube ich sogar RPs.
Weil die halt im Grenzgebiet sind.
Und das Beste,
meiner Meinung nach, zu leveln auf Eden,
wenn man kein Problem
na... Sekunde,
mein Headset spackt. Was ist das?
Okay, gut.
Ihr könnt mir jetzt pullen oder nicht, man?
Was ist los mit euch?
Alter!
Man hält es, man hält es...
Was machen die Leute denn da vorne,
man? Man hält es nicht für möglich,
dass
es Leute gibt, die das seit 20 Jahren
spielen und... Okay.
Genau, und das Beste
auf Eden zum Leveln ist
eigentlich Battlecrowns.
Auf Eden kannst du Battlecrowns...
So, ich hab das Viech jetzt einmal
Damage gemacht, das reicht eigentlich, mehr muss ich nicht machen.
Einmal Damage und gut ist.
Beim Shammy waren sie ein bisschen...
hatten sie ein bisschen wenig Bock auf Animationen,
die... der Gamehersteller.
Weil so gut wie alle Spells vom Shammy
haben die gleiche Animation.
Okay, außer die Heals, die Heals nicht.
Ich vermute...
Das ist glaube ich, ohne Mist,
das ist der dümmste Dragon Raid,
den ich je gesehen habe.
Guckt es euch an, man.
Ja, und das Beste ist tatsächlich
Real Old One Battlecrowns Leveln.
Da haben sie an Eden viel gemacht, also
du hast Battlecrowns von 1
bis 59?
Hast du Battlecrowns?
Guck mal hier, Slash Battlecrowns.
Du hast
von Level 1 ab...
Ganz ehrlich, die ersten
zwei Battlecrowns benutzt man eigentlich nicht.
Da macht man das Tutorialgebiet, dann ist man
instant Level 10. Nach 20 Minuten
bist du Level 10. Da machst du Battlecrowns
und...
Wenn du dir das hier
anguckst,
du kannst quasi, sobald du Level 10 bist,
kannst du Battlecrowns leveln.
Quasi, hier siehst du ja auch,
von welcher Levelrange das ist.
Und...
Da haben sie sich enorm viel Mühe gegeben auf Eden,
dass du wirklich sinnvoll
von 10 bis 50 Battlecrowns
leveln kannst, weil du kriegst
nicht nur RPs in Battlecrowns,
sondern du kannst in Battlecrowns
paar Killquests machen,
die geben auch ganz gute XP.
Du kannst Cap'n Quests machen,
also wenn du das Keep erobert hast,
für jeden Keep-Take im Battlecrown kriegst du
ein Free Level. Und wenn du das Keep hast,
kannst du dort beim Lord
kannst du Quests holen.
Quests ist, du musst so ein paar NPCs
der anderen Reiche killen und dann kannst du wieder
zurück und das einreichen.
Plus jeder Kill
in Battlecrowns und jeder
und ich glaube sogar jeder Mob,
also jedes Viech, was du killst,
gibt
Tokens und die Tokens kannst du
einreichen beim Lord
oder bei NPCs, da kriegst du
XP für. Und alle,
keine Ahnung, alle 500 Tokens
spawnt für jedes Reich ein
Siege-Giant, der das Keep
angreift, sodass du quasi keine
RAM und sowas brauchst,
im Battlecrown, um das Keep,
um die Türen von der Festung
aufzukriegen.
Was enorm nice ist. Also die haben das wirklich gut
durchdacht. Ach ja, übrigens,
für alle, die sich fragen,
wo man das spielen kann, hier, Dark Eden
funktioniert folgendermaßen,
ist total simpel zu spielen, ich glaube, die haben sogar
eine Anleitung mit Play Now.
Du musst den offiziellen Dark Client runterladen,
einmal ausführen lassen
und dann den in Launcher
runterladen, installieren, Dark Folder
einstellen und auf Play drücken. Das war's.
Ich behaupte mal,
ich behaupte mal, das kriegt jeder hin.
Habe ich noch genug Platz für Loot?
Hoffen wir mal.
Hand out, let's go, ich will umloggen.
Ich, ich logge jetzt aus.
Gibt eh nix.
Ich logge jetzt aus. Wobei, ich logge nicht aus.
Ich,
ich porte
jetzt zurück und pack das erstmal
alles in mein Vault, weil mein Inventar ist fast
voll.
Okay, habe ich irgendwas gewonnen? Nein.
Nice, wäre das gedacht.
Du musst dir aber überlegen,
was du spielen willst
denn mit, weil,
also je nachdem, auf was du baust. Ach, guck mal,
Auroch am Start. Weil,
du kennst das ja noch, wenn du damals live gespielt hast.
Es ist nicht alles
gleichermaßen beliebt.
Sie haben auf Eden
auch viel gemacht an der
Class Balance. Meiner Meinung nach
zum größten
Teil gut. Ein paar Sachen
sind aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen zu
OP, aber nachdem wir
das nicht live ist und die 500.000
Jahre brauchen, um was
zu patchen, traue ich
denen bei Eden zu, das ganz gut hinzukriegen. Also
eine Sache, die meiner Meinung nach
persönlich extrem OP ist,
ist Warden
auf hip, weil du hast
quasi einen vollwertigen Tank,
vollwertigen Healer, also
einen 95% vollwertigen
Tank gepaart mit einem
95% vollwertigen Healer
mit Shield-Spec.
Also deswegen, deswegen, also
du hast die beste Rüstung, du hast
also Warden
finde ich, also jetzt für BG nicht unbedingt,
aber Warden
generell zum Kupenbauen ist
durch den Shield-Spec mega OP.
Ich weiß nicht, wird kaum diskutiert, aber
ich finde es ist eines der OPsten Classen
im Spiel zur Zeit.
So, mein
Vault ist voll.
Dragon Scales
habe ich noch im Pages.
Ich muss mal mein Inventar
ein bisschen aufräumen.
Glass habe ich noch
ein bisschen.
Sonst noch irgendwas?
Ice?
Okay, Ice brauchen wir.
Das Ice ist voll.
Switchen wir das mal.
Switchen wir das mal mit Ice.
Ice ist
voll.
Sonst haben wir hier nix.
Okay, schauen wir mal im anderen Vault
nach. Disband.
BG Leave.
Schauen wir mal kurz im anderen Vault
nach. Alter, ich habe einfach alles
random in meinen Vault geklatscht,
Mann.
Paukt das was?
Das können wir mal irgendwie für
300 Gold oder so ins Housing stellen.
Bounty Scrolls
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Brauchen wir alles nicht, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Brauche ich bei meinem Runi,
wenn ich den 50 habe. Okay,
umloggen. Reshade ausschalten
vom Relog, weil sonst crasht das Game.
Und zurück auf den Runi.
Den müssen wir jetzt nämlich 50
machen, da ich heute Abend
fürs RvR
einen 50er Runi am Start habe.
Also ich habe an Chars, ich kann das vielleicht auch nochmal kurz
zeigen, ich habe mehr oder weniger alles was man braucht
am Start. Ich habe
wenn ich den Runi 50 habe, habe ich
jetzt was für nice BG RvR
Aescasten. Ich habe meinen
BG Heiler.
Also meinen 49er
Heiler. Ich habe meinen
BD fürs Farmen.
Ich habe meinen Skalde für RvR Group
und ich habe meinen Shami für
Füllen, wenn man gerade keinen Shami da hat.
Also ich habe jetzt
echt für alle Situationen was
am Start. Was muss ich jetzt als nächstes
machen? Return, okay.
Also wir müssen, also
ich muss heute ein paar Sachen erledigen.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, das dauert eine Weile. Ich mache auch den Stream
an, weil es lohnt sich nicht für eine Stunde oder so
zu streamen. Also ich muss
ähm, okay ich muss meinen Salvage
Salvage Crafting Skills trainieren.
Das mache ich nicht ohne Stream, das ist langweilig. Es fuckt.
Ich muss mir mal den
Charplaner für den Runi und den Heiler angucken.
Ob das alles so passt, wie ich mir das
überlegt habe. Ich muss mir ein Template
für den Runi raussuchen. Genug Währung habe ich.
Template für den Heiler für Level
49. Ich muss
CL5 machen.
Mit dem Runi. Ich muss
die Epic machen mit dem Runi. Ich muss die Epic
fertig machen mit dem Heiler.
Dann will ich ein bisschen RvR machen. Gleich, wenn
die Leute am Start sind. Okay, wir
machen jetzt ein bisschen PvP zur Abwechslung.
Ich muss mal kurz Discon. Ich glaube,
wir machen eine Runde BG RvR.
Halbe Stunde zur Abwechslung zwischendurch.
Ähm,
dann muss ich noch ein bisschen Auto-Hotkey skripten
für meinen Heiler. Und dann machen
wir Daily PvP Quest.
Und nehmen
die ein oder anderen Currency Rates
mit, die aufploppen.
Okay. Dann
machen wir mal zur Abwechslung eine Runde PvP.
Bevor wir heute den PvE-Crime starten.
Halbe Stunde.
Kollege ist schon am Start.
Wenn die Dark-Installation durch ist,
Glückwunsch, Sie haben eine Milliarde Files runtergeladen.
Ja, ist echt so.
Aber im Vergleich
zu anderen Games ist das Game
glaube ich nur 5 Gig groß oder so.
Ich spiele jetzt mal eine Runde Heiler.
Ich muss dazu sagen,
ich bin nicht der allerbeste Heiler-Spieler.
Zumal ich erstens noch nicht die Skillung habe,
die ich haben will. Zweitens keine gescheiten Hotkeys
und sowas. Aber für den Battleground reicht
das. Gestern auch noch knapp 40k
in BG gemacht.
So, dann porten wir mal.
Äh, Battlegrounds.
Wo ist der Papst?
Charakter
von meinem Kollege, mit dem ich hier
öfter zusammen spiele, heißt tatsächlich
The Pope.
Wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob er
den Papst spielt oder was anderes.
Ist der
Papst on?
Ja, The Pope ist
am Start.
Okay.
So, Heiler.
Ist meiner Meinung nach
der
anspruchsvollste Char im gesamten
Game.
Du hast vielleicht noch ein paar andere, die da hinkommen.
Aber aus
meiner Sicht ist
Heiler der schwierigste und anspruchsvollste Char
im gesamten... Alter, wo ist der Typ denn?
Im gesamten Game.
Das liegt daran,
dass...
Ich hoffe,
ich werde jetzt nicht
weggestellt.
Während ich zu meinem
Kollege renne. Also, hier auf der Map sieht man seine
Group Members. Der ist gerade am
Quest-Spot. Das Problem ist,
als Heiler, du kannst zwar
enorm viel,
was du nicht kannst, ist Gegner
killen und Damage machen. Also, alleine
bist du als Heiler komplett verloren.
Dark ist in dem Gesichtspunkt
echt noch so richtiges Oldschool
MMO. Du hast
Support-Klassen, ohne die kannst du nicht spielen, aber
Support-Klassen alleine bekommen nichts auf die Reihe.
Und das
ist nicht so einfach.
Oh nein, die wollen
CL5 machen. Mein Huni ist noch nicht 50.
Aber CL5 ist laufend.
Und
dementsprechend
muss einem das liegen, muss einem Spaß machen.
Aber ehrlich,
ich finde, es gibt kein MMO, wo Support-Spielen
so rewarding ist wie in Dark.
Es kann übrigens sein, dass wir jetzt direkt auf den Sack kriegen,
weil wir sind bloß zwei Leute.
Wo ist der... Wo ist der...
Oh, oh, da sind mit. Wo ist der Papst?
Der Papst
am Start. Guck mal hier.
Der Papst killt schon Leute.
Oh, oh.
Der Papst wird
gebasht. Aber der Papst
kann nicht gebasht werden.
Solange ich ihn heile.
Das war by the way ein echter Spieler.
Man hat es wahrscheinlich kaum gesehen.
So, das ist jetzt eine Neuerung
von Eden. In jedem Battleground
hast du neben Quests
und Tokens. Guck, es gibt für
jeden Kill gibt es Tokens.
Die kannst du einreichen. Oh, da ist dann auch ein Gegner.
What the fuck? Ich habe nicht aufgepasst.
Der Papst regelt schon. Der Papst macht das.
Es gibt in jedem BG so ein
Deserter-Camp. Das ist eine repeatable
Quest. Du musst zehn
Deserter killen und kannst
es abgeben, dass du zehn gekillt hast.
Dafür kriegst du...
Dafür kriegst du
RP und XP.
Das heißt, wenn du dominierst
im BG, kannst du und schnell
durch den BG willst,
kannst du im Endeffekt einfach
Chain für
45 Minuten Deserter machen und du bist
aus dem BG rausgelevelt.
Also das ist Captain-Quests
und Deserter-Quests mit Abstand
das Schnellste, was es gibt.
Oh, das... Ah, das sind Mids.
Ich muss mal kurz
mein...
So, dass man den Chat nicht sieht.
Chatge...
Okay, gut.
Ah, wo ist der Papst?
Ich hab den Papst...
Alter, es hat geleckt.
Ich hab den Papst verloren.
Was, der Papst?
So, das hier ist ein Battleground.
Sprich, das ist von Level...
sieht man hier von Level 45 bis Level 49
quasi so ein Übungspvp-
Gebiet, könnte man das
Ganze nennen. Das ist quasi nicht das
große PvP-Gebiet, was man hier sieht.
Sondern das ist ein
relativ hier überschaubares
Ein-Map-PvP-
Gebiet. Und...
Das ist aber relativ beliebt,
das 49er-BG.
Da spielen
viele zur Entspannung, die grad
keinen Bock auf großes PvP haben.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach mir mal einen
49er-Heiler.
Weil
mit nem ordentlichen Heiler steht und fällt halt
in der Regel so ne
RVR-Gruppe oder PvP-Gruppe.
So. Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich euch
mal später ein bisschen was zu Dark
Gruppen-Setups erzählen.
Also, aktuell ist es so,
wir haben nur zwei Leute in der Gruppe,
mich und den Papst.
Gegner sind nicht zu sehen.
Der Papst ist
Spiritmaster und ich bin
Heiler, was ein ziemlich gutes Duo ist für den
BG. Damit kann man durchaus
auch zu zweit,
naja, vielleicht nicht ne ganze Gruppe killen, aber man kann
durchaus zu zweit 3, 4, 5 Leute killen,
wenn man sie gut erwischt.
Und jetzt vielleicht mal...
Ne, in Dauer kannst du
keine Untoten heilen. Das wär ne coole
Mechanik. Das wär cool.
Da könntest du als Heiler vielleicht ein bisschen was killen.
Ne. Ne, das geht nicht.
Zumal man sagen muss, Heiler ist glaube ich
so ziemlich die dümmste
Klassenbezeichnung, die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Weil
die Sache ist halt die, der Heiler kann heilen,
ja, das ist richtig, aber
der Heiler ist auch Primär-Heiler
in Mid, ja, aber
das meiste, was du machst,
ist meistens gar nicht heilen.
Das meiste, was
du als Heilen machst, oder je nach
dem, was du für einen Heiler spielst, ist
eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass
die Gegner keinen Damage machen können.
Also eigentlich bist du als Heiler mehr dafür da,
dafür zu sorgen, dass
die Gruppe keinen Damage
bekommt.
Da musst du auch nicht heilen, wisst ihr so.
Also...
Und der Grund, aber
auch mit, okay.
Der Grund, warum Heiler, der meiner Meinung nach
Char ist
mit dem, also im gesamten Game,
mit dem, wie sagt man heute
heutzutage so schön, mit dem höchsten
Skill-Sealing,
der Papst ist in seiner Kirche, guckt,
ähm, das liegt daran,
wenn man sich mal hier anguckt,
allein schon, was man für ganze, was man
30 Milliarden Spells hat, man hat vielleicht
insgesamt nicht die Menge, ups, nicht die Menge
an Spells, aber beim Heiler ist es so,
dass man alle Spells braucht.
Nicht wie bei anderen
Klassen, wo du 90% quasi
einfach weglassen kannst.
Der Papst, auf geht's.
Genau, und
was Heiler so anspruchsvoll macht, ist,
du bist halt hauptsächlich dafür da,
die Gegner daran zu hindern,
eben was machen zu können.
Und du bist die beste CC-Klasse
im gesamten Game, meiner, meiner Ansicht nach.
Wobei ich, wobei, ehrlich
gesagt, ich würde sagen, gleich auf,
gleich, gleich auf mit Hexe und
eventuell, Bade kann man sich drüber
streiten, aber du bist
auf jeden Fall die vielseitigste
CC-Klasse im gesamten Spiel.
Also du hast, nur mal so
eine Erklärung, du hast
einen Stun als Heiler,
sowohl als Single-Target, als auch als
AE-Target. Stun bedeutet in Dark,
das ist ein
CC, der geht relativ kurz,
Stun bedeutet in Dark, du kannst
nichts mehr machen, wenn du ihn
abbekommst, und er wird nicht gebrochen
durch Damage. Also da hier zum Beispiel
ist ein Mid, den kann ich jetzt nicht killen.
Okay, im BG ist nichts los.
Du kannst den Gegner stunnen, für
Fall 8 Sekunden, glaube ich, 10 Sekunden
und der Stun hält dann
je nach Resi so
6 Sekunden, 6, 7 Sekunden
und in den 6 Sekunden
kann der nichts machen.
Du kannst den, du kannst den vollen Damage
rein klatschen, ohne dass
er sich wehren kann. Also Stun ist so ziemlich die beste
CC-Variante, die es gibt, aber
dementsprechend auch die kürzeste.
Was der Heiler
hat, was sonst niemand
im gesamten Spiel hat, ist
AE-Stun. Du hast quasi in
einem Radius von 250
Units, kannst du
Gegner stunnen für
9 Sekunden. Das ist super
krass. Also das ist, das ist eines
der OP-sten Spells im gesamten Game.
So, dann hast du als Heiler noch
Alter, in dem BG sind ja nur
Mids da, nicht einen Gegner gesehen bisher.
Außer die zwei Hips am
Deserter-Spot.
Too many Mids.
Albs sind auch keine da.
Äh, sieht, sieht
gerade mau aus mit PvP, ja.
Es ist ja, es ist ja nichts da, Mann.
Nichts. Nichts, Alter.
So, ähm,
so, neben, neben
Single-Stun, damit ihr mal ein Gefühl
dafür bekommt, wie OP Heiler
und dementsprechend auch wie kompliziert Heiler ist,
du hast einen Single-Stun,
du hast einen Area-Stun,
du hast, um noch einen oben
draufzusetzen, einen Instant-Stun,
den du erst gar nicht casten musst,
wenn du noch, oh, guck mal, da kommt ein Gegner.
Der wird jetzt, der wird jetzt gebasht.
Guck mal, ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie OP-Stun ist.
Passt mal hier auf. Stun.
Und jetzt.
Dead.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Der konnte nichts machen. Der musste jetzt einfach,
der musste jetzt einfach für neun Sekunden
dastehen.
Und konnte sich nicht wehren.
Also, ich glaube, das ist, und das war,
das war auch noch Area. Ich habe seinen Pet und ihn
gerade gestunnt für neun Sekunden.
Er hat einfach, er, er konnte, er ist einfach aus dem
Game für, für, für neun Sekunden.
Ja. Also,
massive, massive OP-Spell.
Und nicht nur,
dass du als Heiler Single-Stun,
Area-Stun hast. Du hast
Instant-Single-Stun, Instant-Area-Stun,
je nachdem, wie lang du,
wie lang du, wie hoch du,
wie hoch du skillst. So.
Das ist aber, das ist aber noch nicht genug an CC.
Du hast ein Single-Target-Root,
wo du Gegner quasi root für,
als sie quasi am Boden festfrieren
oder können sie sich nicht mal bewegen.
Das ist für Caster nicht so gut.
Man kann ja immer noch Range-DPS casten,
aber für Tanks ist es halt sehr gut.
So, du hast ein Single-Target-Root.
Du hast ein Sleep.
Ein Single-Target-Sleep, ein Area-Sleep.
Du hast alles.
Heiler hat alles an CC, was es in diesem Spiel
gibt.
Polemo spielt jetzt mit. Ja.
Obermalaka spielt jetzt,
spielt jetzt mit.
Ich sag ihm mal, dass wir gerade streamen.
Jetzt ist er bestimmt, ist er bestimmt verwirrt.
So.
Nächster Punkt. So, als wäre das,
als wäre das noch nicht alles genug.
Als, als wäre das noch nicht alles genug,
dass du als Heiler
jedes CC hast, was das Spiel
zu bieten hat, sowohl in Single,
Area, okay, außer Root und
Instant und Instant-Area-Variante.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das reicht noch nicht.
Ach ja, und diese, und
die Spells musst du auch alle zur richtigen Zeitpunkt
an der richtigen Stelle anwenden.
Das heißt, als Heiler musst du wirklich
genau gucken, wo du stehst, dass du das gescheit machst.
So. Dazu kommt noch,
neben dem, dass du alle CCs
hast, die das Spiel hat, du kannst
selbst Sleeps heilen, also
wenn Gegner Sleeps casten auf deine Leute,
kannst du die heilen. Du kannst
Near-Sight heilen.
Caster werden ganz
gerne mal genear-sight, wie das in Dark so
schön heißt. Da kriegt
die, da können, das verkürzt die
Zauber-Reichweite, ja. Normalerweise
hat so ein Zauber 1500, 1500
Range und mit Near-Sight hat er
dann auf einmal plus noch 300 Range oder
sowas.
Hahaha.
Okay. Leute,
der Papst, der Papst hat
euch gewunken gerade. Er hat euch
gebläst.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen? So, genau.
Du kannst Sleeps heilen, du kannst Near-Sights
heilen, was du auch regelmäßig machen
musst, weil sonst bist du ein schlechter Heiler.
Du kannst Vergiftung und Seuche heilen
als Heiler. Du kannst
dafür sorgen, dass Gegner, wenn sie
Zauber casten, vergessen,
dass sie Zauber casten und den Zauber neu casten
müssen. Das ist eigentlich eines der
OP-sten Sachen im gesamten Game.
War lange Zeit unter dem Radar
der 0815 Casual-Leute, die das Spiel gespielt
haben. Das ist ein massive
ähm...
Pilz ist nicht in der Unterzahl, nein, nein. Pilz ist
immer noch super,
super, super krasse
Riesen-BG. Gestern Abend wurden
die Hips bisschen weggefickt.
Anders kann man's nicht, kann man's nicht sagen.
Die haben ziemlich
auf den Sack bekommen. Aber da
vor dem ganzen Tag hat Pilz alles
weggezerrt. Also alles, alles beim Alten.
Ja, hiermit kannst du
gegnerische Caster vergessen lassen, was sie
gerade casten und dann müssen sie's nochmal neu zaubern.
Plus,
zu dem ganzen Zeug, was ich jetzt erklärt hab,
was Heiler so OP macht und was Heiler auch so
kompliziert macht, kann Heiler
selbstverständlich auch noch heilen.
Und das musst du neben dem ganzen CC-Kram
auch noch machen.
Und deswegen ist meiner Meinung nach
Heiler mit die
anspruchsvollste und schwierigste Klasse im
Spiel. Ich hab mir extra
einen Battleground-Heiler gemacht, dass ich mich ein bisschen dran
gewöhnen kann. Es geht.
Also man muss sagen, wenn man... Was ist denn da am Start?
Mids, oder? Ja, Mids.
Also ich muss euch
sagen, es geht eigentlich ganz gut,
was BG RvR angeht,
auf Eden in Mid.
Weil wir haben...
Oh, erschreck mich nicht so.
Wir haben, sagen wir mal, wir haben mit Polemo
unserem griechischen
Obermalacca
haben wir quasi den
Haupt-BG-Leader, der quasi jeden Tag
mehrere Stunden am Start ist.
Da ist noch Siri, der macht ab und zu BGs.
Ist auch ganz nice. Wir haben noch
die ein oder anderen bisschen kleineren, die haben aber meistens
dann nicht so die große Spieleranzahl.
Aber mit Polemo geht's eigentlich abends ganz gut.
Und du kannst dich bei ihm halt auch drauf verlassen.
Der ist halt einfach da.
Der ist halt immer da.
Stehen, wie sieht's aus? Was macht dein Döner?
Moin.
Jetzt, kleine Besonderheit.
Der Papst hat, wie sich das gehört,
ein Relikt aufgenommen.
Jetzt werden wir auf der Map angezeigt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hips, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen.
Das sind keine
Kack-Noobs.
Die werden jetzt gebasht.
Du gehst, du gehst.
Alter,
ich Kack-Noob, ich hab den
nicht angeklickt bekommen.
Aber ist egal, ist egal.
Den kann ich instant C10 hier, das geht schon.
Kein Ding. Habt ihr's gesehen?
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Ich hatte das Fenster
über dem Instant, Alter.
Ich hab's
verkackt.
Ich hab's richtig verkackt.
So schnell kann's
gehen als Heiler, siehste?
Einmal verkackt, direkt,
direkt gelitten.
Ich hab den Gegner nicht angeklickt bekommen, weil ich irgendwie
keine Ahnung, Räumer im Finger hab
oder so.
Und schon dead.
Schon dead.
Waffen wir das Pad nochmal kurz.
So schnell kann's gehen. Als Heiler nicht aufgepasst.
Alles kaputt.
Next.
Das Schöne an Battle Crowns ist, es geht halt schnell.
Die Action geht halt schnell.
Ah ja,
ein Problem war auch,
dass ich hab den
zwar gesleept, den Typ an mir,
aber irgendjemand
hat den rausgeholt, sonst hätte ich das überlebt.
Das nächste war, ich hab meine Instance
nicht quick bindet,
dementsprechend konnte ich die auch nicht auslösen.
Da sieht man, man muss als Heiler einiges machen.
Ja,
E-Twin.
Eigentlich wär das E-Twin gewesen, wenn ich's nicht
verkackt hätte.
Was findet ihr besser, Leute? Hut
oder ohne Hut mit Kappe auf?
Ich find Hut ja nice.
War da oben was?
Mit Hut? Ja, Hut ist stylisch, ne?
Find auch Hut nicer.
Extra nice.
Eine dumme Sache am Battle Crown
ist, man hat so wenig,
also ich hab richtig, richtig
schlechtes Gear, guck mal.
Ich hab kaum Nahkampfresis, deswegen hat er
mich auch so schnell gekillt.
Deswegen, ich will mit dem Heiler unbedingt die Epic
machen.
Damit ich mal ein bisschen ordentliches Gear hab.
Wenigstens. Das müssen wir heute auch machen.
Mit dem Heiler. Die Epic fertig.
Vielleicht machen wir das jetzt sogar gleich anschließend.
Ach guck mal, die wollen sich das Keep holen.
Mit diesen Tokens hier,
die man für jeden Kill bekommt,
kann man diesen Siege Giant spawnen.
Und mit dem Siege Giant
kann man jetzt versuchen, das Keep
anzugreifen, ohne dass man Rammen und sowas braucht.
Was ist denn da vorne?
Was ist da los? Albs? Albs?
Oh! Oh! Oh!
Viel zu viele, Mann! Viel zu viele! What the fuck?
Wobei das gar nicht so...
Moment, das sind...
Den muss ich, den muss ich CC'en.
Ich hab's...
Ich bin so schlecht gerade, Mann!
Weißt du mal, wie's richtig...
Ich muss den Papst heilen.
Der Papst muss geheilt werden.
Der hier muss...
Alter Falter, Mann!
What the fuck?
Der ist aus Range gelaufen, ey.
Siehst du, so schnell
kann's gehen, bist du direkt
dead.
Ich will nicht 50 werden.
Ich hab XP off.
Ich hab XP off
mit dem Heiler.
Oder Papst muss weiterarbeiten.
Sad girl.
Der Papst hatte Mittagspause und wollte ne Runde
BG spielen, jetzt versteh ich's.
Okay.
Oh, das war jetzt miese Files, Alter.
Wenn ich so oft Chars switche
und die
Quickbinds und so noch nicht drauf hab, ey.
Boah, richtig verkackt.
Und ich hab grad gefühlt
auch echt so übelsten Krampf im Finger
und krieg nichts angeklickt.
Macht nix, macht nix.
Wir gehen jetzt zurück.
Oder mach ich jetzt die Epic fertig?
Ich mach
die Epic mit dem Heiler fertig.
Komm, wurscht.
Wir sind stehen geblieben.
Nach Hagal müssen wir.
Wir machen die Epic
fertig. Weil das Ding ist, ich hab
halt mega miese Ausrüstung.
Das einzig coole, was ich habe
auf dem Heiler ist der Umhang.
Und der Umhang ist auch nicht gut.
Der Umhang hat nur nen guten Skin.
Also die Stats vom
Umhang sehen ist wirklich nicht berauschend.
Das brauch ich als Heiler nicht.
Also im Prinzip ist der Umhang
kompletter Schrott. Ich hab den Umhang nur wegen dem
Skin an, dass es ein bisschen pro aussieht.
Ja, nice.
Bis denn.
Ist auch ne coole Sache, die
Eden hat. Zeig ich euch mal schnell.
Mega nice.
Passt mal auf.
Eden hat
ein Skinsystem.
Das Game mit Healer fängt erst richtig mit
RR8 an. Warum?
Ich mein, umso höheren RR
du hast,
umso mehr Sachen hast du noch, die du machen musst.
Gut, du hast ein paar Vorteile
mit RR8.
Kannst vielleicht insgesamt ein bisschen schneller casten und sowas.
Aber warum?
Eine Sache, man kann
auf Eden, das gibt's auf live nicht,
man kann den Umhang nehmen,
kann den Umhang diesem NPC geben,
dann muss man 200 Gold bezahlen und bekommt jetzt
einen Pattern.
Jetzt hab ich den Umhang hier an
und dieser Umhang hier,
der sieht so aus. Der sieht kacke aus.
Batterie, Perch, Mock. Ja, ja, das stimmt schon.
Du hast schon recht. Aber ich
finde gerade, vorher muss man sich
ja erst recht Mühe geben. Du kannst nicht einfach
mal Mock drücken und sowas. Außerdem musst
du ja irgendwie RR8 werden.
Und RR8 dauert schon eine Weile.
Also ihr seht, zack, hier guter
Umhang, hier schlechter Umhang. Aber
der schlechte Umhang hat
deutlich, deutlich bessere
Stats als der
hübsche Umhang. Und es gibt
jetzt die Möglichkeit in Dark Skins
auf
also Skins von Items
anzufertigen, zum Beispiel von diesem hübschen Umhang.
Und da kostet
200 Gold. Und da sag ich jetzt hier,
Skin anwenden und zack,
sieht der gute Umhang aus wie der
gut aussehende Umhang.
Massive.
So, dann machen wir
doch jetzt mal die Epic
mit
dem Heiler.
Dass ich, ich bin,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich die Epic mit
dem Heiler machen soll.
Weil, also, das Ding ist, ich muss
50, ich muss 50 mit dem Runi werden.
Muss 50 mit dem Runi
Game
GG
Erstmal gecrashed.
Achso, das war, weil ich Reshade noch an hab.
Ja.
Reshade, Reshade crasht das
Game immer, wenn man in den Login Screen
geht. Warum, man weiß
es nicht. Aber nur, wenn man in den Login Screen
aus dem Game reingeht. Andersrum
nicht. So, ich
muss den Runi 50 machen, damit ich
CL5 mit kann, sobald
CL5 ist.
Ich, oh, wo bin ich denn hier?
Okay, wir machen jetzt schnell mit dem Runi
den, ich geb den
Epic Step hier ab. Danach machen
wir nicht weiter. Ich mach den Runi jetzt
so schnell wie es geht 50.
Gucken, wie ich das am besten mache.
Vielleicht hab ich Glück und es ist irgendein
Free Level Raid oder sowas.
Ansonsten, ich mach jetzt, ich mach einfach
sinnlos ein paar Kill Quests.
Den Epic Step hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Wir machen ein paar,
wir machen ein paar Quests. Das geht, das geht.
Normalerweise würde ich sagen NF
Quests, aber es gibt in Haggar
gibt es eine relativ schnelle,
relativ schnell ein paar Quests, die man,
die man machen kann.
Da sind die Mobs quasi hier um
die Ecke, die man
killen muss.
Und das geht relativ schnell und wahrscheinlich,
wenn ich Glück habe, reicht das.
Sogar schon für 50.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
So.
Spiele eine Runde Runi.
Heißt, ähm, Main
Range DPS Caster in Midgard.
Hast, ups.
Kannst du, wenn
ihr das vergleicht, ne, zwischen dem
Heiler und zwischen dem Runi. Moin EDV
Forensik. Wenn ihr das vergleicht zwischen dem
Runi und dem Heiler, die Leisten hier
oben.
Ist halt, ist halt ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Runi brauchst du eigentlich nix.
Als Runi brauchst du zwei Tasten.
Bolt 1, Bolt 2
und danach DD.
Und Gegner
tot.
Ehrlich. So, ich glaub wir müssen
10 Stück davon killen. Das wird jetzt ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich glaub 10, 10 davon.
Wenn ich Glück hab, hat irgendjemand
Bock mitzumachen.
Weil ich muss den Char echt so schnell
wie es geht 50 kriegen.
Wir könnten versuchen ne Runde PvP
zu machen in
Katal Valley mit dem Runi.
Das Ding ist halt
so schlecht, ey.
So schle...
So schlecht ist mein Gear gar
nicht für
nur random Krempel.
Blaues Molvik random Zeug
Alter.
So schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Da könnten wir
sogar ein bisschen was killen. Das Problem ist,
man kann, also
wenn man keine gescheiten Leute hat, ist BG
RVR halt echt
sehr anstrengend. Wie lang streamst
du bis heute Abend?
Wir killen jetzt schnell
jeweils 10 Mobs hier. Das dauert 5 Minuten.
Dann gehen wir ein bisschen BG.
Das Ding ist, also der Grund
warum ich so schnell wie es geht 50
werden will ist, weil
es gibt ein paar
Quests, die kannst du erst machen, wenn du 50 bist.
Wenn du 50 bist, kannst du
Halls of...
Boah, frag mich nicht
wie man hier... Halls...
Vielleicht ist da jemand drinne.
Nee, ist keiner drin.
Halls of... Irgendwas. Raid machen.
Und das ist
super simpel. Du gehst rein, killst ein paar
Mobs und dann ist durch. Kannst du aber erst mit 50
machen. Kannst du auch nicht
Solo machen, aber in Group ist das
also mit BG ist das super easy.
Und danach
bekommst du
5 Champion Level gratis.
Also als Quest Reward. Und mit
den 5 Champion Level kannst du erstens ein paar neue
Fähigkeiten kaufen, okay. Aber du kriegst deine
Waffe. Kriegst deine
Champion Waffe. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht
die einfachste Waffe
für Level 50er,
gerade für Caster, die einfachste Level
50er, also
die beste, einfachste Level 50er Waffe,
an die man schnell rankommt.
Und CL5 ist auch
Pflicht. Insofern...
Ich müsste mir mal ein ordentliches
Setup raussuchen, was man
mit Runi
auf 50 für ein Template,
was die meisten Leute da spielen. Da müsste ich mal in
Discord gucken. Dafür schon fertige
Templates gibt. Bin ich eigentlich auf Steam
eingeloggt? Ja.
In your face spielt?
Weiß ich jetzt
grad nicht.
Muss ich mich einloggen, um
das Spellcraft Programm zu starten?
Weil ich brauch
ein ordentliches Template für mein
Runi. Mit Template ist in Dark
gemeint, das ist eine ziemlich bescheuerte Bezeichnung.
Wenn man sich
ein Ausrüstungsset
umstellt, also
Rüstung passend zu Schmuck,
Umhang und so, und so dieses
Set, das nennt man Template. Ehrlich
gesagt, ich hab gar keine Ahnung, warum man das eigentlich
Template nennt.
Aber man nennt es Template.
Und
es macht einen enormen Unterschied,
ob man einfach nur Level 50
ist und ein halbwegs brauchbares
Gear hat, oder ein sinniges
Template. Also der...
Man wird sich eigentlich so
denken... Mal als Beispiel. Ja, ich
hab ja meinen 49er Heiler.
Der Heiler ist Level 49,5.
Das ist in Dark wichtig, weil
ab 40 gibt es für jedes halbe Level auch Punkte.
So, also
mein Heiler ist Level 49,5.
Was meint ihr, wie groß
der Powerspike ist
zwischen einem
Level 49,5
Heiler
mit
Level Gear und
einem 50er Heiler mit
gutem Gear?
Wie viele Preacher brauch ich da noch?
Also was
meint ihr, wie viel besser?
Wie viel besser ist ein 50er Heiler
mit gutem Gear versus ein
49,5er Heiler
mit Level Gear? Gut, wahrscheinlich
wird's keiner wissen. Ich kann's euch auch nicht
in Prozent so richtig sagen, aber
ich würd mal sagen, wahrscheinlich so
nicht doppelt so gut,
aber 30, 40
Prozent besser.
Allein schon der Cast Speed ist halt
enorm. Du castest
das Gefühl doppelt so schnell
mit Level 50 und gescheitem Gear
plus auch vielleicht ein paar RRs
als mit 49,5.
Du hast
Gear mit
Geschicklichkeit, Charges drauf und
Geschicklichkeit. Warum auch immer,
Dark ist da nicht sonderlich
logisch. Wenn ihr jetzt hier
zur Auswahl hättet bei
den Fähigkeiten Stats,
welches
von diesen Stats hier ist zuständig
für
Zaubergeschwindigkeit?
Was meint ihr?
Also, nehmen wir mal zwei zur Auswahl.
Zwei zur Auswahl.
Quickness, also sagen wir mal
Schnelligkeit oder Geschicklichkeit.
Was ist
wohl wichtig für Zaubergeschwindigkeit?
Die meisten Leute werden sich jetzt denken
so, ja, bestimmt
Geschwindigkeit, also
Quickness, weil heißt ja
Quickness.
Ist es aber nicht. In Dark
ist Geschicklichkeit für Zaubergeschwindigkeit
zuständig. Weshalb
wissen nur die Hersteller,
nur die Leute, die das programmiert haben?
Keine Ahnung.
Man weiß es nicht.
Was brauche ich jetzt überhaupt noch?
Neun.
Wie viele von den Schlangen
muss ich denn jetzt noch killen? Habe ich das jetzt schon?
Warte mal, ich seh's. Es ist
Geschicklichkeit, ja.
Okay, eins davon noch
und fünf von den Schlangen.
Es ist auch Geschicklichkeit.
Und das geht so weit,
dass es damals der Hersteller selbst nicht wusste
beziehungsweise der Distributor
in Deutschland nicht wusste.
Ein Kollege von mir hat Ordi gespielt
früher. Das ist Chai in Alp,
der
einzige Chai im Game, der
als Waffe so Stäbe verwendet.
Auf jeden Fall auch ziemlich gut.
Zumindest der hat zu Release damals in Deutschland
den Hersteller gefragt,
was soll er denn für Startstats
skillen? Bei seinem Ordi.
Und die haben ihm gesagt,
ja, mach mal, mach mal irgendwie
Quick und Con
und sowas. Total
bescheuert. Falsch. Komplett
falsch. Die hätten ihm eigentlich sagen müssen
15 Decks oder
sowas. Rest such dir aus.
Also der Hersteller wusste es damals selber nicht,
dass Decks für Zaubergeschwindigkeit zuständig ist.
War komplett pepega.
Also vieles in Dark ist halt, man weiß
es, weil man es weiß oder man hat gelitten
im Endeffekt.
Ich hoffe, ich bin danach, mal gucken.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also ich kann in dem Gebiet
Oh!
BG RvR geht los.
Wir könnten, wir könnten tatsächlich
Alter, was ist das denn?
Vormittags BG RvR?
Polemo ist heute aber richtig früh.
Ich hab kein Mana mehr.
Mana please.
Ohne Mana kann ich das Viech nicht killen.
Dead.
Geh mal kurz hinsetzen. Oh nein.
Alle Tränke leer. Fuck.
Brauch Power Tränke.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, warum man unbedingt
seinen 50er
CL5 Stab haben will.
Macht der, macht der Epic?
Macht der Epic? Macht der Quests?
Macht der Quests?
Ich hoffe, der Typ macht Quests.
Dann nehm ich den mit und wir machen schnell die Quests zusammen fertig hier.
Weil Quests geben immer gleich
viel XP. Ich frag den mal, ob er die
Quests macht. Das mag ich übrigens
auch an Dark, dass du einfach
Coop machst mit random Leuten.
Okay, der hat keinen Bock
zu antworten. Dann nicht.
Eschen.
So, hab ich 10? Ja, fertig.
So, und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wie viel XP das ganze gibt.
Das wird noch nicht reichen
für 50,
aber das ist schon mal so ne Hausnummer.
Ohne, es war TG?
Das hab ich verpasst. Hätte ich
mein Level ja umsonst bekommen.
Hab ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Okay, Quests abgeben.
Ja.
49,5. Okay.
Easy. Easy. Easy.
Noch 2,9.
Noch 2,9. Das geht schnell.
Dann mach ich jetzt, zack ich die anderen
zwei Quests hier und dann bin ich 50.
Und sobald es...
Moment, haben wir DF?
Wir haben gar kein DF.
Wo ist der denn?
Ist das ein DF?
Dann mach ich ja schnell die zwei Quests fertig
und dann bin ich 50.
Und wenn ich 50 bin, kann ich die Epic
mit meinem Heiler weitermachen.
Das ist gut.
Nice. Die Sache ist halt, ich hab keinen
Bock, jetzt Epic mit meinem Heiler zu machen.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt hier ein bisschen
langweiliges
wie killen Mobs machen.
Ich hab keinen Bock, umzulongen, die Epic
mit meinem Heiler zu machen und dann zu sehen,
dass es CL5-Dungeon gibt und ich kann nicht mit,
weil ich nicht 50 bin.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
So.
Müssen wir hier runter noch ein paar
Viecher killen?
Ja, bei diesem Baumhaus ist noch was.
Übrigens wisst ihr was ganz merkwürdig ist?
Gerade auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm.
Auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm, da wird
die Lampe hier, er hält
den Boden ganz ungleichmäßig.
Und das muss an der Video-Compression
liegen, keine Ahnung.
Allzeit, moin.
So, das Viech müssen wir killen.
Und dann präge 50
nach der Quest.
Okay, davon muss ich die anderen auch killen.
Hab ich vielleicht
noch ein Lagerfeuer?
Noch ein Lagerfeuer?
Jawoll, ich hab ein Lagerfeuer.
Nice.
Dann geht das jetzt mit Regen auch
deutlich schneller.
Das was ich übrigens mache, wäre
mit Heiler komplett undenkbar.
Och nee, man muss nur jetzt
resisten, man.
Mit Heiler könnte ich hier nichts killen.
Heiler kriegst du nichts dauernd.
Nee, die brauch ich nicht, okay.
Heißt, ich brauch
nur...
Moment, ich hab die andere
Quest nicht angenommen.
Ich bin ein Kack-Noob.
Guck mal, der Bersih ist auch am Start.
Ich bin ein
richtiger Kack-Noob, ich hab die anderen
Quests nicht angenommen, oder?
Weil normalerweise kann man die
Holzfäller auch killen.
Und dann
bin ich 50, wenn ich die zwei
Viecher gekillt hab.
Also 10 Stück.
Und nachdem da jetzt noch ein Tank rumrennt,
ist es noch einfacher. Nee, nicht moderner.
Oh, da kommt Scheiß drauf.
Ich nehm einfach alles an und lösch dann
wieder, wenn ich 50 bin.
Ja, perfekt, geh her.
Und...
Ah, der Linkrat, da brauch ich...
Ihren Wut nehmen wir auch noch an, Quests.
So, jetzt sollte ich wirklich alle haben.
Weil man kann die Quests nicht unbedingt immer
nur in dem Gebiet erledigen, wofür sie da sind.
Sondern manchmal
spawnen Mobs auch außerhalb
von so einem Gebiet.
Ähm, Moment.
Ich hab...
Ich bin etwas orientierungslos.
Hast du damals mit Fahrradfahren angefangen?
Bist du kürzere Strecken gefahren und dann immer länger?
Oder bist du schwierige Strecken gefahren?
Naja, ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre ich super viel Fahrrad schon
gefahren. Nicht, weil mein Fahrrad ist jetzt ja kaputt.
Äh, ich bin tatsächlich...
Ich hab mit ein bisschen kleineren Strecken
angefangen.
Nice.
Jetzt kriegt man nämlich auch hier mehrere
Quest-Belohnungen für den gleichen Mob.
Ich hab mit ein bisschen kürzeren Strecken angefangen.
Aber irgendwann hab ich gesagt, komm, weißt du was?
Auf geht's.
Und dann bin ich auch...
Also, meine längste Strecke bisher waren, glaube ich,
58 Kilometer und mit einem Berg
dazwischen.
Ich glaub, der Berg ist knapp 430 Meter hoch.
Hab ich auch auf
Twitter gepostet. Sieht man, glaube ich, auch.
Hier, warte mal.
Ähm...
Ups, nein.
51 Kilometer hatte das.
51 Kilometer nach Frankfurt sind es 58
gewesen. So viel. Genau.
So was. Und ohne Scheiß,
das Ding ist, das kriegt man hin.
Wisst ihr, er muss mir nicht pissen. Alter!
Mein Ohr!
Das muss... Man darf's halt nicht übertreiben.
Wenn dir schon die Beine brennen
nach 5 Meter ist halt schlecht.
Und selbst wenn man sich super lahm vorkommt,
irgendwie muss man's halt durchhalten.
Also besser langsam
und man schafft, was man schaffen will,
anstatt es total zu übertreiben.
Ich bin jetzt auch kein wirklich richtig
guter Radfahrer oder so.
Alter, der macht schon Damage, ey, der Runi.
Das, obwohl er noch Kack-Gear hat.
Richtiges...
Rot-Gear hat der.
Und er macht immer noch übelst Damage.
Äh, was heißt immer noch? Schon wieder übelst Damage.
Schon übelst Damage.
Und man kann
ihn mit 2 Buttons spielen. Das ist der perfekte
Begeecher für mich.
5 von 5.
Nochmal Greenhand bashen.
Mal gucken, der Bersi macht das.
Wir leachen da jetzt einfach rein.
Guck mal, wir sind jetzt richtig
assi. Wir lassen den
Bersi den anhauen, dann casten wir einmal
drauf und lassen den Bersi den Rest killen.
Und jetzt kriegen wir trotzdem
Quest-Belohnung, Clay.
Weil wir einmal Damage gemacht haben an dem Viech.
Und in der Zwischenzeit können wir
Mana raggen. Ich hab übrigens auch keine
Probleme, wenn der Bersi das auch macht, gell.
So, Woodsman
müssen wir nicht killen. Greenhand müssen wir killen.
Und...
3 Stück noch.
Und dann 50...
Level 50 Ink
stehen bleiben.
Alter, der macht gut Damage, ey.
Okay, 2 Stück noch.
Irgendwie Greenhand...
Greenhand... ah, ein Gelber.
Gelber ist easy.
In Dark ist das übrigens so,
falls ihr euch fragt, warum die Mobs verschiedene
verschiedene Farben
vom Namen her haben.
Gelb bedeutet, die sind ungefähr
dein Level. Grün... äh,
Grün, lull, Alter. Orange
bedeutet, die sind über deinem Level. Ein bisschen
über deinem Level. Und Rot bedeutet,
die sind eine ganze Ecke über deinem Level.
Mila bedeutet, die sind sehr viel über deinem Level.
Umgedreht gibt's das Ganze auch. Blau
bedeutet, die sind eine Ecke unter deinem Level.
Grün bedeutet, die sind
sehr viel unter deinem Level. Also sind
noch weiter unter deinem Level. Und Grau
bedeutet, die sind so weit unter deinem Level, dass du gar nicht mehr XP
dafür bekommst.
Übrigens das Falsche, was ich hier an
nuke grade.
Guck mal, ob ich ein bisschen leachen kann bei dem Bersi.
Oh ne, da hat schon einen gekillt. Fuck.
Okay.
Nice. Sehr schlau gemacht, Max. Du musst ja
trotzdem noch einen anderen killen, weil du den nicht gebraucht
hast. So.
Lass mal überlegen, was machen wir als nächstes?
Wenn ich 50 bin mit dem Runi, geh ich rüber
auf den Heiler, mach Epic mit dem
Heiler. Guck mal, ob ich
einen Roten krieg, ob der nicht zu viel resistet.
Mach ich Epic mit dem Heiler.
Das geht glücklicherweise relativ
schnell, weil ich die meisten Steps schon
hab. Dann
muss ich theoretisch noch die Epic
mit dem Runi machen, aber ich hoffe,
dass es CL5 gibt mit dem
Runi.
So. Geschafft.
Brage Chat.
Dass ich jetzt 50 bin und ich noch irgendwas komisches
questen muss. Es sollte eigentlich reichen,
ja. Zwei Quests
für 2,5B
sollte passen.
Wenn wir auf Nummer sicher gehen wollen,
können wir noch die
Elche da vorne killen.
Die kriegen auch ein bisschen XP
und haben auch eine Killquest.
So.
Brage 50.
Blitz.
Einmal hier abgeben.
Ja. Easy. Noch 0,9.
Easy. Haben wir geschafft.
Nice.
Level 50. So.
Dann lasst uns mal kurz in den
Skillplaner schauen.
In den Characterplaner.
Runemaster
Level 50. So.
AE ist es. 47.
Mehr als 47 in
Runecarving.
Bringt nix. Wie viel hab ich in Runecarving?
Ich glaube, ich hab bei 47 gestoppt, ja.
47 Runecarving.
Jetzt ist die große
Preisfrage, was wir als zweite
Skill-Linie nehmen.
Eigentlich Suppression, weil Suppression ist
die beste, die bessere
Support.
Support ist Group Support
Skill-Linie hiervon und Utility
Casting Skill-Linie. Aber
eine Sache ist halt, dass
man bekommt jetzt als Runemaster
einen Kälte-Debuff.
Einen 50% Kälte-Resistenzen
Debuff.
Und wenn man Darkness
spec'd, bekommt man
eine, nicht spec'd, ähm, wenn man Darkness
ähm, bekommt
man, mit Darkness bekommt man einen
180er oder 179er
Kälte
Single Target Damage.
Das heißt, ich gehe davon aus,
wenn man wirklich richtig gut Damage machen
will, ist es wahrscheinlich
sehr sinnvoll zu debuffen
und dann Darkness zu nuken.
Das Problem ist nur, ich hab Darkness nicht geskillt.
Und damit Darkness Damage macht, müsste ich
da ein bisschen Punkte reinpacken und dann kann ich
Suppression nicht skillen.
Also gehe ich mal von aus, ich skill Suppression.
Anstatt Darkness.
Heißt im Endeffekt
für
einen sinnlosen
AE Spam BG
Runi 47
47 Runecarving
bringt 26 eigentlich was?
Ah, man kriegt sogar
einen Group Playturn. Das ist nice.
Also Train
Übrigens, das ging
auf live auch nicht. Auf live musstest
du, um zu skillen, musstest du immer
so einen Trainer NPC, hier
Trollbuba
Musstest du immer
so einen Trainer NPC suchen, der zu deiner
Klasse passt, damit du trainieren kannst.
Das muss man jetzt auf Eden glücklicherweise nicht mehr.
Auf Eden kann man sagen, was machen
die denn alle in DF? DF ist doch
zu oder check ich's nicht.
Oder ist
DF für alle auf gerade?
Da steht zwar Albion,
aber
wenn ich mir
die Keeps angucke, was machen
die?
Alter, was machen die alle in DF?
Ist DF irgendwie auf?
Oder ist das für alle
offen gerade? Ich check's nicht.
So, zumindest kann man jetzt sagen
Slash Train
47, was hatten wir gesagt?
47 Runecarving und
gut, restliche Punkte in Suppression.
Also 47 passt.
Heißt im Endeffekt sowas hier.
Gut, dann werden wir
unsere Level 50er Skillleisten
bauen. Gab's hier noch irgendwas?
48er Nuke,
den hab ich schon, gab's nix mehr dazu.
47,
den hab ich
auch schon auf der Leiste, easy.
Bei Darkness kam nix dazu.
Runecarving, gab's da noch
irgendwas? 48, jetzt hab ich schon
Bolt, hab ich den? 46er
Bolt. Suppression
kam aber was dazu. Suppression
gibt's ein, ups,
das war das falsche, gibt's ein
Schild.
Gibt's ein Schild, dass ich ein bisschen
mehr aushalte. Stärke,
Debuff und sowas, Overrated, Outdated,
Cheap Baited, braucht keiner.
Und Nearsight hatten wir doch
grad noch bekommen. Wir hatten doch noch nen blauen
Nearsight gekriegt, seh ich das richtig?
Das müsste hier sein.
Ja, blauen Nearsight.
Und
Group BT.
Ja, nice, sehr schön.
Gut, Rudi50?
Dann wollen wir mal.
Ich werd mal jetzt checken, ob DF
auf ist. Mich wundert's, dass so viele
Leute in DF sind, obwohl DF
eigentlich Alp gehört, was enorm
selten ist auf Eden.
Also,
auf Eden haben Alps eigentlich
nie DF.
99% hip,
1% mit und
Alps nie.
Jetzt können wir grad mal unsere
Quests, unser Questlog aufräumen.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwie in DF
reinkommen. Wär auch nicht verkehrt.
Dann kann ich den Huni in DF
parken, dann mach ich mit dem Huni
DF-Quest, sobald's ab ist, falls man
reinkommt. Dann logge ich jetzt auf
Heiler, mach mit meinem Heiler
die E-Pick. Wenn Leute
on kommen, machen wir ein bisschen RVR
zwischendurch. Und
ansonsten machen wir heut Abend BG.
Ist DF...
DF ist auf?
What?
Warum zum Teufel ist DF
auf, aber Realm sagt mir, dass
Albion Zugang hat?
Eh?
Ist DF Event oder sowas?
Hier steht doch eindeutig
Darkness Falls, Axis,
Albion und nicht mit...
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ach, es ist, es ist
DF Event!
Wo sieht man das? Ich seh
hier nix von DF Event.
Okay, ich lösch mal alle meine alten Quests,
vielleicht seh ich dann wieder was.
Es ist
DF Event!
Ja dann, let's
go!
Scheiß auf E-Pick, wir machen ein DF Event.
Ich weiß nicht, wie DF Event aussieht, was man da
dafür macht, aber...
Da gehen wir mit dem
Skalde hin. Oder mit dem
Shammy.
Muss ich kurz umloggen.
Aber erstmal Quests,
erstmal Quests
entfernen.
Ist echt volles Kreis im kleinen
Programm heute, das brauch ich, muss ich behalten.
Heiler E-Pick, Runi E-Pick,
DF Event...
Hast ja was zu tun, ne?
Summoners, Hall Explorer,
Diamond Explorer...
Ach, hier steht's doch!
Moment. Es ist noch
24...
24 Minuten DF Event.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was da abgeht, aber
ich log mal kurz auf nen anderen Char,
dass ich am DF Event teilnehmen
kann. Was auch immer im DF
Event passiert. Ich hab absolut keinen
blassen Schimmer.
Gucken wir uns das Ganze doch jetzt mal an.
Guck mal, die Franzosen sind am Start hier.
French BG.
Des LFG, Le Lube.
Ich kann kein Wort
Französisch.
Ich kenn nur die
MMO,
die MMO
Begriffe, die die Franzosen immer um sich werfen.
Die schreiben ja auch
nicht LFM,
LFG, die schreiben immer Des LFG.
Und es gibt so nen universellen
Term, wo ich auch
keine Ahnung hab, wo der herkommt.
Und zwar
irgendwie schreiben alle Leute
AFK Bio.
Wenn sie aufs Klo müssen.
Nur die Deutschen,
die Deutschen schreiben
AfKlo.
Ist mein Chatfenster
hidden?
Ich glaub nicht, ne?
Jetzt aber.
Bio Break.
Okay.
Wo sind die Leute
alle in DF?
Ich lauf mit den Franzosen da jetzt runter.
Auf.
Let's go.
Darkness Falls.
Ich seh hier überhaupt nicht die DF Events.
Ich glaube euch
einfach mal jetzt, dass
Okay, das kann ich ablehnen.
Daily brauch ich jetzt net.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen seh ich
das DF Event
überhaupt nicht.
Wo sind die?
Ich lauf jetzt runter, mir egal.
Die Franzosen haben keinen Bock loszulaufen.
Also anscheinend ist DF Event,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet,
was da überhaupt abgeht.
Ich werd wahrscheinlich jetzt gefarmt,
wenn ich nicht aufpasse.
Ich schau mal.
Ich guck mal, ob ich rausbekomme,
was DF Event meint.
Reshade einschalten.
Ich würd ja gern mit den Franzosen da runtergehen.
Wie ist denn deine Meinung zu
Maoui mag ich nicht.
Auf.
Franzosen, let's go.
Maoui und Blazer mag ich nicht.
Also Maoui mag ich null.
Blazer
muss mich
noch überzeugen.
Aber
soll ich mal faken, dass ich Französisch bin?
Ob die mich aufnehmen in die Gruppe?
Ich schreib jetzt einfach Death LFG,
weil ich weiß, dass die Franzosen immer so Gruppe suchen.
Und dann tu ich so, als bin ich French.
Dann nehm ich die Franzosen vielleicht mit.
Also wie gesagt,
Maoui mag ich gar nicht.
Ich warte auch immer noch auf den Tag,
wo ich bei Microsoft im Blog lese,
dass Maoui eingestellt wurde.
Es ist die Hölle, ja.
Verstehe ich. Maoui ist wirklich Schrott.
Xamarin war schon Schrott und wurde nie richtig
gut gemacht und Maoui ist ja im Prinzip
das gleiche, nur unbenannt.
Franzosen können nicht sprinten.
Wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste,
wo unsere BG ist,
das wär halt enorm nice.
Also die Mids killen auf jeden Fall schon mal
in DF was.
Ich renne jetzt einfach mal mit den Franzosen weiter
und gucke, ob da irgendwas sich
tut.
Wo ist denn die BG aktuell?
Die erste App
wurde mit XF geschrieben.
Was ist denn XF?
Okay, anscheinend
geht richtig was ab gerade in DF.
Ich weiß bloß nicht wo.
Ach, Xamarin Forms ist XF.
Ah, verstehe.
Ich hoffe die viben jetzt nicht,
während ich gerade auf dem Weg dahin bin.
Ich hau mal mit drauf.
Bin mal nett.
Was würdest du sagen, ist ein großer Unterschied
zwischen Xamarin und Maoui?
Also soweit ich das gesehen habe ist
Maoui ja quasi nur ein
rebrandedes Xamarin.
So, ist hier die BG?
Wetten die schaffen es nicht hier vorbeizulaufen
ohne Mobs zu pullen?
Doch, schaffen sie.
Ist hier unten was? Es ruckelt schon ein bisschen.
Ich glaube da unten geht was.
Da unten stehen schon Hips rum.
Okay, da unten stehen schon Gegner rum.
Da...
Das sieht aus wie ein Gegner der Stickloss hat.
Irgendjemand spielt...
Spielt jemand von euch auch auf Eden
und hat eine Ahnung was das DF Event
eigentlich genau ist?
Ich bin nämlich gerade eingeloggt und habe festgestellt
es ist DF... Aha, guck mal da.
Oh shit.
Ich verpiss mich mal.
Okay Franzosen, let's go.
Macht ihr das mal.
Nope.
Die sterben jetzt gleich.
Und tschüss.
Oder? Sterben die?
Oh fuck, Alter wie viele Hips.
Mon KS.
Das sind ja 3 Milliarden Hips
gerade gewesen.
Wo sind denn... Wo ist denn unsere BG eigentlich?
Wo ist unsere BG?
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo unsere BG ist.
Oh fuck.
Okay Leute, ich glaube ich bin...
Ich glaube ich bin dead, gell.
Wenn jetzt hier ein Mob steht bin ich gefickt.
Wenn wir Glück haben...
Kann ich mich hier irgendwie verstecken oder so?
Ja.
Kann man auch kämpfen in dem Spiel?
Wenn man nicht sterben will sollte man aber nicht gegen 40 Gegner kämpfen.
Hätte einer...
Ich hätte ja den einen fast one-shotted gerade.
Okay ich...
Ich checke.
Stick, stick, stick.
Ja ich würde ja gerne sticken wenn ich wüsste wo ihr seid, Alter.
Okay hier sind bestimmt noch ein paar Hips.
Muss ich aufpassen.
Dass ich da nicht rein laufe.
Okay die Hips sind da unten.
Ey ich kann allein halt hier überhaupt nichts machen.
Die Franzosen sind geweibt. Sind dead.
Ich versuche halt irgendwie zu unserer BG zu kommen.
Ah.
Vielleicht... Okay.
Vielleicht kann ich den einen oder anderen ableachen.
Lass mal kurz gucken von hinten.
Heck wait.
Oh ne.
Das war jetzt gerade ein echter Gegner.
Wenn ich gerade one-shotted habe.
Gucken das nichts von unten kommt.
Sobald Gegner kommen und ich hier
Mobs am Arsch habe bin ich eh dead.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Dass ich das Viech vielleicht
halbwegs schnell kaputt kriege.
Auf Mann.
Okay wir probieren jetzt mal was Leute.
Wir probieren mal was.
Ob ich es überhaupt schaffe zu unserer mit BG.
Ich könnte versuchen ein paar Hips zu killen.
Die versuchen runter zu gehen in DF.
Das ist glaube ich das einzige was man noch machen könnte.
Okay ich werde invited.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo der Dude ist.
Was ist denn da unten?
Sieht man das?
Man sieht es nicht.
Man kriegt es auch nicht angeklickt.
Ach hier ist unsere BG.
Die sind gar nicht da unten.
Ich bin viel zu weit vorne.
Sag ihm das doch mal Mann.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht durch.
Aber hier ist unsere BG.
Lull alter.
Hier da sind sie doch.
Euch habe ich gesucht Jungs.
Euch habe ich gesucht.
Hallo Jungs lets go.
Ich habe auch ein BD dabei.
Wir sind richtig gut zum RPs leachen.
Einmal TWF rein und wenn wir den Fight gewinnen
dann gibt es Fett, Donks.
Schau mal mit drauf.
Also was wir gesehen haben ist
vorher sind bestimmt an die 100 Hips
herunter gerusht.
Ich vermute mal, dass unser
Ober Malacca BG Anführer
versuchen wird
die jetzt
zu killen.
Na, die Quest brauche ich nicht.
Das habe ich übrigens auch neu auf
eben, dass die
BG-Anführer hier
so eine, so ein
Banner haben.
Schauen wir mal, wo die Hips sind.
Mal gucken, ob das was wird.
Bin gespannt.
Ich haue jetzt nicht drauf.
Ich mache mal kurz die Effekte aus.
Oh, da sind die Hips.
Da sind die Hips.
Oh, das sind richtig viele, Mann.
Das sind richtig viele.
Guck mal, wir haben kaum Leute.
Oh, wir sind dead, Alter.
Ich glaube, wir sind
richtig dead, gell?
Aber den können wir killen.
Bam. Oder auch nicht.
Warum hauen wir denn jetzt ab?
MonkaS?
Okay, wir hauen ab. Verstehe.
Wir wollen nicht sterben.
Der Beam ist neu, ne?
Oh, da kann ich nicht rein.
Wenn ich da reingehe, bin ich direkt dead.
Wir haben keinen Heiler und nix.
Können versuchen, ein bisschen Damage zu machen und uns
zu verpissen.
Aber die Heiler von denen stehen um die Ecke.
Wir sind direkt dead.
Nice. Top.
Alter, sind das viele.
What the fuck?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind einfach 30 Milliarden, Mann.
Dead.
Okay, das war jetzt
Biggie Leaf.
Wir machen jetzt das, was ich die ganze Zeit
machen wollte.
Ich mache jetzt Epic mit meinem Heiler.
Das hat ja so keinen Sinn.
Guck mal, das sind 30 Milliarden mit.
Way too much.
Ich mag Epic mit Heiler.
Das hat sonst keinen Sinn.
Ja, das DF-Event.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was jetzt eigentlich das DF-Event ist,
ehrlich gesagt.
Also, was es bei dem DF-Event jetzt gibt.
Warum alle auf einmal wie verrückt
nach DF rennen.
Du machst auch noch nicht. Okay, ja, dann.
Kein Plan.
Das waren so viele.
Letztendlich.
Normalerweise würde ich RVR,
also gerade BG-RVR, würde ich auch nur mit
...
mit Delay-Stream.
Oh, guck mal.
Markus Lanz ist am Start.
Nur mit Delay-Stream, aber in DF.
Und die waren so viel mehr.
Da ist es auch wiederum egal.
Wenn wir die beim gescheiten Boss erwischt hätten,
vielleicht.
Wie soll man mit der Invasion anfangen?
Oh, das wäre nice.
Auf Real Invasion oder Realm Invasion,
da freue ich mich schon richtig drauf.
Und für uns sieht es gar nicht immer so schlecht aus,
nachdem wir gestern endlich mal die Glocke getroffen haben.
Und die ganzen Hips geklatscht haben.
Zumindest gestern Abend, da ich kurz in der BG war.
So, wo bin ich in meiner Epic stehen geblieben?
Zeig mal hier.
Ich muss nach Haggar.
Alles klar.
Ah, ich glaube, ich brauche nur noch zwei Steps für die Epic.
Easy. Nice.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, in 20 Minuten,
20, 30 Minuten durch.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Jemand aus der ...
Gilde am Start.
Ah.
Jetzt haben wir ...
Kann ich mal in Guild fragen,
ob irgendjemand Epic machen will.
Also.
Wir müssen ...
Final, denkst du, was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Get ...
Oh.
Die Skull Epic.
Gut, die kann ich als Heiler definitiv ...
Vielleicht kann ich die alleine machen.
Okay, das habe ich noch nie probiert,
ob ich die alleine machen kann.
Potenziell kann man die als Heiler wahrscheinlich alleine machen.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also, wenn man die als irgendeinen Char alleine machen kann,
dann als Heiler.
Epic bin ich dabei.
Ab Skull.
Ja, nice.
Auf geht's.
Der Rux macht mit.
Ach so, die sind auch in TG.
Okay, dauert noch zwei Minuten.
Wir haben noch einen aus Gilde, der mitmachen will.
Skull ist doch da, wo du bei den Morvalds das Item aufheben musst.
Korrekt.
Ich laufe schon mal hin.
Ich laufe schon mal hin und mache TP.
Hast du Solo hingekriegt als Shammy?
Als Shammy Solo stelle ich es mir schwierig,
weil die casten halt, wenn sie geroutet sind.
Als Heiler, ich glaube,
Heiler ist so ziemlich der einzige Char,
der das Solo machen kann.
Du kannst theoretisch einfach alle
dort sleepen und den Skull aufheben gehen
und schnell wieder abhauen.
Ich meine,
als Shammy würde ich sagen,
ist es theoretisch möglich Solo,
aber da brauchst du schon ein bisschen Glück,
dass sie nicht so schnell spawnen
und dass die an der richtigen Stelle laufen
und sowas.
Ich wollte nachher...
Wollte nach moderner...
So, Endo-Trunk.
Warum sehe ich meine Spells nicht?
Ah, Effekts.
Effekts all.
Ich habe mir die Effekte,
Zauber-Effekte ausgeschaltet.
Ja, ich muss meinen Heiler respecken.
Während ich dahin laufe
und auf meinen Gilden-Member warte,
dass der umlockt oder bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was er eigentlich machen will.
Müssen wir mal kurz in den Skill-Planer für heile.
Wir sind zufällig in der gleichen Gilde.
Nice.
Ich bin da auch erst gestern oder so,
oder vorgestern noch irgendwie so reingejoint,
weil ich mir gedacht habe,
ey, na super.
Okay, das ist halt auch so ein Ding,
als Heiler kannst du sogar vergessen.
Da musst du nicht ankommen.
Renn einfach weg.
Kannst eh nichts killen als Heiler.
Ja, ich bin da auch erst reingejoint,
weil ich mit einem Heiler von denen
öfters zusammen groope im RvR.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
ey, eine deutschsprachige Gilde wäre doch mal wieder was.
Auch wenn ich eigentlich von solchen Gilden
normalerweise nicht viel halte,
weil, muss ich erklären,
das ist eine Gilde, wo jeder inviten kann
und meistens läuft das nicht so gut.
Ich habe damit nicht so gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Aber die Leute machen bis jetzt echt ganz guten Eindruck.
Vor allem hat man doch immer ordentlich Leute on.
Ich meine, wir haben,
ja, wir haben,
ich weiß gar nicht, wo man das sieht.
Guck mal, ich meine, das ist montags morgens.
Wir haben zwei Seiten,
zwei Seiten voller Leute.
Naja, okay.
Nicht ganz zwei Seiten voller Leute.
Wir haben,
GCU kann man machen.
Laden wir den mal ein.
Und ich mache TP.
TP.
Du hast deine Season 1 Chars
noch nicht gelevelt?
Also es bietet sich an,
die Season 1 Chars in Season 2 weiterzuspielen,
weil du behältst deine RPs.
Zwar bist du immer noch an dem Limit
für RPs,
aber wenn du in Season 1 einen RR6-Char hattest,
ist der jetzt auch schon wieder,
sobald du 50 bist, RR5.
Das ist eigentlich mega, mega,
ich finde, das haben die richtig gut gemacht in Eden.
Also ich muss sagen, aus meiner Sicht ist Eden
der beste Server, den es bisher gegeben hat.
Eden macht vieles einfacher, was nervig war,
hat aber noch genug Wiederspielwert
und gerade dieser,
ja,
und das habe ich vergessen,
weil ich es sagen wollte.
Ja, also Eden hat jede Menge Verbesserungen.
Das hat es weiterhin mitgebracht,
ja, Wiederspielwert,
aber du hast halt
immer noch den Anreiz,
jede Season weiterzuspielen,
weil du deinen Char weiterspielen kannst
und die RPs behältst mit Limit,
dass du nicht Instant RR10s oder so hast.
So, da wollen wir mal.
Ach, guck mal, da machen das zwei andere auch gerade noch.
Da machen auch noch gerade zwei andere Epic.
Warte mal, ob die,
warte mal, ob die bei uns in Gruppe wollen.
Was ist denn das?
Valk und doppelt Valk, okay.
Okay.
Da kann ja nicht viel schief gehen.
Okay, ich entweite die mal, die anderen.
Das ist halt auch was, was ich in Daog mag.
Daog ist halt kein anonymes Dungeon-Finder-RPG
oder MMO.
Das finde ich halt richtig geil.
Let's go.
Final Trial, wir müssen Skullman.
Mit dem Team können wir fast,
wenn die hohen Chills back haben,
können wir theoretisch sogar Wasser machen.
Okay, die wollen killen.
Der Step ist mega easy.
Man muss bloß aufpassen.
Wenn man mehr als drei Gegner gleichzeitig aggro,
dann killen die einen.
Weil die super eklige Dots haben.
Ist der Rux 50 jetzt?
49,5 wahrscheinlich.
Ey, Vastrim ist kein Ding.
Ich hab, ich hab Vastrim, Vastrim, wie auch immer der heißt,
ich hab den als Skalde schon getankt, ey.
Okay, weiter.
Auf geht's, Leute.
Let's go.
Auf.
Hoppity-hopp.
Leute, ich bin kein Tank, ihr müsst da schon rein.
Okay, die haben keinen Bock.
Ich metz die jetzt einfach alle.
Auf geht's.
Okay, gut.
Auf.
Oh, der Rux hat LD.
Fuck.
Schlecht.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Let's go, Leute.
Okay.
Ey, Leute, ihr solltet mal ein paar Mobs killen,
anstatt hier sinnlos die Quest abzugreifen, ne?
Ich sag's ja nur.
Alter.
Diese, die Noobs, Mann.
Guckt's euch an.
Die sollen halt mal was killen,
anstatt einfach nur sinnlos rumzustehen.
Er hat's immer gefickt.
Nice.
Sehr gut.
Sehr schön.
Nice.
Tja, und die ticken, die Dots ticken nämlich bei jedem Ding und interrupten.
Oh, Gott, diese Leute immer.
Ich raste aus, Mann.
Wie scheiße kann man sein, Alter?
Die hätten die Mobs einfach nur einzeln killen müssen.
Mann, so schwer ist das doch nicht.
All got it.
Alter, die sind so dumm.
Die sind alles so dumm.
Ich fass es nicht.
Die sind alle so unfähig.
Die spielen das seit fucking 20 Jahren, Mann.
Die stehen einfach hin und killen nix.
Ich darf nix schreiben, sonst raste ich aus, ja.
Mann, wo ist das Problem?
Reingehen, Gegner killen und dann holen sich alle diesen komischen Skull und gut ist.
Aber ihr habt's gesehen.
Ich hätte es als Heiler...
Wir hätten es zu zweit machen sollen.
Zu zweit hätten wir es besser geschafft als zu viert, Mann.
So, mal gucken.
A, G, S, S, T, P.
Ey, wir hätten es echt zu zweit machen sollen.
Das war wieder echt ein Musterbeispiel von...
Man spielt das Spiel seit 20 Jahren, aber hat nix gecheckt, Alter.
Okay, hoffentlich stirbt Rux nicht.
Rux wird PR'd.
Okay, abregen, nochmal neu.
Easy.
Ey, wo ist Rux hin?
Rux ist weg.
Da ist er wieder.
So.
So, meine Quickbar ist halt auch ein bisschen verkackt.
Für PVM-Gedöns brauche ich kein Instant-CC.
Machen wir mal so.
Kann ich die Single matzen?
Auf geht's.
Moment, auf welcher Seite sind wir überhaupt?
Nee, wir sind hier schon richtig.
Auf geht's.
Sobald ihr anfangt zu dotten, hat man halt gelitten.
Einfach schön killen, eine Reihe nach.
By the way, ihr seid Nahkämpfer.
Ihr dürft ruhig dahin.
So, den da jetzt.
Geht doch.
Oh, next.
Auf.
Und der noch jetzt.
Die müssen gar nicht so viel Schiss davor haben.
Die können einfach rein und Damage machen.
Ist halt das Ding, als Nahkämpfer musst du halt ran, um Damage zu machen.
Okay, nice, next.
So, die hier hinten CC'en wir jetzt.
Okay, jetzt steht alles.
Und jetzt killen wir alles.
Einmal initial und dann ist easy.
So, und jetzt können wir das Ding aufheben.
In Combat, in Combat, in Combat, in Combat.
Please, lass mich.
Jawoll.
Ich hab's.
Okay, das darf man aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Wo ist das Viehchen?
Hallo?
Sichtlinie, please.
Jetzt muss der Rux noch hin.
Okay, let's go.
Wir haben's.
Final Epic.
Ding, Show Skull.
King Eric, okay.
Jetzt müssen wir zurück zum König.
Und dann geht das.
Gucken wir mal gleich, ob wir...
Oh, nee, shit.
Nix wie weg.
Die Viecher sind aus dem CC rausgekommen.
Okay, wenn wir sterben, ist nicht schlimm.
Ey, wenn wir sterben, ist nicht schlimm.
Wir haben die Quest fertig.
So, kann sich das Viech mal...
Kann das mal abhauen, please?
Ey, wetten.
Die lassen...
Die lassen mich hier und lassen mich jetzt verrecken.
Nice.
GG.
Best...
Beste Teammates überhaupt.
Ich verpiss mich jetzt.
Kann das...
Kann der Mob...
Kann der Mob sich mal bitte verpissen jetzt?
Was ist das hier?
Äh, jetzt.
Nice.
Okay.
Da.
Solche Heal und...
Und jetzt kann ich hoffentlich zurückporten.
Okay, wir müssen zum König.
Was denn?
Mach's gut.
Gu...
Gupa...
Gupagea.
Der Binde...
Der...
Der Bindpunkt hier ist sehr suboptimal.
Man muss immer doppelt porten.
Man portet ins Tutorial-Gebiet.
Portet in die Stadt.
Man muss immer doppelt porten.
Man portet ins Tutorial-Gebiet.
Portet in die Stadt.
Immer mit Ladescreen dazwischen.
Portet in den Thron... äh, Thronraum.
Und dann portet man raus.
Und portet wieder zu...
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja Ladezeiten des Thrones.
Ich versteh übrigens auch gar nicht, warum das Spiel so lange Ladezeiten hat.
Es ist uralt.
Also es gibt ne...
Es gibt wohl nen Bug in Verbindung mit Windows Defender, dass man dem Windows Defender Ausnahmen
eintragen muss.
Und...
Und das Ganze dann schneller lädt, weil der Windows Defender wieder Probleme macht.
Aber wer hätte...
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass der Windows Defender Probleme macht?
Aber ich wollte bisher noch nicht im Windows Defender irgendwelche Ausnahmen hinzufügen,
weil...
Theoretisch, dadurch, dass die nen eigenen Launcher haben, für den... für den Freeshot,
und wer weiß, wie sicher die ihre Software-Repos und sowas haben, wo alles herkommt und Updates
gezogen wird.
Nicht, dass der Launcher die Game-DLL austauscht durch irgendwas, weil irgendjemand nicht aufgepasst
hat.
Oder...
Zugangsdaten geleakt hat, was auch immer, und man sich irgendein Virus einfängt.
Und...
Sag ich mal.
Kann ja nicht...
Vorsichtig genug sein.
Okay.
Letzter Epic-Step.
Dann gibt's endlich die Rüstung.
Pog.
Also ich bin Heiler.
Damit geht das schonmal easy.
Ich hab auch genug Mana.
Mit Lagerfeuer.
Das Ding ist...
Dum-dum-dum-dum.
Ah geil, muss ich.
Das Ding ist...
Wir...
Könnten...
Also...
Theoretisch...
Theoretisch kann das ne...
Ne...
Schild...
Valk tanken, das Ding.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ne...
Level...
46er...
Mit Level-Gear...
Schild-Valk tanken kann.
Also vielleicht...
Suchen wir uns gleich noch ein paar...
Ich fang mal hier...
Ich frag mal im Chat, ob jemand sucht...
Ja...
Zwerge, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Ich weiß, ihr mögt mich nicht.
Oh!
So.
Und ist dort
Okay, was ist da?
Fuck
Fuck spinnt das fisch brutal die machen übelst damage. Ich hoffe ich hoffe okay. Ich habe noch mal ein instant am start
Muss auf jeden fall ich muss auf jeden fall rennen dass das ding nicht mich wieder an castet sobald mich das
bin doch nicht
Weil wir müssen übrigens darunter ich laufe gerade mega pepega
Mein nachname muss ich noch umbenennen pepega jeder jeder bescheid weiß
Will ich denn jetzt überhaupt im final step
go in wood slay was ram
Hier muss ich lang
Was ram was ram slain ich hoffe ich verpasse jetzt ich hoffe ich verpasse jetzt nicht
Den cl5 dungeon ich versuche nämlich gerade zwei sachen gleichzeitig zu machen einmal epic ist das hier oben
Ich würde gerne einmal epic machen das fisch spawnt hier irgendwo
einmal epic und
Dann cl54 wasser切 casserole ja
dort müssen wir killen dann ist die e epic vorbei
Wir können probieren ob ich das hin ich hab noch eine ich habe noch ein lager für extra
Wir müssen uns beagern
Dann wollen die dann starten
Auf leute macht hin uiler
Viele ob die 23 leute haben wir haben sie für die bg schon am start das reicht nicht die müssen noch mehr sammeln deswegen
Die Leute sollen mal hinmachen.
Die anderen disbanden nicht.
Da denkst du echt, die Leute haben noch nie das Spiel gespielt, Mann.
Wir haben es eilig.
Ich muss umlocken, Leute.
Ich muss umlocken.
Als haben die das Spiel noch nicht gespielt, Mann.
Die müssen disbanden.
Ich invite sie und gut ist, hast du früher auf Dartmoor gespielt.
Bei dem Namen klingelt irgendwas.
Nein, auf live hieß ich komplett anders.
Ich glaube, PogChamp hat sich damals auch keiner genannt, oder?
So, BGCounts.
23, okay.
Das andere startet nicht so wirklich.
Die kriegen es doch nicht auf die Reihe.
Ich frage mal kurz.
Von meinen Leuten sind keine da.
Okay, wir kriegen vielleicht noch ein paar Leute dabei.
Ah, wir kriegen einen Warrior.
Nice, dann ist es easy.
50er Warrior.
Jetzt ist die Sache geritzt.
Ah, damit packen wir das.
BGCounts.
Ich muss danach direkt umlocken, Leute.
Direkt.
Die anderen haben es noch nicht gecheckt.
So, invite, invite.
Wie hieß der andere Typ zum Inviten?
Okay, der andere hat es sogar ausgelockt.
Keine Ahnung, die haben es wieder nicht kapiert.
Alles klar.
Let's go.
Easy.
Ich sollte mir vielleicht mal einen ordentlichen Heal auf die Leiste ziehen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Mending.
Was habe ich denn da hier?
Sowas da vielleicht.
Irgendeinen Heal, wo ich nicht sofort mana-los bin.
Ach, easy haben wir doch gleich geschafft.
So, 26 Leute für Champion-Level-Dungeon.
Das reicht auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich müsste eigentlich einen relativ effizienten Level-33er-Heal haben.
Der hier, der ist gut, glaube ich.
Der braucht nicht viel Mana.
Ah, 75%.
Eats, eats, eats, eats.
Also ja, ich habe Dartmoor-Midgard mal was gespielt früher.
Hieß aber ganz anders.
Ich habe hauptsächlich Stonehenge-Albion gespielt.
Und?
Und Salisbury-Midgard.
Und dann später US-Classic-Server.
Midgard.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hieß da, ich hieß auf live komplett anders.
Damals gab es noch keine Twitch-Emotes.
Wie hieß du auf Dartmoor?
Vielleicht kenne ich dich ja noch von früher.
Falls du sagen willst.
Also ich halte mich da immer zurück mit meinen alten MF-Hundern.
Nee, sagt mir nix.
Sagt mir nichts.
Okay, Viech fast tot.
49%.
BG für CL5 hat 29.
Nice.
Das ist richtig gutes Timing.
Nahkampfhunter.
Ich glaube, das kannst du.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du Eden spielst.
Ich glaube, das kann man auf Eden sogar, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, sogar halbwegs spielen.
Aber am besten ist natürlich Kombination.
Aber das heißt, du stehst auf Schleicher-Klassen.
Ist ja überhaupt nicht meins.
Wenn es nach mir geht, könnten sie alle Schleicher rauspatchen aus dem Game.
Aber ich glaube wirklich gut, funzt das nicht.
Aber ich kenne mich, also ich kenne mich mit Schleicher auch echt nicht aus.
Hat mich nie interessiert.
Okay.
Die wollen 55 los.
Was ein perfektes Timing, Leute.
Epic mit Heiler fertig.
Die wollen 55 los für den CL5-Dungeon.
Bis dahin habe ich sogar noch die Epic abgeholt beim König mit dem Heiler.
Exzellent, exzellent.
24% das Viech.
Früher konnte man auch Solo schleichen.
Das kannst du ziemlich, also du kannst immer noch so, aber es ist halt enorm viel los.
Gerade an den Hotspots triffst du dann immer irgendwelche 10er-Schleicher-Gruppen und sowas.
Die treten da immer in geballter Ladung auf.
So, wir haben es geschafft.
Epic fertig.
Jetzt gibt es eine ordentliche Rüstung.
So, ist die Epic jetzt auch wirklich...
Ask the King for your Reward.
Nice.
So, genug Platz im Inventar haben wir auch.
Exzellent.
Dann suche ich jetzt ja gleich mal für den Huni eine Gruppe.
Ich muss mit dem Huni glaube ich noch zum König vorher und die...
Chat, kann ich euch nicht erinnern, war ich mit dem Huni schon beim König und habe die 15er-Quests abgeholt?
Ich glaube nicht.
Da muss ich mich beeilen.
55 wollen die los.
CL5-Dungeon is banned.
Okay, machen wir uns das jetzt mal schnell.
Zack.
Okay, Rüstung.
Inventar-Space ist genug.
Finish.
Okay.
BG-Leader?
Ne, wer hat das?
Zug?
Zug oder so?
Zug.
Alles klar.
55 wollen die los.
Achso, ja, passt mal auf hier.
Guck mal.
Jetzt sehe ich mit der Rüstung nicht mal ganz so verkackt aus.
Also die hier ist es nicht.
Guck mal.
Healer-Epic-Rüstung.
Zack.
Hut lasse ich mal weg.
Zack, zack, zack.
Sieht doch schon gleich ein bisschen besser aus, oder?
War ganz so verkackt.
CRM-LFG.
Ich logge mal kurz um.
So, ich muss jetzt auf den Huni umloggen und ganz schnell zum, zum Dungeon flitzen.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, ob ich vorher zum King muss oder nicht.
Realm Calls, das ist die Epic.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich habe noch vier Minuten Zeit.
Wie kommt das?
So, machen wir mal hier den LFG-Spam.
Ich brauche nicht unbedingt eine Gruppe für CL5.
Aber wenn ich nicht in Gruppe bin für CL5, muss ich auf jeden Fall gucken, dass Hulu.
Hulu macht eine Gruppe auf.
Besser, Mann, Hulu.
Ah, wir haben sogar einen Port.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Wahrscheinlich Mulan.
Alle haben ihren Port, Mulan.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich noch zum König muss vorher.
Unschlüssig.
Mulan coming.
Ab, okay.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich die annehmen kann.
Wenn ich die annehmen kann, wenn ich die annehmen kann, dann sehe ich das gleich bei den Quests.
Wenn nicht, muss ich mich sehr stark sputen.
Dann muss ich noch zum König mit dem schwätzen.
Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, es geht mit 50 einfach so.
Sehen wir gleich.
So, da ist die erste.
Ah, nice.
Okay.
Except.
Sehr schön.
Wir haben keinerlei Heals.
Wir haben kein...
Okay, das ist, das ist ja ein Group-Setup, Mann.
Donnerkrieger, Skalde, Rune-Meister, Shadowplate, Rune-Meister, Savage.
Okay, das ist echt super mieses Group-Setup.
Aber ich will mich mal nicht beschweren auf der anderen Seite.
Nicht wild.
Wir dürfen einfach kein Damage nehmen.
Einfach, einfach kein Damage.
Easy.
Just, just don't take damage.
Okay, ich kann meinen Koop-BT anmachen.
Dann habe ich Glück und wir nehmen ein bisschen, aber vielleicht Glück, wir nehmen ein bisschen weniger Damage.
Ist das, ist das überhaupt?
Moment, ist das überhaupt Koop?
Schon?
Runes.
Level.
26.
Absorbs the damage of a single.
Geht das automatisch wieder?
Ja, Pulse.
Hier, Pulse.
Sollte jetzt eigentlich wiederkommen.
Klar.
Pulse, BT.
Ja.
Ja, ja, Funst.
Okay.
Ähm, das ist eigentlich ein mega nicer, mega nicer Support, Support-Spell.
Man bekommt ein Schild, was einen Nahkampftreffer absorbiert.
Was sich alle 10 Sekunden wieder automatisch, oder, ich glaube, es ist, glaube ich, alle 5 Sekunden sogar.
Oder alle, alle, alle 5 und in die 10 Sekunden ist es.
Alle 10 Sekunden automatisch refreshed.
Das ist, das ersetzt zwar keinen Heiler.
Ist aber sehr praktisch.
Gerade bei High-Level-Mobs, die richtig.
Hart-Hitten.
Okay.
Check.
Jetzt wird's langweilig, aber glücklicherweise nicht lang.
So für eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten.
Wir müssen jetzt durch den Dungeon durchzergen.
Alles schön.
AE.
Anhitten.
Auf Diamonds and Demons.
Die Quest kann ich hier auch erledigen.
Muss mal alles, alles taggen, alles an.
Anhitten, was geht.
Los.
Das war richtig gutes Timing.
Erst.
Die Heiler-Epic.
Und jetzt direkt CL5 mit dem Huni.
Dann brauche ich eigentlich nur noch die Epic mit dem Huni machen.
Also quasi das, was wir gerade gemacht haben, nochmal mit dem Huni.
Und, ähm.
Ah, da ist Offline.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Wie süblich.
Dark PVM.
Ziemlich easy.
Einfach hinstellen.
AE-Spam.
So.
Jetzt mache ich das, was der Huni am besten macht.
Was der Huni am besten kann.
Einen Knopf drücken.
Für drei Stunden am Stück.
Bam.
Easy.
Mehr mache ich jetzt nicht.
Und schon Instant Win.
Oh.
Boah, ich muss die Effekte ausmachen.
Wirklich epileptische Anfälle.
Wobei, ich lasse die Effekte an, das ist für euch netter zuzugucken.
Gut.
Unser Shadow Blade hat es ein bisschen verkackt.
Der ist zu spät.
Der kommt jetzt nicht mehr rein.
Weil du kannst.
Ist auch sowas, was es auf Live-Dog nicht gibt.
Du kannst Town-Portals und Bin-Stone-Porten.
So.
Gibt es den Dog nicht.
Normalerweise.
Und man kann diese Town-Portals allerdings nur verwenden, wenn die Gruppe nicht im Fight ist.
Und wir sind gerade im Fight.
Dementsprechend kann unsere Shadow Blade da nicht mehr reinporten.
Und spätestens, wenn wir den ersten Boss gelegt haben, macht es auch überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr hier rein zu porten.
The King's Champion.
Hier.
Das ist die Quest.
Genau.
Oh.
AE.
Ich brauch.
Brauch.
Brauch Mobs.
Hiervon.
Jawoll.
Ähm.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht in den Chat geguckt.
Das Schleichen finde ich auf jeden aktuell sehr anstrengend.
E-Devs, die Schleicher-Zacks unterbinden wollen, können dann und alle Klassen, die nicht schleichen können, die Schleicher leichter entdecken.
Oh.
Da finde ich gut.
Ha.
Wenn du mich fragst, bin ich sofort dabei.
Sobald du in einem Einhand-Radius bist.
Vorbeilaufs-Kanzel.
Ja.
Das ist mir tatsächlich auch schon aufgefallen.
Ich habe schon, also gerade auf Eden habe ich erstaunlich viele Schleicher schon aus dem Stealth rausgekloppt, weil ich den gesehen habe.
Gerade, wenn man mit der Gruppe durchläuft, dann, äh, einer der Group sieht eigentlich immer irgendeinen Schleicher, wenn man durch Engpässe durchläuft.
Ja.
Glücklicherweise sind die meisten Leute halb AFK in Gruppen.
Und machen nix.
Ja, aber das ist mir auf Eden auch schon aufgefallen, ja.
Ja.
Wenn du mich fragst, ich mag Schleicher überhaupt nicht.
Und alles, was die machen um Schleicher.
Abzufacken, ist mir recht.
Ich verstehe natürlich, dass es kacke ist, wenn man selbst gerne Schleicher spielt.
Dass man das dann nicht so geil findet.
Für mich ist das gut.
Ich, alles, alles, was Stealth irgendwie nervt oder schlechter macht, ist mir recht.
Zumal, gerade Assassins auf Eden ziemlich OP sind, wenn man, wenn man denn, muss man dazu sagen, wenn man den Auto-Hotkey benutzt, und Auto-Hotkey ist nicht verboten.
Auto-Hotkey macht Assassins ziemlich OP.
Du kannst quasi jede, jeden Schlag neu verändern.
Neue vergiften die Waffe.
Normalerweise konntest du als Assassin Gift auf deine Waffen machen und dann hast du halt einmal geschlagen, da wurde das Gift angewandt und gut ist.
Und du kannst quasi jetzt mit Auto-Hotkey kannst du Gifte rotieren aus dem Inventar raus.
Was richtig krass ist.
Also du kannst gefühlt kaum noch One-on-One gegen ne, gegen einen Schleicher gewinnen.
Oh, ich spamm jetzt einfach AE und gut ist.
Wie sehr eigentlich meine, ach Quatsch, ich habe ja hier gar keine Epic.
Die Epic muss ich ja gleich noch machen.
Auch mit dem Huni.
Ja, das wird tatsächlich cool, wenn du bei LD noch die, noch die Credits bekommen könntest.
Wobei das oftmals funktioniert, jetzt schon.
Weil du halt bei LD noch bis zu 20 Sekunden teilweise in Game bist.
Und wenn der Boss halt dann umkippt, dann kriegst du den Credit noch.
Wenn du halt gerade draußen bist, hast du Pech.
Das haben sie ja bei, das bei Relikten haben sie das übrigens auf Eden schon gemacht.
Wenn du bei einem Relikt-Rate dabei bist und du bist in der Zone zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das Relikt aufgehoben wird.
Dann hast du den.
Dann kriegst du den Credit beim Einlösen.
Egal ob du zwischendurch LD hast oder nicht.
Finde ich eins ganz gut.
Exzellent sozusagen.
Brauche ich hier, brauche ich hier noch welche?
Erstmal, ich, ich hitte einfach mal alles an, was es hier gibt.
Ja, davon brauche ich noch welche.
Vier von zehn, fünf von zehn.
Next.
Go, go, go.
Ich will hier nicht länger drinnen bleiben, als es notwendig ist.
Ah.
Daog PVE ist immer so müdend.
Oh nein, die Mobs brauche ich auch noch.
Weiß.
Also wer anspruchsvolles PVE in Daog machen will, es gibt ein paar Sachen auf Eden, die man semi-anspruchsvoll nennen könnte.
Das erste ist Sobekeit oder wie auch immer man das genau ausspricht.
Mit 8er Group, das ist tatsächlich eine der wenigsten Instanzen, die es gibt.
PVM-Instanzen.
Das reine Group-Content kannst du gar nicht mit mehr rein.
Wobei, wenn man es ein paar mal gemacht hat, der Anspruch sich in Grenzen hält.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht Brain-AFK und Durchzerren.
Dann kannst du die ein oder anderen Thor-Encounter machen.
Die allerdings nur Skins bringen auf Eden, sonst nichts.
Ich glaube, ich glaube.
Im eigenen Realm kannst du die Shape-Shift-Effekte noch benutzen.
Davon.
Aber ansonsten sind Artefakte und sowas reine.
Guckt es euch an! Guckt es euch an, wie sie in die falsche Richtung laufen!
Guckt es euch an!
Meine Güte, Alter, die Leute sind so...
Jetzt mal ehrlich, ne?
Ich habe es heute schon fünfmal gesagt.
Viele Leute spielen das 20 Jahre.
Und checken immer noch nichts.
Es ist unglaublich.
Teilweise.
In Dark ist es halt echt so, wenn du dich auf andere Spieler verlassen musst,
die nicht zu deiner Gruppe gehören, mit denen du öfters spielst,
oder von denen du weißt, dass die was taugen,
dann bist du, bist du Verlassener.
Wie man eben, wie man eben bei dem Epic-Step eindrucksvoll gesehen hat.
Ich CC alles als Heiler selbst.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Und die Nahkämpfer stehen halt drinnen und denken sich so,
ach nee, ich mache mal kurz meine Quest-Objective und renne wieder raus.
Haha.
Also hier haben wir noch verschiedene Tasten, alle sind...
Hab ich die schon?
Warte mal hier kurz.
Darkness Falls Explorer...
Ich hab...
Okay, Umbrut Warrior brauchen wir.
Crawler und Hikes brauche ich noch.
He és Crawler...
Überschaubar!
Ach nee, das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Da habe ich 10 von 10.
Alles gut.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaub, da kommen gleich nur welche.
Ja, Hikes kommen immer noch.
Kommen immer noch.
Auto-Hotkey ist so eine strittige Sache.
Ich verwende es auch nicht.
Aber ich werde es verwenden.
Sobald ich einen Anwendungsfall für habe, wo ich sage, ey, damit würde es wirklich deutlich einfacher zu spielen oder effektiver zu spielen.
Zum Beispiel, für meinen Heiler werde ich es wahrscheinlich benutzen.
Ich meine, wenn du das Spiel nicht gecheckt hast und ich weiß, was du wie wo machen musst, bringt dir Auto-Hotkey auch nichts.
Also es ist ein heiß diskutiertes Thema.
Für manch einen ist es Cheaten, für manch einen ist es quasi Next Level Dark Skills, wie auch immer.
Ah, fuck, die Viecher brauche ich.
Ach Gott, hat mal wieder keiner Aed.
Also beim Heiler werde ich es auf jeden Fall benutzen.
Zumindest werde ich es ausprobieren, ob ich es auf jeden Fall benutzen werde.
Am Ende war es zweimal hingestellt.
Wäre jetzt auch fast falsch gerannt.
Mit Absicht, um die Mobs hier zu bauten.
Ah, hier, jetzt.
Ah, eh.
Geh wie.
Jawoll.
Schön gesperrt.
Beim Heiler kannst du nämlich wirklich coole Sachen machen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel Single-Mats und D-Mats auf eine Taste legen.
Was Quick-Bars spart, Cubines spart, Platz spart.
Und sehr angenehm ist.
Okay, habe ich jetzt 10 von 10?
Nein.
Einer hat resisted, okay.
Ah, da vorne.
Nein, nein.
Leute, wenn meine Gruppe ja nicht komplett AFK wäre, dann könnten wir da vorne jetzt reintanken.
10 Sekunden.
Okay, please, please, nicht pullen, nicht pullen.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1 und frei.
Let's go.
Ah, super, haben wir nichts abgekriegt.
Doch, 10 von 10.
Aber unser Scham hier hat es gepackt.
Ja, es ist halt erlaubt.
Und dadurch, dass es erlaubt ist, kann man halt auch nicht sagen, es wäre gecheatet.
Ich kenne die Diskussion.
Für viele ist es ja tatsächlich sowas wie gecheatet, aber ich denke mir, hey, es ist erlaubt.
Was nicht erlaubt ist, sind Schleifen in Auto-Hotkey.
Also du kannst beispielsweise nicht sagen, ich switche meine Auren und Songs immer wieder durch.
Was ich aber eh für total unsinnig halte.
Selbst wenn das erlaubt wäre, würde ich es nicht machen.
Weil du bekommst, also selbst mit maximaler Duration auf deine Songs, glaube ich, kannst du nicht alle Songs abhaben.
Deswegen macht man einfach die Songs an, die passen gerade.
So, und fertig.
Du brauchst gar nicht alle Songs.
Also entweder, gerade wenn man Skaldes spielt, du hast immer Speed an plus X.
So, X ist in der Regel defaultmäßig Damage Add.
Oder bei einem längeren Fight Mana oder, oh, die Krabbler.
Krabbler brauche ich unbedingt.
Krabbler müssen Aed werden.
Jawohl, schön reinsperren hier.
Nice.
Ja, also entweder lässt du Mana laufen.
Oder Damage Add, Default oder Resist.
So war es eigentlich.
Rest braucht man selten.
Dafür würde ich kein Auto-Hotkey benutzen.
Selbst wenn es sinnvoll wäre.
Also selbst wenn man es machen könnte.
Selbst wenn es erlaubt wäre mit Schleife, würde ich es nicht machen.
Weil ich glaube, selbst wie gesagt mit Max Spell Duration kriegst du nicht alle Songs permanent ab.
Und das ist dann irgendwie auch sinnlos.
Weil was bringt es dann?
Dafür kann man andere nette Sachen machen.
Also wie gesagt, gerade auf Supportern, die Tasten doppelt belegen, finde ich sehr praktisch.
Dass du beispielsweise, sagen wir mal jetzt Single-Target-Sleep und D-Match auf eine Taste legst.
Da kannst du nämlich entweder, sagen wir mal auf 2, dann kannst du den Typ anklicken und 2 drücken.
Dann wird der D-Match und du klickst den Gegner an, drückst 2 und dann wird gematcht.
Das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Und nachdem man da im Prinzip immer noch alles selbst machen muss, finde ich das gar nicht so verwerflich.
Also ich werde es mir auf dem Heiler angucken und wahrscheinlich werde ich es auf dem Heiler auch verwenden.
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich aus Versehen gefühlt hier die...
Den halben Raum gerade aeht habe und wir haben keinen Heiler bei uns in der Group?
Ah, nix wie weg.
Nix wie fort.
Ich halte mich mal ein bisschen zurück.
Ich will das hier nicht abkratzen.
Wir haben nur einen Chammy.
Chammys können zwar nicht schlecht heilen, aber gerade großartigen Burst-Damage auf die komplette Group sind Chammys jetzt nicht die besten Heiler.
Ja, für Nahkampfangriffe ist auch...
...die Outdoor-Hotkey genau für diese eine Sache sinnvoll für Backup-Styles, ohne die Backup-Style-Funktionalität im Game benutzen zu müssen.
Alles mit einer Taste, ja, dass du mit einer Taste quasi Side-Stun, Any-Timer machen kannst.
Und ganz ehrlich, würde ich das machen?
Also hätte ich einen Char, wo das sehr sinnvoll ist, ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch benutzen.
Aber das ist das einzige, was du mit Nahkampf-Chars machen kannst.
Aber schon...
Ist schon...
Man kann das alles auch von Hand machen.
Es ist nicht so, als dass das irgendwie großartig...
Was...
Was bringt das?
Der könnte genauso gut einfach zwei Tasten jedes Mal drücken.
Au.
Ist ein...
Also in der DAO-Community schon lange Zeit recht umstrittenes Thema.
Ich denke, auf ihn ist die Frage halt...
Ja...
Eher...
Eher eine persönliche, so...
Will man es selbst benutzen, oder...
Ist da für einen persönlich die Grenze überschritten, weil...
Äh...
Überschritten, weil offiziell ist es ganz einfach.
Offiziell ist Outdoor-Hotkey erlaubt.
Und...
Solange du keine Schleifen machst.
So, wo ist Hulu?
Hululul.
Hul...
Wie heißt der Typ?
Hululu.
Besser.
Guck mal.
Richtig...
Echter...
Malaka.
Auf Live-Servern ist es nicht erlaubt.
Sicher?
Okay.
Auf Live-Servern ist es die typische...
Typische Sache.
Es steht...
In den Bedingungen drinne wahrscheinlich.
Man darf keine...
Makro-Programme benutzen.
Aber sie werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht eingebannt haben auf Live, weil er Makro-Programme benutzt.
Die...
Man kann jetzt davon abziehen.
Auf Live...
Jeden, den die aktuell auf Live bannen...
Ist...
Geldverlust so.
Und die machen mit Daok eh schon immer viel Geld.
Wahrscheinlich bannen die auf Live einfach gar keinen mehr.
Selbst Radar...
Selbst detektete Radar-User werden wahrscheinlich auf Live nicht mehr gebannt, weil es Geld kostet.
Generell hat Daok halt auch keine Anti-Cheat-Erkennung.
Du kannst das nur selber-seitig feststellen, dass irgendwas halt passiert, was normalerweise so mit einem normalen Client...
Nicht möglich ist.
Weiter geht's.
So.
Läufte haben wir durch, Leute.
Nur noch...
Nur noch circa...
Viertelstunde Resident Sleeper.
Bis der Raid vorbei ist.
Aber dann bin ich CL5.
Bedeutet als nächstes...
Ich guck mir mal nebenbei...
Jetzt...
Jetzt sind wir mal...
Jetzt sind wir mal mutig.
Ich sticke mal...
Hulu Malaka.
Und gucke mal kurz in meinen Char-Planer für den Heiler rein.
In der Hoffnung.
Ich finde ne gute BG-Spec.
Achso.
Habe ich überhaupt alle Quests mittlerweile?
Ein Hulk.
Und drei Crew.
Und drei Crawler.
Okay.
Ich muss da noch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Wir machen erstmal die Quest voll, bevor ich Char-Planer gucke.
Das habe ich alles.
Habe ich alles.
Weil ich traue meinem restlichen Team nicht zu, die Mobs zu tanken.
Crawler...
Crawler gibt's auf jeden Fall vor Legion.
Und Hulks müsste es gleich beim nächsten Boss geben.
Also.
Ich habe mir überlegt...
Das wäre mal was für Stream.
Portal Revolution.
Portal Revolution erscheint nach Freigabe durch...
Ach ja.
Ach das ist...
Ich habe schon gedacht, sie hätten es wirklich geschafft mal einen dritten Teil zu produzieren.
Aber das ist ein Mod.
Aber gerade im Half-Life Universum gibt es enorm viele gute Mods.
Guckt euch Black Mesa an.
So ist es offiziell, dass die Community...
Nice.
Da hätte ich echt Bock drauf auf einen Portal-Mod.
Zack.
Wenn es ein Community-Mod ist...
Will...
Eigentlich...
Wisst ihr was?
Was 2024...
Wisst ihr was mega geil ist?
Die werden sicherlich nicht die Sprecherin von Klaados bekommen haben.
Aber durch AI kannst du heutzutage wahrscheinlich, ohne dass du den Sprecher dafür brauchst und
die Sprecherin dafür brauchst, das fast zu 99% original nachmachen.
Die haben das bestimmt mit AI-Klaados-Stimme.
Oh Hulks.
Hulks.
Ja, 10 von 10.
Nice.
Jetzt fehlen mir nur noch 3 Crawler.
Müssen wir mal gucken, dass ich vor Legion alles tagge.
Hulks da drüben?
Ja.
Ich guck mir den Mod mal an.
Ich kopier mir das mal rüber.
Habt ihr übrigens schon gehört?
Nicht so Poggers Bahnstreik ab Mittwoch und ich muss Mittwoch nach Frankfurt.
Mal gucken.
Es könnte auch sein, dass mein Chef sagt, wir verschieben das alles.
Wir müssen den Boss da drüben killen, Leute.
Wo rennt ihr denn hin?
Wo ist denn der BG Leader?
Ist der auch hier lang gerannt?
Wo ist der BG Leader?
Oh, Crawler.
Crawler.
Nice.
Okay.
Ein Crawler.
Einer weniger.
Wir müssen den Boss da aber noch killen jetzt.
Crawler.
Schnell.
Ae.
9 von 10.
Und?
Und 10 von 10.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
10 von 10.
Jawoll.
Quest fertig.
Nice.
Excellent.
Wir haben aber den Boss vergessen und zwar, wo ist die Quest?
Ne.
Boah Mann, ich bin King's Champion.
Den haben wir nicht gekillt.
Wir müssen nochmal zurück und den Boss killen.
Aber wie ist es denn rechtlich, wenn die Stimme AI generiert ist?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber nachdem Valve das erlaubt hat, ist es zumindest Copyright-technisch, was Half-Life
und Portal angeht kein Problem.
Ich bin ehrlich.
Ich bin rauchviau.
anderen leuten kopieren darf und ob mein urheberrecht an seiner eigenen stimme
hat weiß ich nicht man würde so spontan sagen ja sicherlich aber das ist ja
alles immer nicht so einfach da hinten kommt der boss der wird jetzt kurz
angebotet und dann verpiss ich mich ich habe der mensch gemacht jetzt alles gut
auch auf mich an zu karsten kattenhub wo willst du hin gehst du weg was soll das
jetzt mal seriously was soll das überhaupt sein was was was sehe ich hier
überhaupt was ist das was ist das was sehe ich hier also ich sehe vor lauter
effekten schon mal nicht so viel aber was soll das für ein fisch überhaupt
sein ich kann das nicht zuordnen
was ist das hatten die hatten die die grafik designer kein bock oder ich
erkenne es nicht hat jemand eine idee warum edgar tom keine werbung blockiert
obwohl diese eingeschaltet ist blocklisten
kommen Smartphone ist teilweise schwierig smartphones umgehen oftmals
dann den dns der von dhcp zugewiesen wird und dann funktioniert das wird
denn dein dein der cp überhaupt verwendet er überhaupt deinen dein edgard
als dns server kannst und sonst geht es natürlich nicht und viele seiten sind
mittlerweile auch pfeify fett und lassen sich nicht mehr
so ausbe unintentional ansatzي
tricksen so einfach mit dns blogging dns blogging lässt sich ja nur mit dns blogging lässt sich ja
nur werbung umgehen wenn werbung und content von unterschiedlichen servern kommen also wenn du so
ein bekanntes adnetzwerk verwendest und das ist geblockt okay dann geht das aber dazu muss zwingend
der dns verwendet werden der adblocker dns benutzt werden als dns und es muss halt was sein was über
ein bekanntes adnetzwerk ausgeliefert wird oder zumindest von der anderen domain sein als der
content den du sehen willst sonst funktioniert es nicht und wahrscheinlich ist auf den seiten
wo es bei dir nicht funktioniert das nicht gegeben ach so dann weiß ich auch nicht ka wie man so
online so schön sagt dann weiß ich nicht du kannst in den logs gucken von deinem adguard ob das
überhaupt dns request bekommt muss man ja nachvollziehen
können ob rege lasst diesen raid soon over sein wie ich nicht mal in der lage bin normale deutsche
sätze zu formen mittlerweile lasst diesen was heißt denn raid überhaupt was ist ein mmo raid
was ist denn das auf deutsch ein ein feldzug oder sowas könnte man vielleicht sagen aber
es trifft sich so genau was heißt was raid shadow legends
raid auf deutsch überfall also um das jetzt mal auf deutsch zu sagen bitte lasst diesen überfall bald
vorbei sein klingt aber erstens total falsch und zweitens trifft es den sinn auch nicht laut kugel
razzia lasst diese razzia bald vorbei sein also ich würde es eher als feldzug oder so übersetzen
dass das hat noch ein bisschen mehr
den ursprünglichen sinn bleibt noch ein bisschen mehr erhalten schlachtzug schlachtzug ist auch gut
jaja ich ist da war ich mit feldzug doch gar nicht so weit vorbei wenn wo das das schlachtzug nennt
dann ist gut dass mmo auch audio ja ich hab's leise gemacht hört man nichts mehr vor den sounds ich
hab's leise gemacht weil die sounds mich nerven man müsste noch ein bisschen mehr
was hören im hintergrund ja dass man nichts hört ich muss ich ich checke das jetzt gerade mal auf
meinem handy bisschen was hören müsste man eigentlich doch klar hört man hört man ich
hab's extra gerade um handy gecheckt das hat auch sound aber auf auf hier so einem bg raid
hörst nicht viel außer sinnlose zaubersounds im hintergrund guck du hörst zum beispiel wenn ich
meine bowls kaste das hörst du hier da macht so ein feuergeräusch
aber ich habe die sounds absichtlich leise weil die dark sound sind davon 2001 es gibt
lustige habe ich letztens schon sehr lustiges story wie die sounds überhaupt zustande gekommen
sind in dem game das war wie gesagt das spiel wurde 2001 oder 2000 2001 entwickelt mit relativ enger debtline also das ursprüngliche kern des games und
damals gab es ja noch keine stockfotoseiten und uns sound
AI-Generated-Sounds und sowas
und die hatten halt das Problem, dass
die Sounds gebraucht haben für Gegner und
Effekte und so in dem Spiel und da haben die
sich damals Stock-Audio-CDs
gekauft und
deswegen hören sich viele Sounds in dem Spiel auch so
falsch an, weil die halt irgendwelche Sounds
nehmen mussten, die auf diesen Stock-Audio-CDs
drauf waren. Ja, da hattest
du dann, ehrlich gesagt, ich persönlich
kenne so CDs nicht mehr,
aber da hattest du halt so die Random-Sounds
schlechthin drauf, so, keine Ahnung,
sagen, äh,
Lama
scheißt auf
Baumstumpf oder so, weiß weiß ich, was man
da für, was man da für Sounds auf so einer
Stock-Audio-CD drauf hat und
die Sounds haben die im Endeffekt für das Game genommen.
Später haben die es natürlich ein bisschen verbessert,
aber viele der alten Sounds sind da halt noch
drauf und das
sind zum Großteil, am Anfang
waren das Sounds, deswegen,
ihr müsst euch die Mob-Sounds teilweise anhören.
Brrr, brrr, brrr.
Also entweder
haben das irgendwelche
Leute dort selbst ganz schlecht
mit schlechtem Audio-Equipment
gemacht oder es sind halt wirklich
noch Sounds von diesen Stock-Audio-CDs.
Next.
Wie viele, wie viele
Sachen müssen wir, ich hab ja gesagt, es dauert nur
eine Viertelstunde, aber wir sind lahm.
Äh, wir brauchen noch,
ja, wir brauchen
noch einen Boss und dann
den Final Boss, okay.
Ja, sag mal so, vielleicht
fünf bis zehn Minuten,
dann ist das endlich durch.
Die Nachvertonung im Film ist ja noch was anderes,
das ist ja quasi so eine, fast schon eine
Wissenschaft für sich.
Vieles, was man, du hast schon recht, vieles, was man
im Film sieht, ist
überhaupt nicht das, was man hört, ja.
Also wenn du da beispielsweise
irgendjemand im Film siehst, der sich
gerade einen Anzug anzieht
und du diesen Sound hörst
dabei, dann ist das nicht unbedingt das Sound
vom Anzug, den der sich anzieht, sondern Leute,
die das halt so nachvertont haben mit Sounds, die
sich halt besser anhören, als
der Anzug sich wirklich anhört.
Gefühlt lauft der die ganze Zeit im Kreis, alles
sieht gleich aus. Das liegt daran,
dass alles gleich aussieht und wir
tatsächlich im Kreis laufen. Guck dir das mal an.
Wir haben hier unten angefangen
und sind einmal im Kreis gelaufen
und laufen jetzt hier wieder, wir haben jetzt
einen Kreis gelaufen und jetzt
laufen wir hier zum Final Boss und dann ist es vorbei.
Ja, aber du hast recht.
Ersten sieht alles gleich aus und zweiten
sieht es nicht nur gleich aus, sondern wir laufen auch im Kreis.
Der Dungeon ist ja nicht
groß. Da sind ja im Prinzip hier nur
ja so ein größerer,
ein größerer Ring quasi und
dann hier der, hier in der Mitte der
Gang unten. Sobald wir
den Kreiselgrind
verlassen, wirst du auch sehen, sieht es anders aus.
Das ist doppelt verwirrend, ja.
Es sieht alles gleich aus und wir laufen im
Kreis. Aber sobald wir den
Kreislauf
verlassen, wirst du sehen, es sieht auch
ein bisschen anders aus.
Guck, hier hast du die
Bossräume immer. Das ist halt so ein Kreis.
Uns fehlt jetzt noch der hier,
der mit dem super
easy auszusprechenden Namen
Farbjotr.
Danach kommt der nächste Dungeon.
Ne, glücklicherweise nicht.
Ich glaub, damit, ich glaub, dann war's das mit Dungeon
erstmal. Danach muss ich, muss ich
die
die Frontier Steps
für die Huni-Epic machen.
Dann nochmal die letzten zwei Epic Steps,
die wir eben schon mit dem Heiler gemacht haben.
Da muss ich nochmal schnell den Chartplaner für den
Heiler gucken. Ich muss ein Template
für den Huni raussuchen, dass ich heute Abend
gescheit spielen kann damit.
Ich meine, ich hab genug
Currency, ich kann einfach alles an Items kaufen.
Und ich hoffe,
dass mal noch ein paar Leute an den Start kommen, dass wir
noch ein bisschen LVR machen können.
Aber gerade
sind keine Leute da.
Ich hab gerade extra nochmal ins Discord geguckt.
Kein Bock auf TG.
Wer ist gerade TG?
Das halte ich jetzt nicht aus.
Nochmal ein TG-Rate hinten drauf.
Außerdem
hab ich keinen Charmeiter, der das braucht. Ich hab mehr
als genug Currency.
Den jetzt hier zu
equippen. Und den Heiler zu
equippen. Wobei der Heiler, da kann er eh keine 50er
Items anziehen. Der bleibt ja 49.5.
So, hier. Boss killen, please.
Man sieht von dem Boss
noch nicht mal was. Wo ist er denn hier? Da, da ist er.
Hey, okay, da erkenne ich jetzt sogar, was es sein
soll.
Das ist irgendein
Viech.
Okay, ich erkenne nicht, was es sein
soll. Irgendein Viech.
Und es heißt Fabjordre.
Alles klar.
Es muss, letztendlich
ist es auch wurscht, weil
das hat keine Story hier oder sowas. Wobei,
streng genommen hat es eine Story, aber ich
hab keine Ahnung.
Es muss gebasht werden, dafür
dass ich gleich 5 Champion-Levels bekomme.
Das ist das Wichtige dabei.
Der Rest ist mir egal.
Theoretisch hat es sogar eine Story.
Aber ich kenne niemanden, der die
Story kennt, weil in Dark
niemand Quests liest.
Und auf Eden
glaube ich, die meisten Sachen gar keine
Quest-Texte haben.
Ja.
Aber selbst auf Live, niemand liest die Story.
Oh,
mannala.
Wird das für die Nostalgie gespielt? Ne, das wird
für PvP gespielt.
Das ist das beste Game, was es
gibt. Das beste MMO, wenn man PvP
spielt. Es gibt kein besseres,
aus meiner Sicht. Und das, obwohl
es 20 Jahre alt ist. 23 Jahre alt ist.
Ah,
22 Jahre alt ist.
Ey, ich hab nie Quest-Texte gelesen.
Ich hab nie Quest-Texte
gelesen.
Selbst auf Live nicht. Warum?
Weil es schon mal eine Sache hat,
die sonst kein
mir bekanntes
anderes MMO hat,
beziehungsweise so gut macht.
Nämlich,
ihr werdet vielleicht Parallelen
zu Elder Scrolls Online erkennen, wenn ich euch
das jetzt erzähle. Weil du drei
verschiedene Reiche hast,
du hast einmal dieses
Reich hier mit dem Baum, einmal die mit dem Hammer
und einmal mit diesem Kelch.
Ich spiele in
Midgard, das sind die mit dem Hammer.
Das ist quasi so an nordische Mythologie
und Wikinger und Gedöns angelegt,
äh, angelehnt.
Dann hast du die mit dem Baum, das ist
Hibernia, das ist so an keltische
Sachen angelegt. Dann hast du Albion, das sind die mit dem
Kelch.
Da haben die, da haben die, die Roleplayer früher
immer im RVR geschrieben, für den
Kelch voran und so komisches.
Rollplayer sind eh ganz, ähm,
eigene Spezies an Gamern.
Seht hier ein mächtiger Zauberer,
er steht mit dem Feuer im Bunde.
Weil du drei verschiedene Reiche hast,
äh,
wir sind noch nicht fertig, ne? Ich sag's nur mal.
Wir sind, Leute, wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Ich möchte nur, äh, noch anfügen,
dass wir noch nicht fertig sind, auch wenn wir
gerade Quests abgegeben haben.
Aber wir haben zumindest schon mal
einen Hut bekommen,
der besser ist als mein Mollwikum.
Ein Mollwig-Hut auf jeden Fall.
Was haben wir denn hier für einen Hut?
Wir haben einen Hut für
eher Heiler und einen Hut für
das ist eher der Heiler-Hut,
hier.
Decks, Decks, mehr Decks,
mehr Decks, schneller casten, wichtig.
Dann haben wir noch
ein Gürtel,
der auch gar nicht so übel ist.
Den ziehen wir erst mal an.
Und noch ein Bracer,
der Risi-Pierce
hat und Decks in
den Kreese.
Auch nice.
Und das war's.
Jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, schon mal
gar nicht mal so schlechte,
okay, Spirit-Risis sind ein bisschen wenig,
gar nicht mal so miese Stats
für einen
Level-Armor-ausgerüsteten
Runi, 307 Decks.
Ich hab noch nicht mal
doch, ich hab's backbought,
aber keine Bases, ich hab keine Bases.
Warum hab ich keine Bases?
Okay.
Deswegen hab ich so wenig Decks, weil ich keine Base-Buffs hab.
Ich muss mal, ich muss mal kurz
meinen Buff-Trank trinken.
So.
Na ja, mein Molvik-Hut
hab ich gemeint hier, Molvik.
Dort, wo ich den, bei dem NPC,
wo ich den gekauft hab.
Guck mal, euch fällt auf,
wir haben uns, wir haben den Kreis
verlassen, es sieht jetzt anders aus
auf einmal.
Ja. So, es gibt drei verschiedene
Reiche, jedes Reich hat
komplett unterschiedliche Klassen.
Manche Sachen überschneiden sich ein bisschen, aber
im Prinzip sind es drei komplett unterschiedliche Reiche.
Inklusive Grenzgebiet, Heimatbereich.
Und dadurch ist das,
hat das Game eine nie erreichte
Dynamik im PvP.
Weil selbst, wenn du ein Reich hast,
das zur Zeit mehr Spieler eingeloggt hat
und alles wegzergt, du hast
immer noch den Fall, dass in einem
Fight, wo quasi,
sagen wir mal, es gibt ein Fight,
200 versus 80. In der Regel
zu 99% gewinnen die mit 200.
Bei solchen Riesen-Riesen-Fights.
Ja, realistischere Zahlen.
Nehmen wir mal realistischere Zahlen. Du hast 100
versus 60. Zu 99%
gewinnen die mit 100.
Aber, wenn die mit
60 clever spielen
und das so drehen,
dass vielleicht das dritte Reich noch
am Start ist, auch mit 50.
Dann kannst du auch
mit 60 160
killen. Wenn du es gescheit machst.
Dann musst du dir halt
einen guten
Fight aussuchen. Zum Beispiel
ist es immer sinnvoll,
wenn
sagen wir,
die Leute aus Albion sitzen
in irgendeinem Festungsturm
und die Hips zergen
die um und du wartest den Moment
ab, bis gerade das
Tor vom Turm kaputt geht,
alle in den Turm rein stürmen
und dann rusht du hin.
Dann hast du 50 im Turm
in einem Reich, 60 vom anderen
Reich draußen und 100 dazwischen.
Die quasi gesandwiched werden.
Und durch diese
Dynamik aus
3 Realm
PvP
ist eigentlich
jeder Tag anders
und es wird nie
langweilig.
Obwohl man oberflächlich sagen könnte,
man macht ja immer das gleiche, aber in jedem Game
machst du oberflächlich betrachtet immer das gleiche.
Es ist nie langweilig. Und vielleicht erkennt ihr die
einen oder anderen Parallelen daran
zu Elder Scrolls Online.
Das liegt daran, dass einer der
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es einer der Hauptentwickler
von Dark war, aber ich glaube einer der
Mitgründer damals von Mystic Entertainment
der hat Elder Scrolls Online
maßgeblich mitgebaut,
aber selbst da haben sie es nicht so gut hingekriegt.
Auf welchem Chart spielst du auf Eden?
Es gibt ja nur einen nennenswerten.
So, jetzt machen wir dieses fette Viech da
kaputt.
So und gleich
haben wir es geschafft, wenn ich jetzt
auf Eden starte.
Wir haben alles gekillt
und jetzt zum Final Boss.
Prage, prage, dass es die Leute
nicht wieder verkacken.
Also hier, ich spiele auf Eden.
Also falls du auch früher gespielt hast
und Bock hast, es ist super simpel.
Du lädst dir den offiziellen Dark Client runter.
Spiel, bitte laden.
Du lädst dir den offiziellen Dark Client runter,
updatest den, also lädst runter,
startest den, dann lädt er sich
die neuesten Sachen runter
und dann startest du den Eden Launcher, gibst den Dark Folder an,
und drückst auf Play. Fertig.
Ganz easy. Ich glaube, das kriegt jeder hin.
Wirklich nicht schwer.
Eats AF.
Was musst du beim Final Boss beachten?
Was ist deine Aufgabe?
Das ist Dark PvE.
AE-Damage spammen und warten,
bis er umkippt.
Wenn wir von etwas anspruchsvollerem PvE
reden würden, sagen wir mal, ich würde
jetzt einen Croop Dungeon machen.
Gibt es ja einen recht relativ
anspruchsvollen hier auf Eden.
Und ein paar Artefakte.
Ein paar Counter, die mit kleiner Gruppe
auch recht anspruchsvoll sein können.
Dann wäre meine Aufgabe
jetzt, nein, jetzt in dem Fall
ist es halt blöd, weil
hier ist AE-Spam und Ruhe ist.
Dann wäre meine Aufgabe, je nach Fight,
entweder Gegner
Single-Target zu cc'en,
dass sie sich nicht mehr bewegen können,
oder ein Damage zu machen und sie umzupusten.
Weil ich bin gerade Main
Range, also
Main Range Damage Dealer
von
diesem Reich.
Hier muss ich gar nichts machen.
Hier muss ich einfach nur AE-Spammen
und warten, dass die restlichen Leute von
ABG den umzergen.
Easy as fuck.
Guck, ist schon fast tot.
50, 40, 30,
20, 10
und
dead.
Easy.
Das ist Dark PvE.
Das ist aber auch so
was, wo hier, okay,
Tor, na dann, alles klar.
Das ist aber auch was, was extra so gemacht ist, dass jeder
Voll-Depp es auf die Reihe kriegen kann.
So, wir haben es geschafft.
Ich glaube, wir können direkt
zum König und das
Ganze abgeben, oder? Kings Champion.
Return to King Eric.
Guck mal, Hulu hat schon ein Portal
am Start. Dann returnen
wir doch mal.
Wo zum Teufel sind deine Spells?
Ja,
zwischen den 30 anderen Spells.
Achso, habe ich Effekte nicht
angehabt? Kann sein, dass ich
Effekte nicht angehabt habe,
weil es dazu neigt
zu ruckeln, wenn Effekte an sind.
Selbst auf dem NASA PC von 2024.
Achso,
das hier sind meine Spells.
Ich kann es dir gleich mal zeigen, was die Spells machen.
Huni ist eines der einfachsten Klassen überhaupt.
Du brauchst vier
Tasten und gut ist. Wenn du das mit einem
Heiler vergleichst, der irgendwie acht
Quickbars braucht oder so, um alles unterzubringen,
ist Huni easy as fuck.
Ich kann die Spells
gleich mal zeigen. Ich habe mir den
Chaya hier auch hauptsächlich gemacht,
damit ich schön abends im Zerg mitlaufen
kann, AE spammen und
gut ist. So,
except
Finish!
Jawoll! Jetzt gibt's
Champion Level
für den kleinen Pox Champ.
Und wenn ich
Champion Level 5 bin,
habe ich diesen ganzen Krempel hier auch gerade mitgemacht.
Das war so... Was kann das denn?
Kann das was?
Bonus Armor Faktor!
Auf jeden Fall Resis sind nicht
verkehrt. Habe ich noch genug Decks?
Oh, mehr als genug Decks.
Eigentlich ist mein... Also für das, dass es einfach
nur Levelgear ist, ist es gar nicht mal so
beschissen. Gut, jetzt
kriege ich einen Stab.
Dafür habe ich das eigentlich gemacht.
Dass ich meinen
klassenspezifischen Stab kriege.
Jetzt habe ich hier so einen...
Pox Staff!
Der leuchtet sogar.
Und er hat einen Mana
Restore Spell drauf.
So.
Um jetzt mal zu der Kasbah zu kommen.
So, BG Leaf.
Dispend.
Ich muss mal die ganzen Buffs
wegklicken. So.
Okay, ich muss jetzt die
Runi Epic Frontier Stabs
noch machen. Wir sind stehen geblieben.
Da kann ich dir auch gleich die Spells
zeigen. Weil wie gesagt, Runi ist
wirklich idiotensicher. Du brauchst drei
Knöpfe. Und machst
übelst Damage. Ich würde
sagen, Runi ist...
Also es gibt in jedem Reich
so einen Caster, der echt idioten
für alle geil ist, ja?
In Albion ist es Feuer Wizard. Da musst
du im Prinzip nur drücken 1, 1, 1, 1,
1, 1, 1. Okay, vielleicht mal ein Bolt.
1, 1, 1, 1. Machst übelst Damage.
Hier ist es Runi. Wobei Runi noch ein bisschen mehr kann.
Und in Hipp.
Was ist in Hipp der Einbuttoncaster?
Ich glaube, die haben gar keinen so richtig.
Vielleicht Eng noch am ehesten.
Wobei der auch einen Pet hat. Ich glaube, in Hipp gibt es gar keinen
so richtig krassen Einbuttoncaster.
So, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Okay.
Ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht weggesnackt
im PvP-Gebiet.
Also meine
Quest sagt, ich muss nach
Odin's Gate an die Docks
und
dort einen Mob killen.
Pass auf, ich werde jetzt
stream-sniped.
Und wenn nicht, selbst wenn ich
gekillt werde, werde ich einfach sagen, ich wurde
stream-sniped.
So, Buffs abgeholt.
Buffdrang rein.
Ja, passt alles.
Ach Quatsch, was mache ich denn hier?
Da muss ich hin.
Also, meine Spells sind folgendes.
Ich muss
dir das an dem Mob zeigen.
Sonst ist es bescheuert.
Und jetzt im PvP-Gebiet muss ich ein bisschen
sinnig laufen, dass mich nicht gleich
irgendwas aufspießt.
Was hier an der Stelle gerne passiert,
gerade als Caster in Level-Rüstung
bin ich quasi mehr oder weniger
One-Shot von jedem halbwegs sinnvoll
ausgerüsteten
Gegner.
Und gerade hier an den Docks ist immer richtig viel los.
Auf Eden
muss man übrigens sich keine Gedanken mehr machen,
wenn man Laterne anmacht nachts.
Das haben die ausgeschaltet, dass die anderen
Leute das Licht sehen. Da ist das fiech.
So. Ersten beiden
Spell sind Range-Damage
mit besonders hohem Damage und
besonders hoher Reichweite. Dritter Spell
ist Single-Target-Damage.
The Dead.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat man übrigens auch mal
die Spelleffekte
gesehen. Gut.
Jetzt muss ich zurück zum König.
Das sind wir heute ganz schön oft.
Und dann kann ich dir...
Ich zeig dir die Spells mal.
Ich zeig dir die Spells mal an einem Trainings-Dummy.
Ich glaube, da ist ganz gut erkennbar,
was was ist.
Runi ist wirklich idiotensicher.
Ich finde, Runi ist auch ein guter Einstiegs-Charme,
wenn man Bock hat auf Caster.
Runi wird immer gebraucht, weil jeder braucht
Range-DPS-Caster. Gerade wenn du BG
spielst. Also BG ist meistens
sowas wie 50 Leute gegen 50 Leute
und sowas. Da
spielt niemand ohne Range-AE-Caster,
weil Punkte halt.
So. Also 5 Level 50er
Trainings-Dummy. Was ich an Spells
hab, ist folgendes.
Was ich an Spells habe, ist
folgendes. Also.
Erster Spell.
Range-Damage mit
1875 Range.
Das ist weit. Die normalen
Spells sind eigentlich
einheitlich alle nur 1500er Range.
1500er Range ist ungefähr
so.
Bisschen weiter vielleicht noch.
1500er Range ist so.
Moonwalk, ja.
Und 1800er Range ist
ungefähr so.
Was sehr praktisch ist, weil
du kannst normale Damage-Dealer
halt mit den High-Range
Dingern
Two-Shotten, wenn die Pech haben.
Also das sind zwei
super High-Damage,
super schnell castbare
hohe Range-Damage-Spells.
Das ist der erste.
Das ist der zweite.
Die machen Übels-Damage.
Jetzt an dem Trainings-Dummy nicht so sehr.
Der hat auch ein paar Riesen. Die machen Übels-Damage.
Und wenn die gritten, kannst du
gegnerische Caster
und Low-Life-Targets
Two-Shotten.
Manche sagen sogar, sie haben schon Leute
One-Shotted mit einem Bolt.
Dafür, dass es nicht allzu
OP ist, wie du siehst, gehen die Dinger
allerdings auf einen Cooldown von 20
Sekunden, nachdem man sie eingesetzt hat.
Die machen Übels-Damage.
Dann habe ich ein Single-Target
DD, also Single-Target
Damage. Du siehst den Unterschied.
Der macht jetzt nur 318.
Die anderen machen 650 oder
irgendwas.
Deswegen braucht man auch ganz viel Decks
als Caster.
Damit man schneller castet.
Ganz einfach.
Also so 300, 340, 350
Decks sollte man haben. Witzigerweise
schneller casten geht nicht durch
Geschwindigkeit hier, sondern durch
Quickness, sondern durch Geschicklichkeit.
Weil Dark-Logik.
Single-Target hier.
DD.
Dann habe ich einen
Area-Effekt.
Ich drücke jetzt die 4.
Area-Effekt. Ranged.
Damaged. Das sind diese Sperre.
So.
Und das war es eigentlich schon, was so ein Huni hat.
Ich habe noch Near-Sight geskillt.
Auch ganz praktisch.
Ja, Massive-Grafik.
Das verkürzt um
45%
die Range anderer Caster und Bogenschützen.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt da vorne
den Typ da sehe, der hat übrigens 2300er
Range. Wenn ich da vorne jetzt diesen Dude sehe
und denke mir, oh fuck, Alter, der
killt mich jetzt gleich, wenn ich da rankomme,
dann caste ich Near-Sight drauf, so.
Gehe ich hin, caste Near-Sight drauf.
Und jetzt hat er viel
weniger Range als ich. Das heißt, ich kann
da hingehen und kann den
uncasten, kann den damagen,
kann dann weglaufen und er kann
nichts machen, weil ich viel mehr Range habe als
er. So, Near-Sight.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Spezialität.
Man kann Crown-Targets
setzen. Das geht beispielsweise
auch, wie euch vielleicht
auffällt, wenn hier was dazwischen ist.
Wenn hier jetzt die Hütte dazwischen
ist, sagt er
Target not in view.
Was ich aber machen kann ist,
ich kann mein Crown-Target
hier hinsetzen und
diesen Spell nehmen und da
caste ich immer auf
diesen Punkt, egal ob ich Sichtlinien
habe oder nicht. Das ist für
Fights an Festungen
und so gut. Wenn man beispielsweise in
Innenhof Damage machen will oder
auf die
Zinnen Damage machen will, wo du
keine direkte Sichtlinie hin hast.
Das macht aber auch nicht so viel Schaden
hier.
Ranged Area Damage ohne Sichtlinie.
Das ist, dass
ich ein bisschen mehr aushalte. Absorb und
Armor Faktor Schilder.
Das hier absorbiert einen
Nahkampfangriff und das hier ist, dass ich schneller
rennen kann. Das war's an Spells.
Achso, stimmt. Dann habe ich noch
einen Root. Das kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen,
weil das sich nicht bewegt.
Mal angenommen, das hier wäre ein Tank, der auf mich zurennt.
Ja. Das wäre ein Tank, der auf
mich zurennt. Dann könnte ich den
rooten. So, zack, root.
Oh, dann kann er sich nicht mehr, kann er nicht
mehr weiterlaufen. Für, haltet euch
fest, haltet euch fest, für
eine Minute.
Eine Minute 13 Sekunden kann er nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Das ist aber nur halb so wild, weil
wenn er Resistenzen hat gegen
gegen Body. Wenn er Body Resistenzen
hat, dann zählt es dann auch nur 50%.
Und Tanks kannst du eh nicht gescheit CC'en.
Also,
realistisch betrachtet, auf einen
ordentlich geskillten Tank, der auch
sich Tank nennen kann, hält das
hier vielleicht 10 Sekunden.
Und dann kann er sich wieder bewegen.
Kann man davon befreit werden?
Ja, das ist mit Dark
und CC so eine Sache. Von Root kannst du
nicht befreit werden. Du kannst
nur von Sleep
befreit werden. Sleep
kannst du heilen,
Stun kannst du nicht heilen und Root kannst du nicht heilen.
Aber Root ist meistens nicht so schlimm,
weil du weiter
casten kannst.
Und
also, wenn das hier jetzt ein gegnerischer
caster Bogenschütze oder sowas wäre, dem wäre das egal,
ob der gerootet ist, der kann trotzdem auf mich schießen.
Und
jeder, jeglicher
Damage bricht das CC,
aber
echt, mit was kannst du
Root heilen?
Es gibt kein D-Root oder sowas.
Du kannst
Dead oder sowas backen.
Oder...
Ach stimmt!
Du hast recht! Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, du hast recht.
Ja.
Und tatsächlich, ich glaube
sogar, es gibt ein paar
RR5-Fähigkeiten, die
anti-CC mäßig sind. Der Skull hat auch irgendeine
Anti-CC-Geschichte auf RR5. Stimmt, da habe ich
gar nicht dran gedacht.
Das ist aber auch was, was es
früher tatsächlich nicht gegeben hat. Das haben die ja später eingeführt.
So, und das war es. Das war es eigentlich.
Da gibt es noch eine kleine Spezialität,
die ich aber nicht benutze.
Man kann sein
Ziel debuffen. Ich zeige euch das mal.
Guckt mal hier. Jetzt mache ich kaum Damage drauf.
So gut wie nichts.
266, resisted,
240,
208. Ich mache kaum Damage drauf.
Okay? So, ziemliche Varianz.
Jetzt debuffe ich den und mache
nochmal den gleichen Spell drauf.
350, 668,
233,
567. Also die Varianz
ist halt trotzdem groß, weil ich das nicht geskillt habe.
Aber ich
kann Kälteschaden,
Hitzeschaden und Materieschaden
um 50% die Resistenzen senken.
Lohnt sich bei mir
allerdings für mich selbst nicht,
weil
das hier kommt aus der Darkness-Skill-Linie
und Darkness habe ich nicht geskillt.
Ich habe
Runecarving und Suppression geskillt.
Runecarving ist das für die
Bowls. So.
Und das war's. Mehr hat der Runi nicht.
Ich habe noch eine
Realm-Mobility.
Da kann ich auch ein Crown-Target
setzen und dann TWF casten.
Sieht dann so aus.
Dann kommt hier sowas.
Und alles was da drinnen steht,
bekommt ein bisschen Damage.
Wie ihr seht, alles was da drin steht und feindlich
ist, bekommt Damage. Der Damage ist aber
gar nicht so das Ding, sondern die werden
auch geslowt.
Das ist auch sehr praktisch.
Gerade für irgendwelche Belagerungssachen,
weil es auch durch alles durchgeht.
Das war's.
Mehr hat ein Runi nicht.
Also Runi ist eines der
most
straight-forward und
unproblematischsten Klassen im ganzen Spiel.
Ich muss zum König
jetzt wieder.
Runi finde ich ist auch eine super
Einstiegsklasse.
Runi ist eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Also ich finde...
Das Spiel hat
ein paar gute Einstiegsklassen,
wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ich habe im Chat gesehen,
dass ein paar Leute tatsächlich
gerade runterladen und sowas.
Lasst euch mal zwei
Sachen gesagt sein. Erstens,
ihr müsst ein bisschen reinkommen.
Daok ist nicht sonderlich einsteigerfreundlich,
weil es halt keine Sachen gibt, die einem das erklären.
Es sind halt auch viele Sachen nicht sonderlich
intuitiv. Zum Beispiel, dass
Geschicklichkeit Cast-Speed ist und nicht
Geschwindigkeit Cast-Speed
ist. Was eigentlich keinen Sinn macht.
Aber es ist halt so.
Also man muss sich da ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Das ist aber auf Eden kein Ding, weil ihr auf Eden
ganz viele Übungsgebiete
habt, wo ihr da relativ schnell reinkommt.
Wo ihr da relativ schnell reinkommt.
Aber man darf nicht komplett abgeschreckt sein
von ein bisschen
Clunky-Bedienung.
Und dann...
Ah ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen zu erwähnen.
Was das hier ist...
Das hier ist ein Spell, den habe ich gar nicht gezeigt.
Das hier ist ein Spell für
Anti-Nahkampf.
Da kriegt man...
Kann man sich so eine...
So ein... Wie heißt das?
Ein Runic Ward geben, der
absorbiert einen Nahkampftreffer.
Ne, neue Models mag ich nicht.
Neue Models mag ich nicht.
Gecox, habe ich dich
nicht gerade in...
Am Trainings-Dummy gesehen?
Du bist doch gerade an mir vorbeigelaufen, oder?
Ne, neue Models mag ich nicht.
So, und du hast
das Gleiche noch. Das gibt es für mich
als Target. Das hast du noch
für Gruppe, was sich alle 10 Sekunden
erneuert.
So...
Ich muss mal kurz was
gucken. Hm.
Kurz auf meinem Skalbe was schauen.
Ach ne, da steht noch DF, oder?
Ist der noch DF?
Wenn der noch DF ist, dann lasse ich den
auch DF geparkt.
Der ist noch DF. Ne, den lasse ich
DF geparkt. Da gucke ich später, ist
egal. Ich wollte gerade was in
meinem Vault gucken, aber ich will den nicht aus DF
rauspacken, weil...
DF ist nicht uns.
Spielst du mit neuen Models?
Also ich mag die neuen Models nicht.
Dass ihr es mal gesehen
habt, passt mal auf, neue Models.
Das ist das alte Model, das sieht halt wirklich aus wie
2001. Dann gibt es neue
Models. Wo geht denn das überhaupt
einzuschalten?
Skin Choice.
Ne, äh...
Was ist denn überhaupt? Hier.
Genau, ich habe alles auf Classic
geschaltet, jetzt schalten wir mal auf Catacombs.
Und jetzt
sieht es so aus. Sieht auch nicht wirklich besser aus,
oder? Sieht halt ein bisschen
moderner aus
jetzt.
Reicht eine Grafikkarte für das Game
ganz knapp.
Sieht halt ein bisschen moderner aus.
Guck.
So sieht mein Huni aus in den
neueren Models.
Ich finde, ich mag die
neuen Models nicht. Schwer zu sagen,
ich finde, die
sind nicht so im
ja, keine Ahnung, nicht so im Geister der
alten Models. Ich mag die alten Models mehr.
Classic Models.
Aber, um mal auf die andere
Sache zurückzukommen.
Solo-Stelzer.
Ja. Und
weil ich gesehen habe, dass
ein paar Leute gesagt haben, ich lad
mal runter und so. Wie gesagt, lasst euch
nicht so sehr dadurch schocken, dass
es ein bisschen schwierig ist, da reinzukommen.
Da hat viele Sachen so,
du weißt es oder du hast verloren.
Man muss sich da dran gewöhnen, aber
meistens hast du es, wenn du es gesehen hast,
checkst du es schon. Aber viele Sachen sind
halt nicht klar, wie gesagt. Also,
jemand, der neu ist, der weiß zum Beispiel nicht,
was die Sachen hier zum Beispiel
machen. Es gibt auch keine
gescheite Erklärung ingame dafür, was
Stats angeht. Ich glaube,
mittlerweile ist es aber so, wenn du einen Char
anlegst, haben die zumindest
halbwegs, halbwegs sinnvoll
vordefinierte
Start-Stats. Das war ja am Anfang
auch nicht so. Und wenn du damals
gefragt hast, hey Hersteller, wie soll
ich meinen Char skillen? Da haben die dir
Ratschläge gegeben, da warst du verskillt am Ende.
Ja, und es
gibt ganz viele kleine Sachen so in
DAOC, wo man sich dran gewöhnen muss.
Zum Beispiel, ich wollte das
ja eh mal zeigen,
zum Beispiel die Casting und Interrupt-Mechanik
ist halt auch so ein Ding,
das ist man aus moderneren
Games gar nicht gewöhnt.
Äh, fertig?
Hagal!
Okay, also kommt jetzt dieser Krempel.
Ich, ich, ich zeige euch das
mal kurz. Da müssen wir uns
irgendeinen, uns irgendeinen 0815
Mob schnappen.
Und uns mal hinten lassen.
Ja.
Das, das habe ich den Leuten versucht auch
zu erklären, dass das Game mal
einfach das beste, best Game ever ist,
weil man PvP mag.
Auch gerade durch den dynamischen Ansatz ist
quasi fast kein Tag wie der andere.
Okay.
Äh, zack.
Und es hat, es hat sicherlich ja auch noch
mehr Aspekte. Es gibt Leute, die stehen eher darauf,
das Spiel Solo zu spielen. Es gibt welche,
die flitzen gerne in
mit 80
plus Mann rum und zergen
alles weg. Du hast Leute, die
spielen gerne Duo. Du hast Leute, die spielen
gerne mit 3, 4, 5 Mann.
Du hast Leute, die spielen gerne als Achtergruppe.
Du kannst eigentlich alles in dem Spiel
machen, wie du gerade Bock hast.
Sofern du, sofern du, und das ist halt
die Voraussetzung irgendwo, sofern
du PvP ein bisschen was abgewinnen
kannst. Aber ich muss sagen,
ganz ehrlich,
die übelsten Casuals in Dark
spielen PvP. Das ist das
einzige Game, was ich kenne,
das selbst die 0815
nicht Snoops überhaupt
dazu gebracht hat, PvP zu machen.
Also die Leute, die
WoW spielen und den ganzen Tag nur craften,
oder den
vierzigsten
Chart winken oder so, anstatt
mal irgendwie PvP zu machen,
spielen in Dark PvP. Also
ich habe noch
kein Game erlebt, wo wirklich jeder
PvP gespielt hat.
Selbst die Oma
spielt da PvP. Ich meine,
die spielt jetzt bestimmt kein
irgendwie King of the Hill mit Achtergruppe
oder sowas, aber
die, ich meine, wenn ich gucke,
was für Leute da teilweise abends
in der Midgard-BG dabei sind,
ich glaube der Älteste ist 75 oder so,
also das sind
die richtigen Opas am Start,
die sogar nicht spielen PvP.
So, was ich euch zeigen wollte, wir brauchen mal einen Mob, der nicht
ganz so viel Damage macht, please, irgendwie.
Irgendwas Blaues oder
Grünes oder so, ja. Also
ich versuche mal
was zu zeigen, was so die Caster
Mechanic in Dark halt
braucht das was?
Decks? Bonus
Decks? Ah,
Resi Pierce.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ach das hat auch Decks Bonus.
Nö, dann
schmeiß ich den in den Vault. So, normalerweise
ist man es ja gewohnt,
so aus neueren MMOs und Games,
wenn man auf Gegner zaubert,
dann, ich muss mal gucken, dass ich den jetzt nicht
kille. So, ich zauber jetzt auf den Gegner.
So, und irgendwie habe ich den nicht tot
gekriegt, bis der an mich ran ist.
Da kriegst du epileptische
Anfälle, wenn du dir den Gegner anguckst. So, und
jetzt ist das Problem, der macht ja ziemlich
Damage, wenn er an mich rankommt.
Guck mal hier, wenn der mich hittet,
hat jetzt dreimal vorbeigehauen,
oder einmal hat es gebrochen.
Er macht ja ganz schön Damage. Und normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen,
ah ja, ich caste jetzt einfach so
lange weiter,
bis der Gegner tot ist. Das Problem
ist, ihr seht es vielleicht schon, ich kann
nicht casten,
solange der Gegner an mir dran ist.
Das heißt, als Caster musst du
wegrennen, und dann kannst du wieder casten.
Und das
ist nicht nur gegen Monster so,
das ist auch gegen Spieler so.
Und das ist so ein ganz, ganz eigenwilliges
System, wo ich auch schon
wo ich auch schon viele
Leute im Advice-Chat und so gesehen hab,
so, ich bin Level 1
Shammy und krieg keine Gegner
tot und sowas. Und da musst du ihnen halt sagen, ja, du musst
Damage machen, ein Stückchen kiten, Damage machen und sowas.
Oder am besten mit
Kuppelspielen.
Also,
ich wollt eigentlich die Quest abholen.
Also ich hab nicht
25 Jahre am Stück gespielt, ich hab
ultra viel gespielt, früher,
bis
ungefähr
2000, ganz knapp
2010.
Inklusive OS-Server dann auch,
als sie der Klassik-Server in EU
dichtgemacht hat.
Danach hab ich,
hatte ich keinen Bock mehr, aber
als dann immer mehr Freeshots
aufgekommen sind,
hab ich wieder angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, was der erste Freeshot war, den ich
ausprobiert hab, in Dark.
Könnte Dings gewesen sein, wie ist das,
äh, nicht Origin,
Genesis, glaub ich war das.
Das war 2015
oder sowas. Und seitdem bin ich
eigentlich auch permanent auf Freeshots am Start.
Ich, ich, ich cryne das vielleicht
nicht unbedingt
jetzt ein ganzes Jahr durch, weil gerade
wenn die Spielerzahlen droppen und sowas,
irgendwann, irgendwann hab
ich dann auch keinen Bock da irgendwie
großartig, aber
du kannst eigentlich gerade mit dem
Season-Ansatz von Eden, find ich, find ich super
super nice gemacht,
ganz theoretisch, ein halbes Jahr
immer schön Dark cryen.
Dann machst du ein bisschen Pause und dann spielst du
wieder ein halbes Jahr.
Find ich, find ich super, also
ein Monat vom halben Jahr ist schon rum.
So.
Mist, ich bin Solo, jetzt
muss ich da hinrennen, das ist ja kacke.
Ich hab nen,
ich hab nen Char in TG stehen,
wo ich porten könnte, aber
Ich brauch TG-Port.
Heil-Olga.
Heil-Olga hat nen Port.
Heil-Olga, beste.
Heil-Olga, porte mich nach TG.
Excellent,
Poggers.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe Heil-Olga
kann sich
Oh ne, Heil-Olga
hat ausgelockt.
Jetzt ist er offline. Na super.
Any need port und
lockt aus. Och geil.
Machen die Epic?
Machen, machen die Epic?
Die machen aber wahrscheinlich
den Skull-Step. Jetzt muss ich da hinrennen,
da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ne, ne, ich mach kein TG.
Ich wollt nach TG porten,
um da wieder raus zu gehen,
um den Quest-Step, äh, Quest-Step zu erledigen.
Jetzt muss ich da hinrennen.
Ich hab nen Char
in TG geparkt, dass ich da relativ
easy Leute hinporten kann,
aber das dumme ist halt, ich kann mich selbst mit nem
anderen Char auf meinem gleichen Account nicht hinporten.
Die Musik ist nahe, das ist keine Dark-Musik,
das ist ne, ne,
Fantasy-Village-
Playlist von Youtube.
Weil Dark eher nervige Sounds hat.
Ja, ich wollt euch noch was
zeigen und zwar, weil jetzt ein paar Leute gesagt haben,
sie wollen nicht drunter laden, mal angucken.
Also wie gesagt, erstmal lasst euch nicht so sehr
abschrecken von
vielleicht der ein oder anderen Unzulänglichkeit.
Auf Eden ist es schon deutlich besser,
wie es früher gewesen ist.
Lasst euch auch nicht abschrecken
von manchen Dummschwätzern im Chat.
Ist ganz normal. Weiß auch nicht, was die Leute
haben in nem 20 Jahre, 25 Jahre
alten Game immer.
Gibt schon ein paar weird
Leute.
Gerne komplett sinnlos.
Gibt schon ein paar komische Leute
in Dark.
Gerade, wenn dann irgendwelche neuen Leute
im Chat fragen um Hilfe und dann kriegst du
ne total bescheuerte Antwort so.
Zum Beispiel, letztens hat irgendeiner
gefragt, so ich bin Level 1
Shummy und krieg keine Mobs tot.
Das Problem war halt, weil er immer unterbrochen
wird, weil er die
Interrupt Mechanic von Dark noch nicht kannte.
Und dann haben halt wirklich Leute
zu ihm geschrieben, ihr Just
Delete Character und sowas.
Wo du halt denkst, Alter, wie kackspastig musst du
eigentlich drauf sein. Irgendjemand, der
offensichtlich das Game neu spielt,
willst du nicht, dass Leute das neue
Game ausprobieren oder was?
Und dann feiern sie sich im Chat auch immer noch
übelst dafür ab.
Man muss sich überlegen, das sind Leute, die spielen
das Game 25 Jahre lang. Die haben das Game schon
gespielt, wie die Jungen waren.
Die waren damals ungefähr, sagen wir mal, 16
bis 20, so wie ich. Und die sind heute
40. Warum musst du mit
40 Leuten, warum musst du mit
40 auf
einem Freeshot, in einem MMO
irgendwelche
Neueinsteiger verarschen, um dir dann
geil vorzukommen? Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten
los ist. Das ist auch so
ein Ding in Dark, es gibt so eine
es gibt schon ein paar sehr
weirde Leute. Was aber irgendwie
in jedem MMO ist.
Und in Dark kommt dann noch dazu,
dass du so viele Möchtegern-Elite-Leute
hast. Also ich meine, dass nicht Leute,
die wirklich gut in dem Game sind,
die sind meistens gar nicht so
unumgänglich, sondern so
Leute, die eigentlich übelst reinzacken,
aber so tun, als sind sie die übelsten
Pros. Die gehen mir immer auf den Sack.
So.
Eigentlich wollte ich euch jetzt noch was zeigen, für alle, die sich
doch überlegt haben, sich das mal anzugucken.
Nämlich, was gute Einstiegsklassen sind.
Problem ist nur, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, dass ich nirgends wo
reinrenne, sonst bin ich dead.
Trimakurs, das habe ich schon ewig nicht
mehr gehört.
Die alten Dark-Videos mit
640x480
und 5 FPS, gell?
Ich habe einen Fight gestern aufgenommen in der
BG. Irgendwie
180 Mids gegen 200 Hips
und sowas.
Das ist glaube ich auch das, was neue
Leute cool finden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten Leute
Damals hatten die Nightwish
immer im Hintergrund, genau. Oder? Oder?
Auch der beliebteste Song
ever, bei irgendwelchen
Montages, könnt ihr euch vielleicht früher auch noch
dran erinnern.
Down with the Sickness. Kennt ihr das noch?
Bei jeder Montage
Mann war das drauf.
Oder, oder
Let the bodies hit the floor.
Let the bodies hit the floor. Das war auch früher
immer bei jeder Montage dabei oder bei jedem Video.
Yasden, was macht der Döner?
Vielleicht hast du vorhin schon was geschrieben
und ich habe es bloß nicht gesehen.
Das war jetzt auch Darkspeak,
was keiner versteht.
Es gibt in Dark eine Klasse,
die nennt sich Donnerkrieger.
Und im Deutsch wurde der immer Döner genannt.
Hast du nicht? Okay.
Wie gesagt, wenn du willst, sag Bescheid.
Skull ist 50 für Speed.
Ich kann auch was mit dir leveln.
Können wir ein bisschen im BG bashen.
Aber ich habe eigentlich jetzt alles,
was ich haben will.
Ich habe meinen Skull, ich habe meinen Chammy,
ich habe meinen Huni jetzt. Der braucht noch ein bisschen Equip.
Den Heiler fürs BG.
Und den BD zum Farmen.
Also eigentlich habe ich alles am Start.
Du warst im Urlaub.
Moment, Moment.
Ist nicht der Urlaub die Zeit, wo man eigentlich
sowas macht?
Oder meinst du
im Urlaub so wirklich im Urlaub?
Also so irgendwie
an der frischen Luft im Urlaub?
Das ist schon ganz schön cringe,
wer das macht.
So richtig Urlauber.
Sachen gibt es.
Jetzt seht ihr die Spells
auch mal an normalen Mobs.
Ihr seht, die zwei Balls
two-shotten den Gegner fast schon.
Wir gucken uns mal kurz,
während ich auf meine Balls warte.
Dog.
Classes.
Classes and Races.
Ich will eigentlich
die Klasse annehmen.
Okay, die offizielle
Seite
ist ja mal wieder mega hässlich.
Ist da nicht irgendein Wiki?
Ja, doch. Besser.
Wiki.
Ja, das ist eine viel bessere Übersicht.
Auf, gib ihm.
Habe ich schon irgendwas gespeckt, um noch ein bisschen mehr Damage rauszuholen?
Ah ne, ich habe nichts mehr frei.
2L2
Wild Power oder sowas schon?
Ja, Wild Power 3.
Gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Wind und TWF1.
Ja gut, mehr kannst du mit 2L2 auch nicht machen.
Wo bleiben denn die Krits?
Krit-Chance ist gar nicht so klein gerade.
Also ich habe eine Krit-Chance von
9 plus 5.
14%.
14% Krit-Chance.
Ja, ist ziemlich gut.
Für so low RR-Rank.
Aber ihr seht das,
sobald es ein Krit...
Okay, das könnte ein Krit gewesen sein.
Ja, guck mal.
Krit.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr es erkennt.
Der hat 578 gemacht
und nochmal 529 Krit.
Der ist einfach geplatzt beim zweiten Bowl.
So sieht das also aus, wenn die Bowls
kritten.
Aber,
jetzt wollte ich eigentlich euch was zeigen.
Also falls jetzt wirklich irgendjemand Bock hat und sich denkt,
ey, mal gucken, vielleicht ist das ja was, was mir Spaß macht.
Dann
gibt es ein paar Klassen, wo ich denke,
die sind ganz gut für den Einstieg.
Und es gibt auch ein paar Klassen, wo ich sagen würde,
die sind überhaupt nichts für den Einstieg.
Also als erstes müsst ihr euch überlegen,
in welchem Bereich ihr spielen wollt.
Wollt ihr Albion spielen?
Wollt ihr Midgard spielen?
Oder wollt ihr Hibernia spielen?
Ich kann mich theoretisch
sogar mal in den unterschiedlichen Reichen
einloggen. Also das hier ist Midgard.
Da ist alles relativ
schneebedeckt.
Und ein bisschen trister.
Das orientiert sich so ein bisschen an Norwegen
und sowas.
Dann, ähm, Albion.
Orientiert sich eher an mittelalterlichem
England und Hibernia, wie gesagt, mittelalterlich
ist so
Schottland, Irland, so in der Richtung.
Also ist sehr grün alles.
Und wenn ihr euch
für ein Reich entschieden habt,
ihr habt Glück, auf Eden
kann man alle drei Reiche spielen.
Auf live war das
so, man musste sich
auf einem Server für ein Reich
entscheiden. Man konnte zwar Server wechseln
und dort ein anderes Reich spielen,
aber auf einem Server war man festgelegt.
Hier ist es so, du kannst im Prinzip
in allen Reichen spielen.
Was du nicht machen kannst ist,
von einem Reich PvP
ins andere Reich PvP
direkt wechseln. Da hast du glaube ich
60 Minuten Timer. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
60 Minuten Timer. Was aber auch sinnvoll
ist, ja.
Weil es halt Endgame PvP
ist. Und du hast
ein
Loyalty Bonus. Also wenn du
PvP nur in einem
Reich spielst, sammelst du quasi
jeden Tag 1% Bonus.
Punkte.
Also 1% Bonus sammelst du
jeden Tag. Und
irgendwann hast du dann glaube ich bis zu 50%
Bonus. Und bekommst
dann 50% mehr
Punkte für PvP,
wenn du in dem Reich weiterspielst.
Finde ich gut gemacht. Die verbieten
einem nicht woanders zu spielen,
aber es hat gewisse Anreize.
Was du ohne Probleme machen kannst ist,
in allen anderen Reichen PvE,
Character Leveln und Battlegrounds
spielen. Davon,
also da passiert deine
Loyalty
Punkte nix.
Das heißt ihr könnt ohne Probleme
einfach alle drei Reiche mal ausprobieren.
Was euch da besser gefällt.
Was euch optisch besser zusagt.
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich gar nicht so sehr nach Optik
der jeweiligen Realms gehen, sondern welche
Klassen euch gefallen.
Jetzt wir. Wir haben die
Daok Experten am Start
erzählen. So.
Und ich würde
ehrlich gesagt tatsächlich ein bisschen nach der
Klasse gehen, worauf ihr Bock habt zu spielen.
Und es gibt ein paar ganz gute Einstiegs.
Habe ich jetzt die eigentlich schon fertig hier?
Einen. Einen muss ich noch killen.
Okay.
Was? Die Loyalty sinkt im BG?
Ernsthaft?
Kannst du nicht BG spielen so viel du willst?
Loyalty sinkt doch nicht im BG?
Ich will das jetzt mal nicht ausschließen.
Also du kannst, du hast ein 500
du hast ein 500 oder 250
RP pro Tag, die du in einem anderen
Bereich machen darfst. Aber ich dachte das
excludet komplett Battlegrounds.
Wir müssen jetzt diese komischen Eier
sammeln. Ja, also wahrscheinlich
am besten dort zu spielen, wo es eine Klasse gibt, auf
die man Bock hat.
Und wir kommen uns das jetzt mal ganz
ganz schnell an.
Und ich sag mal meinen Senf zu, was
ich für gute Einsteigerklassen halte und was
ich als echt schlechte
Einsteigerklassen halte.
Ich mach mal kurz hier einen Townportal hin, falls ich verrecke.
Falls ich gerade im Browser bin,
während ich hier irgendwie abgefarmt werde.
So, ich glaub die Viecher muss ich
killen jetzt.
War ich bei einem Bolt? Ah doch, hier.
Bäm, in Ass geboltet.
1 und direkt 1
von 5. Also.
Gucken wir uns mal kurz die Klassen an.
Wir machen das ganz schnell, ich hab das in einem der letzten
Streams schon erzählt.
Ich würde euch nicht empfehlen, einen
Nahkampfcharakter als ersten
Char zu erstellen.
Nahkampf in Dark
ist eine Sache für sich.
Da muss man meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen
den Flow drauf
haben. Ich mag Nahkämpfer
nicht als Einstiegsklasse.
Da muss man ein bisschen den Flow drauf haben. Das Problem ist,
Leute, die Nahkämpfer spielen
und neu in dem Game sind, die haben extremen
Tunnelblick. Die sehen den Gegner
und rushen einfach und sind nur tot. Das macht
keinen Spaß.
Und, also wenn du Nahkämpfer
spielst, dann muss man ein bisschen checken,
wann man pushen kann und wann man nicht pushen kann.
Und das
checken Leute nicht, die neu sind.
Das checkst du beim zweiten oder dritten
Char erst, wenn du ein bisschen PvP-Erfahrung hast.
Musst du dir jetzt mal angucken, Leute, die neu sind,
die sehen den Gegner, stellt euch
vor, hier, stellt euch vor, dass hier werden Gegner
und ihr seid Nahkämpfer, die sehen den Gegner,
sind in ihrer Gruppe, ziehen
drumherum, Attacke, Nahkampf,
gib ihm! Und checken überhaupt
nicht, dass die Coup nicht hinterherkommt, nicht mitgepusht
wird und eigentlich 18 Gegner um sie drumherum
sind und sie jetzt einmal angecastet werden und sind tot.
Also ich würde sagen,
ich finde Nahkämpfer,
ich finde Nahkämpfer nicht so sinnvoll
als Einstieg.
Letztendlich ist es wichtig, eine Klasse
zu nehmen, die euch anspricht,
aber ich würde sagen, so reiner
Nahkämpfer ist nicht unbedingt
die beste Einstiegsklasse.
Und Armsman ist ein reiner Nahkämpfer.
Von der Armbrust reden wir jetzt mal nicht.
Armsman ist ein reiner Nahkämpfer.
Kaba ist zum Beispiel, finde ich, eine ganz gute
Einstiegsklasse. Also wenn man
Albion spielen will, ist Kaba eine ganz
nice Einstiegsklasse. Du hast ein Pet,
das heißt, du bist jetzt auch nicht immer
komplett verloren, wenn mal ein Gegner an dich
rankommt, beziehungsweise, wir reden jetzt mal nur
von PvE an der Stelle, wenn irgendein Monster
an dich rankommt. Du hast ein Pet,
du machst mit der passenden
Spec relativ viel Damage und kannst
auch sehr schön in Zergfiles
leachen.
Insgesamt ist Kaba eine schöne Klasse,
auch zum Einstieg
vielleicht nicht die beste,
weil so ein paar Mechanics sind einem nicht
ganz klar, ja zum Beispiel, was macht solche,
was macht Niersalm, keine Ahnung, man weiß nicht wie,
ich muss debuffen, dass ich mehr Damage mache.
Ich finde Kaba ist, wenn man gerne
so ein bisschen Utility lastigen
Caster spielen will in Albion, ist Kaba
finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Cleric ist eine super Einstiegsklasse, meiner Meinung
nach,
wenn man auf Support steht.
Loyalität, Loyalität
bringt mehr RPs
und ich glaube, und da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher,
sogar mehr Currency, ich glaube
du kriegst mehr Currency und mehr
mehr
auf jeden Fall mehr RPs,
wenn du in dem Realm RPs
hast, wo du hohes Loyalty hast.
Ach ja, und du kannst dir irgendwann
sogar so Loyalty
Skins kaufen, wenn du lange
genug dabei warst.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was das Cap ist bei Loyalty.
50?
Oder gar 100?
Moin, einfach
wie je so. Schön, dass
du da bist. Du hast heute
einen
außergewöhnlichen Tag erwischt,
weil normalerweise halten sich
die Gaming-Streams in Grenzen und vor allem
keine super
20 Jahre alten MMOs.
Das ist
nicht für jeden was. Aber ich
musste heute eh viel Kreisel-Crime
machen und da dachte ich mir, ich mach das mal on stream.
Hab ich das jetzt
eigentlich fertig? Ne, ich hab
immer noch eins von fünf. Na geil.
So. Aber wir machen das jetzt,
wir machen das jetzt erstmal kurz mit den Klassen weiter.
Wenn's Gaming ist, dann in letzter
Zeit, ja, ich hätte echt mal Bock
wieder auf eine Runde Battlefield 2042.
Gerade
jetzt mit, was ich,
ich hab die letzte Season mir noch nicht mal angeguckt.
Also, wie gesagt,
ganz praktische Einstiegsklasse, wenn man
Albion spielen will und
ein bisschen Bock hat auf so
Utility-lastigen Caster, der aber auch gut
Damage machen kann und ein Pet hat, ist es
schöne Allround-Klasse. Ich mag Cabba. Cabba ist
eines meiner Lieblingsklassen in Alb.
Ja, tatsächlich, Bock auf 2042.
Cleric?
Für alle Leute, die gerne Support spielen.
Cleric eines DER
besten Klassen im ganzen Game.
Man muss, man muss Bock auf
Support haben, ja. Support
heißt Gruppe heilen, Gruppe
buffen und
ein bisschen
Support-Casting, so. Ab und
zu mal Gegner stunnen und
minimals Damage vielleicht ab und zu
machen, aber, also Mini,
Mini-Damage, ja.
Wobei man sagen muss, von allen Heilern kann der Cleric theoretisch
noch am meisten, am meisten Damage machen.
Aber, wenn man, wenn man
auf Support steht, ist Cleric
eines der besten Einstiegsklassen
und eines der wichtigsten Klassen, die es in Albion
gibt. Main-Buffer,
Main-Heiler,
Buff-Shion, ja. Also,
super. Also, wenn man Bock auf Supporter
hat, ohne den keiner
spielen kann, ist Cleric
genau das Richtige für euch. Also,
ich hab, ich hab live auch gerne gespielt
und ich hab sogar hier auf Alb
eingelevelt. Also, für
mich auch eines der schönsten Klassen im Game.
Und auch eine super Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn man auf Support steht, ja. Wenn ihr jetzt jemand
seid, der nur Spaß am Game hat, wenn
er hohe Damage zahlt, warum leuchtet's
denn da oben rot? Das muss ich
mir jetzt mal angucken. Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Und da leuchtet's gelb?
Warum leuchtet's da rot?
Sekunde, das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Da war ich noch nie.
Warum leuchtet's da rot?
Es leuchtet gar nicht mehr rot, wenn ich da ankomme.
Das ist bestimmt G-Bait.
Die verarschen mich bestimmt. Wahrscheinlich
kommt man hier jetzt gar nicht hoch.
Doch.
Massive High-Res Textures?
Sag mal, soll die Textur
Vogelkacke sein? Ich mein das ernst.
Weil hier sind so viele, so viele Vögel.
Soll das Erde mit Vogelkacke sein, die
Textur? Ich erkenn's nicht, weil die so
sind. Okay. Hier ist einfach random.
Hier ist einfach random
rot. Alles
klar, habt ihr gut gemacht, Dark Level
Designer.
Warum ist hier rot? Man weiß es nicht, es ist einfach
rot. Ist unbekannt,
warum's da rot ist.
Aborets Wohnung.
Also ich wär jetzt...
Da wär ich jetzt als letztes drauf
gekommen.
Bestimmt.
Da läuft der Insi-Modus. Für mehr als die
hoch... Für mehr als zu dieser
Textur reicht der Insi-Modus halt nicht.
Es gibt hier irgendwo an einem dieser
Säulen auch die mit Abstand schlecht
aufgelöste Textur. Hier.
Im ganzen Game. Guckt euch das an,
Alter.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehend?
Was ist das?
Man weiß nicht so genau.
Da war Doom Hi-Rez dagegen.
Wir machen das gleich mit den
Klassen weiter, wenn ich die Mobs gekillt
hab, weil ich...
Ich steh hier mitten im Gebiet, wo
quasi
Viecher rumlaufen, die mich killen, wenn ich gerade im Browser bin.
Deswegen
machen wir die jetzt mal platt.
Null Prozent.
Drei von fünf.
Zwei brauchen wir noch.
Und dann müssen wir die
Quest im PvP-Gebiet
machen. Da hoffe ich,
dass ich nicht abgefarmt werde.
Nehm ich mir am besten
noch ein paar Leute aus der Gilde mit.
Weil Solo-Runi mit
Level-Equip
ist halt jetzt nicht so geil.
Cannot use while in combat.
Bin auch gar nicht in Combat.
Lügt nicht, Game.
Fünf von fünf, please.
Nein. Nee, vier von fünf.
Ach ja, wir müssen aus welchen Gründen auch
immer Eier von den Viechern sammeln.
Und wie sammelt man Eier von den Viechern?
Natürlich, indem man sie killt.
Logisch. Wer kennt's nicht?
Also...
Man muss auch immer seine Hühner
umnuken, wenn man Eier von denen will.
Vier von fünf.
Da kann ja mal was droppen jetzt.
Just MMO-Logik.
Troppen, please.
Troppen. Fünf von fünf. Jawoll. Fünf von fünf.
Okay, geschafft.
Und jetzt muss ich
zurück nach Hagal. Sehr schön. Machen wir doch.
Minecraft China droppen
auch beim Killen. Na, okay.
Wissen wir ja. Wenn das in Minecraft so ist,
dann ist das die Referenz. Dann ist klar.
Alles klar. Aber ich mein,
Minecraft war auch früher. Dann versteh ich das schon.
Ey, die Leute
sind teilweise so wir im Kopf.
Man kann die so geil trollen.
Es gibt im
Wenn du hier im Chat schreibst,
so nach dem Motto
World of Warcraft
war das erste MMO.
Daog hat sich auch so vieles davon
abgeguckt. Dann hast du gleich Leute,
die ankommen. Ah, du erzählst
Scheiße. World of Warcraft war
doch viel später. War doch irgendwie
2005 und Daog war doch 2001.
Und was erzählst du für einen Blödsinn?
Und da musst du einfach weiter
schreibe, so nach dem Motto.
Nein, ich weiß es genau.
Ich hab's damals zum Release gespielt.
World of Warcraft war zuerst.
Die flamen dich.
Die wollen dich quasi förmlich umbringen.
Allein schon, weil du sowas schreibst.
Die checken es nicht, dass das einfach nur
dummes
Gelaber ist, man.
Das ist so der, so obvious
Troll, wo man eigentlich
gar nicht drauf einsteigen sollte.
Das ist genauso, wie ich's
in Overwatch immer, oder generell, wie man
die Leute in Overwatch immer trollen
konnte, wenn du sagst, hier, sag nichts
dazu, wenn du nicht hohen MMR
hast, also mindestens 2000 plus.
Wer es nicht weiß, 2000 plus
MMR, Match Rating, in Overwatch ist
glaub ich Platin oder sowas. Das ist mega schlecht.
Da springen die, da springen sie total drauf an.
Generell kannst du online
die Leute übelst triggern, wenn du schreibst
World of Warcraft war das erste MMO.
Es gibt Leute, die meinen das legit ernst.
Die sind dumm,
aber
wenn ich sowas blödes schreib, dann nur um
die Leute ein bisschen zu ärgern.
So, ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Gut, dass ich mein Home Assistant
hab und dafür nicht aufstehen muss.
Decke, Licht an, perfekt.
Also, jetzt bin ich hier rausgeportet,
jetzt kann ich mal kurz was dazu sagen. Also wie gesagt,
wenn ihr Albion spielen wollt,
Kaba,
guter Einstiegs-Char, wenn man so auf
Utility Caster und generell
Range DPS steht. Cleric,
wenn man auf Support steht, eines der, finde ich,
besten Einstiegs-Chars.
Gerade in Albion ist
ein super, super
Beginner, auch
beginnerfreundlicher Char.
Da lernt man auch viel über Mechanics
in dem Game als Supporter,
weil du darauf angewiesen bist, dass andere Leute was für dich
machen. Ist aber auch sehr
rewarding, wenn man es kann und ist nicht schwer zu
spielen. Also Cleric ist wirklich nice.
So, aber als nächstes
auf Deutsch nannte sich
das Ordensbruder, diese Klasse.
Kann man sich jetzt streiten drüber,
ob das eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist oder nicht.
Ist vielleicht mit die beste
PvE-Geld-Farm-Klasse in dem Spiel,
aber
ich finde jetzt nicht unbedingt die allerbeste
Einstiegsklasse.
Die ist mir persönlich nicht universell
genug. Infi auf jeden Fall
keine Einstiegsklasse, es sei denn,
man mag Schleicher, würde ich aber niemandem empfehlen,
Schleicher anzufangen. Keine Einstiegsklasse.
Heretic finde ich auch keine
allzu gute Einstiegsklasse. Mag ich
allgemein nicht, auch wenn die gerade
Zerg-Fights ziemlich
gut ist. Ich mag Heretic nicht.
als Klasse.
Mauler gibt es auf jeden nicht. Mercenary.
Mercenary ist ein reiner
Nahkampf, DPS,
Damage-Dealer, finde ich ist keine gute
Einstiegsklasse. Minstrel
ist auf jeden Fall definitiv keine
gute Einstiegsklasse. Die brauchst
du zwar überall, ja, ist eines der wichtigsten
und, also Minstrel ist eines der besten
Klassen im Spiel, wenn nicht
die beste Solo-Klasse.
Aber, und die universellste
Solo-Klasse auf jeden Fall.
Und auch in Gruppen ultra beliebt,
aber nicht gerade
easy zu spielen. Also
keine gute Einstiegsklasse. Nekro
super PvE
Farming Char, aber auch keine
wirklich erste Einstiegsklasse
wie ich finde, weil sie
in Gruppen jetzt nicht so geil ist.
Also, weiß ich nicht, Nekro ist nicht
meins. Pala. Pala ist so
ein Ding, ganz viele Leute, die neu sind
in dem Spiel, mögen Pala.
Ich glaube, es gibt zwei Klassen in dem Spiel,
die alle Noobs spielen.
Das ist, Leute, die in Albion anfangen,
machen sich gefühlt 90%
in Paladin und Leute, die in Midgard
anfangen, machen sich
zu 90%
einen Donnerkrieger, weil Tor
und Hammer und sowas.
Man muss sagen,
von den ganzen Nahkämpfern
ist Pala vielleicht
noch der bessere Einstiegs-,
aber ich finde auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Du musst
relativ, auf relativ viel achten,
deinen Auren und
es ist
ein Nahkampf-Char.
Und ich finde generell Nahkampf-Chars für Einsteiger
nicht so gut. Also, Pala geht noch.
Pala würde eventuell, wenn man
unbedingt so auf
Ritter-Rüstung und sowas steht und was in der
Richtung spielen will, Pala ist
auf Eden nicht übel.
Pala hat auf Eden jede Menge neue Sachen bekommen.
Aber
zum Beispiel kannst du mit Pala jetzt wenigstens
nennenswert 2-Hand-Damage machen auf Eden, was
auf Live nicht ging. Nur, wenn man
so einen Typ mit Ritter-Rüstung unbedingt
spielen will, dann Pala. Aber ich finde, das ist kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Ansonsten muss man sagen, ist
Pala ein ziemlich guter PvE-Tank.
Wenn nicht der...
Ja, vielleicht nicht der beste...
Also, einer der besten PvE-Tanks.
Aber ich finde, für den Einstieg ist
es nicht gut. Reaver...
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ist aber
vielleicht kein komplett
reiner Nahkampf-Char, aber
das Nennenswerte, was der Reaver gut kann, ist Nahkampf.
Die anderen Sachen sind
eher so nebenbei. Du hast so ein bisschen
glaube ich so einen Range-Live-Tap und sowas,
den du alle, frag mich nicht, 10 Sekunden
oder so machen kannst, aber
man kann nicht sagen, dass
Reaver irgendwie ein Range-Charakter wäre.
Also Reaver ist ein Nahkampf-Charakter
mit Schild
und Peitsche, der mit seinem
Backstyle übelst Damage macht.
Ist cooler als Off-Tank,
aber auch
kein guter Einstiegs-Char. Scout auch kein guter
Einstiegs-Char.
Zork...
Eines der besten Caster im Spiel, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Allein schon von den Möglichkeiten,
die du hast, aber auch kein guter Einstiegs-Char.
Zork ist, finde ich, für mich
eines meiner Lieblings... meiner Lieblings...
Klassen, die es
in dem Spiel gibt. Also auf Alp-Level
ich eigentlich immer als erstes Zork.
Zork
ist ein bisschen wie Heiler, nur ohne
heilen.
Zork ist ein cooler... ist ein mega, mega
Charakter. Du kannst... du hast ein Pet,
du hast einen ziemlich fetten Nuke,
je nachdem, was du
specst, aber auch der
Base-Nuke ist nicht schlecht, also Single-Target-Damage
und du hast halt massig
Möglichkeiten,
was du machen kannst
als Zork. Du hast super hohen
Cast-Speed, du kannst Gegner
unterbrechen, du kannst Gegner sleepen,
du kannst Gegner Area sleepen,
Area routen, Single-Target routen,
ihre Zauber vergessen
lassen... ist mega.
Ist eines der besten,
die es gibt im Spiel, aber finde
ich nicht gut als Einstiegsklasse.
Da finde ich
Kabba als Einstiegs-Caster tatsächlich
besser. Ich glaube nicht, dass
Zork ein guter Einstiegs-Char ist.
Debuffs hast du noch, ja. Also Zork ist
sehr komplex und man
ist wahrscheinlich als Einsteiger relativ
schnell überfordert mit einer Zork. Turk
kann man als Einsteiger spielen, finde ich.
Turk ist ziemlich braindead, gerade im BG.
Ist so ziemlich der OP-ste Char,
mit den Icepads, den es im BG gibt.
Turk kann man spielen als Einsteiger.
Das ist eine Klasse, die kann
Pads beschwören. Die hat kein einzelnes Pad,
wie beispielsweise eine Zork oder
ein Kabba oder eine Minne, sondern Turk
kann Elementarpads beschwören.
Du hast Erdpads,
Icepads und
Erdpads.
Die Icepads casten,
die Luftpads
stunnen, die Erdpads
halten ein bisschen mehr aus, rennen schneller und unterbrechen
Gegner. Dafür hast du einen ziemlich
starken Nuke, aber
ich finde, die beste Einstiegsklasse
in Albion, so blöd es klingt, wenn man
Caster spielen will, ist
wahrscheinlich, vor allem die einfachste,
Wizard.
Wizard hat den höchsten
Single-Target-Nuke-Damage,
ohne Debuffs,
jetzt mal außen vor,
und ist ähnlich wie der Rooney
zu spielen.
Du hast zwei Bowls, theoretisch
kannst du sogar bis zu drei haben, aber
der dritte ist nicht so der Rede wert.
Du hast Bowls,
du hast Single-Target-Damage,
sogar noch mehr als der Rooney,
und Wizard ist
simpel,
super für
Battle-Group-Fights,
also irgendwie 50 gegen 50,
super AE-Damage, super Range-Damage,
super Bowldamage
und easy zu spielen.
Mit Wizard hast du ungefähr
so viel belegt, wie ich auf der Leiste
hier. Du hast quasi die Hälfte der Leiste noch frei.
Du machst richtig
krass Damage,
und du bist eigentlich überall begehrt,
wenn es um Zerg-Fights geht,
mit größeren Gruppen, weil
AE-Damage und Wizard. Also wenn man einsteigen
will und einen Caster spielen will,
in Albion, würde ich sagen, wenn ihr
reinen DPS-Range-Damage-Dealer
spielen wollt, spielt Wizard.
Ihr könnt Wizard übrigens auch
super leveln, dann aber nicht mit Feuer, sondern
mit Eis,
oder Cover, wer so ein bisschen
Utility-lastige Sachen mit Pet machen
will. Also die zwei Sachen würde ich sagen.
Für Supporter, Cleric,
für Pet-Caster, Cover, für
DPS-Caster, Wizard.
Also ich würde empfehlen,
die drei zum Einstieg in Albion.
Da kann man nicht viel falsch machen,
alle drei sind mega beliebt in Gruppen.
Du kannst super leveln,
und die sind nicht so kompliziert,
dass du gar nicht mitkommst.
Midgard-Klassen,
Bersi,
reiner Nahkampf-Char würde ich nicht
als Einstiegsklasse wählen.
Vermutlich,
ich habe jetzt keine Benchmarks,
ich habe jetzt keine Tests,
vermutlich
dürfte der Bersi der Nahkampf-Char
sein, mit dem höchsten Burst-Damage.
Eventuell der Savage,
also in Burst-Situation,
der Bersi kann sich
in einen Bär verwandeln,
wer hätte das gedacht, und dann ist
jeder, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob es jeder Schlag ist, aber ich glaube,
jeder Schlag ist ein Crit.
Bersi ist eine reine
Double-Wheel-Nahkampf-Klasse,
der aber auch
Zweihand ausrüsten kann.
Überlegt euch,
ihr seid gebufft bis oben hin,
habt gutes Equip, holt eine
Zweihand-Waffe raus,
und schlagt mit jedem Treffer
einen Crit. Also Bersi kann
richtig gut Damage, und auch richtig
krassen Burst-Damage machen.
Wenn ich eines der höchsten
Melee-Damages im Spiel für kurze
Zeit, ich würde vielleicht sogar sagen,
der höchste Melee-Damage im Spiel
für kurze Zeit, konstant, so über
sagen wir mal 20 Sekunden oder so,
aber Bersi ist eine reine Nahkampf-Klasse,
die auch außer Nahkampf-Damage
nichts kann, gar nichts.
Dafür kann sie das ganz gut,
und trotzdem
finde ich für Einsteiger nichts,
weil reine Nahkampf-Klasse.
Bone Dancer ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Bone Dancer dürfte
bei Caster neben Rooney
wahrscheinlich mit die beste Einstiegsklasse
von Midgard sein, weil
Bone Dancer ist easy
zu leveln, kannst du super Solo
spielen, du kannst alles
killen, was es gibt in dem Spiel
als Bone Dancer mit deinen Pets,
und du bist sogar noch
semi-gut,
was PvP angeht,
selbst in der Level-Spec.
Da kannst du ein bisschen Dot rumspammen
und alles vergiften und kriegst ein bisschen
Punkte zwischendurch. Ich würde für
reines FvR
vielleicht später umspecken, oder für
Pro-Fights vielleicht was anderes nehmen,
aber als Einstiegsklasse ist Bone Dancer
wirklich gut, um so die Mechanics
vom Game zu lernen, weil du bist
relativ safe. Du hast dein...
Ich kann euch das sogar mal zeigen. Ich hab ja nen Bone Dancer.
Lul.
Bevor ich jetzt hier labere, ich kann euch auch
die Hexe mal zeigen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich muss ja aber einen Grund haben,
dass ich so viel Zeug gelevelt hab.
Ich log mal kurz auf den Bone Dancer um.
Ja, Suppression ist easy, aber ich würde Bone Army
zum Leveln spielen.
Bone Dancer.
Ich porte jetzt mal irgendwo hin.
Wo ist ein paar...
Die Weihnachts-NPCs könnte man vielleicht
auch mal wieder entfernen, so langsam.
So. Jetzt zeige ich euch mal,
warum Bone Dancer ein super Einstiegs-Char ist.
Wenn es denn irgendwann mal portet.
So.
Achso, ich hätte mir vielleicht mal Speed
holen sollen.
Bone Dancer hat kein Speed.
Superschnell.
Ich flieg jetzt mal kurz wohin, wo es Gegner
gibt, die ein bisschen...
aushalten, die nicht One-Hit sind.
So. Aber wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach
Bone Dancer eines der besten Einstiegs-Chars,
die es in Midgard gibt.
Weil sie... weil er
bisschen...
fehlertolerant ist, in gewisser Weise.
Gerade wenn man Caster spielt und man ist neu
in dem Spiel, gerade wenn ihr beispielsweise mit Wizard
oder so anfangt, dann ist halt das Ding...
Wizard kann halt außer Damage nix.
Dafür ist Wizard simpel zu spielen.
Aber sobald ein Gegner oder halt ein Monster
an euch ran ist, müsst ihr wegrennen.
Ihr könnt halt sonst nix machen. Ihr müsst wegrennen, und dann geht's.
Ihr könnt euch umdrehen, den Gegner umnuken.
Das ist mit Bone Dancer...
Wie hieß...
Wie hieß das?
Hieß der Knochentänzer auf Deutsch?
Glaub schon.
Ich muss mal kurz runterjumpen.
Keck wait.
So. Also. Warum Bone Dancer
eines der besten Einsteiger-Chars in dem Game ist.
Ihr seid nicht alleine.
Denn...
Ihr habt ein Pet.
Und ihr habt nicht so, wie viele andere Klassen,
wie viele andere Pet-Klassen in dem Spiel,
ein Pet.
Nein, ihr habt bis zu 4 Pets.
Und...
Auch keine super Low-Level-Pets.
Sondern doch
ganz annehmbare
Pets.
So. Ich werd das jetzt gleich mal beschwören.
Wenn ich hier ein paar Gegner
gefunden hab.
Auf die ich draufhauen kann.
Ich bin halt...
Ich bin halt super, super geschwind gerade.
Hab ich nicht die Bounty Points?
Ne, ich hab hier kein Bounty Points
Speed-Ding.
Hätte ich mir vielleicht mal holen sollen grad.
Na gut. Da müssen wir jetzt noch
eine Minute in die Richtung laufen,
bis ich ein paar Gegner gefunden hab.
Auf! Beweg dich!
Gib Gas!
Da sind welche. Okay, da sind...
Da sind rote. Also die sind schon relativ hoch.
So. Und als Bone Dancer
hast du einmal deinen Commander-Pet.
Zu dem Commander-Pet kannst du
bis zu 3 weitere Pets beschwören.
Nein! Anki, kannst du 3 weitere
Pets beschwören?
Ich mach jetzt mal reine Nahkampf-Pets.
Dann kannst du deine eigenen Pets
buffen. Mehr Nahkampf-Damage,
mehr Stärke.
Oh, hab ich jetzt 3 beschworen?
Dazu kannst du noch, wenn du
Champion-Level geskillt hast,
kannst du sogar noch deine
Pets Single-Target
buffen. Das
erspare ich mir jetzt mal.
Weil das eine halbe Stunde dauert, bis ich
gefühlt hier alle Pets mit diesen Buffs versorgt hab.
So. Und dann
gehst du zum Gegner hin,
pullst den Gegner raus mit deinem
Instant, schickst die Pets drauf
und freust dich, dass du so viel
Damage an roten Gegnern machst.
Und wenn du Bock hast, kannst du sogar noch
Dots drauf machen.
Und er ist weg. Easy.
So. Und sollte
dein Pet mal sterben
oder irgendwie low
life sein, kannst du sogar noch selbst heilen.
So. Und aus dem
Grund verzeiht Bone Dancer quasi alles.
Selbst, selbst wenn du drei
rote, drei rote Mobs pullst oder so,
ist das kein Ding. Da sagst du, hups,
hups, ich hab jetzt ein bisschen zu viele gepullt.
Da routest du mal einen, dann kann er sich nicht
bewegen. Der Typ kommt, da schickst du dein
Pet drauf und hier den nukest du um.
Du hast ja, du hast ja zusätzlich auch noch,
darf man nicht vergessen, du hast einen gar nicht so schlechten
Single-Target-Damage als
Bone Dancer. Also als Bone Dancer
bist du Damage,
DPS-Caster,
AE-Dot-Spammer und hast
vier richtig gute Pets.
Und
du hast auch nicht so viele Skills, dass du
nicht mehr durchblickst, was du alles machen kannst.
Und dementsprechend finde ich, ist Bone Dancer
in Midgard eines der wirklich richtig
guten Einstiegsklassen.
Und dazu kommt, Bone Dancer
ist gut für Geldfarmen in
PvE.
Vielleicht eines der besten im Spiel, wenn's
wenn's um Money,
Money machen geht in dem Spiel.
Und er ist easy zu spielen.
Und es ist ein Caster mit
ein bisschen Abwechslung, ja, weil du deine Pets
du kannst deine Pets auch umstellen.
Du kannst deinen Pets sagen, hier, ich will, dass
sie unterschiedliche Targets angreift, dass sie
das gleiche Targets angreift.
Du kannst sagen, hier, ich will, dass der Typ mit
Zweihandschwert rumrennt. Guck jetzt hat er
Zweihandschwert und machte noch mehr Damage auf die Gegner.
Und so spielt sich Bone Dancer
mehr oder weniger von Level 1 an.
Nur der Unterschied ist, dass ihr nicht gleich von Level 1
an drei Pets haben könntet. Das gibt's erst später.
Jo.
Und Bone Dancer verzeiht relativ viel,
selbst wenn ihr mal nicht aufgepasst habt.
Bone Dancer ist ein super Farm-Char.
Bone Dancer ist ein super Char in Battle Crowns.
Bone Dancer ist ein guter Char
im RvR.
Also, besser,
eines der besten Einstiegs-Chars in Midgard, Bone Dancer.
Danach gibt's Heiler.
Und ihr bedenkt euch jetzt vielleicht, ey, guck mal,
ich war noch so ein großer
Fan von dem Heiler
in Albion, quasi Clary,
als Einstiegs-Char.
Ich würde sagen, Heiler in Midgard nur
bedingt als Einstiegs-Char.
Du kannst Heiler auf zwei Arten spielen.
Du kannst Heiler
auf Heiler-Art spielen,
oder du kannst Heiler auf, sagen wir mal,
auf Hexe spielen.
Also als
Main Heiler,
oder als Main, sagen wir mal,
Main Interrupter
Schrägstrich
Damage-Vermeider.
Und wenn du Heiler als
Main Healer spielst, ist das kein Ding.
Das ist ein sehr guter Einstiegs-Char,
genauso wie Cleric.
Also so was, so eine Mischung aus
Buffen und
Buffen und Heilen.
Dann ist es ein guter Einstiegs-Char,
da muss man sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken machen.
Aber, wenn du den als CC
spielen willst, oder
als Main,
wie kann man das jemandem erklären, dann spielen nicht die Spieler.
So als,
wenn du Heiler nicht auf
Heilen speckst und auf Buffen,
sondern auf diese dritte Linie, dann bist du halt
dafür zuständig, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Gegner
eigentlich kein Damage an dir machen können.
Das ist eines der stressigsten und
anspruchsvollsten Sachen, die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Also ich würde sagen,
Heiler ist
die schwierigste Klasse im Spiel.
Wenn man sie so speckt.
Manche Heiler sind besonders
abgedreht. Mein Battleground-Heiler
zum Beispiel, der ist Tree-Speck.
Beziehungsweise
speck ich Tree-Speck, dann kannst du von allem
bisschen was, dann fallen dir die Hände ab.
Also wenn du Heiler,
also wenn du den Char
spielen wollt, der
sehr schwierig zu meistern ist, dann ist Heiler
eben auf dieser Skillung euer
Ding. Aber als Einstieg auf jeden Fall
nicht geeignet. Definitiv nicht.
Da musst du nahezu jede
Daunt-Mechanik wissen, dass du Heiler
gut spielen kannst.
Wenn ihr Heiler auf Buffen und Heilen speckt,
würde ich sagen,
ist es ähnlich zu empfehlen, wie
ein Clary zum Einstieg.
Wenn auch immer noch ein bisschen
komplizierter, wie ich finde, als ein Clary.
Ist aber auch ein ganz guter Einstiegs-Char,
wenn man eben nicht auf
diese ich-brauch-5-Hände-zum-spielen
Skillung geht.
Aber primär würde ich sagen,
dann vielleicht eher einen Clary,
wenn man auf Albion Bock hat.
Daug ist immer noch Bestgame, Bestgame einfach.
Wir gucken uns gerade die Character-Klassen an,
weil ein paar Leute gesagt haben, sie
wollen sich runterladen und
spielen. Wollte ich gerade mal ein bisschen
Senf dazu geben, was gute und schlechte Einstiegs sind.
Also Heiler, gute Einstiegsklasse,
wenn man auf Buffen und Heilen
geht, sehr schlechte, wenn nicht
die schlechteste Einstiegsklasse im ganzen
Game, wenn man auf Puck geht.
Beziehungsweise auf, wie nannte sich das
auf Deutsch, die Skill-Linie? Befrieden
hieß das, glaube ich.
Da haben sie wieder
zugeschlagen bei der Übersetzung.
Nächster,
Hunter, keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Stealth-Star gefällt mir nicht, Mauler gibt's nicht.
Runemaster, gute Einstiegsklasse.
Bisschen wie Wizard.
Also
sehr vergleichbar mit Wizard,
muss man eigentlich sagen.
Man könnte sagen, Wizard und
Runi sind, zumindest auf
zumindest ein Feuer-Wizard und
ein Rune-Carving-Runi
sind,
obwohl sie in unterschiedlichen Reichen sind,
sagen wir mal zu 80%
die gleiche Klasse,
was du sonst in Darog eigentlich nicht hast.
Bowndancer ist eine super Einstiegsklasse,
ja? Hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Deswegen bin ich extra auf meinen
Bowndancer gelockt. Bowndancer ist
eines der besten Einstiegsklassen, gerade
in Midgard. So, wenn ihr
sagt, ey, also,
Pet und
Dots und so Zeug
und so, das ist alles nicht meins.
Ich will eigentlich einfach nur einen
Range-DPS-Caster, der richtig gut Damage macht
und im Zweifelsfall auch mal Gegner 2 hittet,
dann müsst ihr Runemaster spielen.
Ist dementsprechend,
habt ihr jetzt auch schon oft genug gesehen,
ist dementsprechend auch relativ easy. Ich lock mal
wieder zurück.
Ihr seht ja hier meine
Bowndancer-Quickbars, die sind mehr oder
weniger alle voll.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal auf meine,
gehen wir mal auf den Runi zurück,
den wir jetzt auch weiterspielen müssen, nämlich Epic machen.
Gehen wir mal,
gehen wir mal auf den Runi zurück.
Pox Champ.
Da werdet ihr sehen, da sind viel
weniger Quickbars belegt.
Ja, ja, viel weniger
belegt.
Und Runi hat halt auch
nur im Prinzip diese 4 Spells.
Single Target Damage, Single
Target Damage, also besonders hoch,
Single Target Damage, Single Target Damage,
Area Damage, so.
Im Prinzip wie der Wizard.
Also wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt einen reinen DPS, Range
DPS Caster, der auch mal Gegner
two-shotten kann, dann Runi, finde ich
jetzt auch eine gute Einstiegsklasse, wenn man auf sowas
steht.
Savage,
ich sag mal, auch wenn sich da die
Spieler wahrscheinlich jetzt aufregen werden und sagen,
das ist doch was ganz anderes, ist ein bisschen wie
der Bersi. Ohne
Bersi zu sein, ist
eines der Nahkampfklassen mit dem
höchsten Burst Damage im Game.
Ihr erkennt da vielleicht ein Thema,
ursprünglich vom Design-Helfer Midgard
eher so als Nahkampf-Realm
gedacht, Albion eher so
als, ja, Ritter
und Plattenrüstung und
Hibernia eher so als Magie-Realm.
Es ist ein bisschen immer noch so, aber im Prinzip
kannst du eigentlich alle 3
Realms auf unterschiedliche Arten spielen.
Also kannst du in Albion Nahkampf- und Castergruppen machen,
wobei,
ich sagen würde, eigentlich sind
Alp-Castergruppen schon
sehr nice. Du kannst in Hip,
Nahkampf- und Castergruppen spielen.
Du kannst auch in Mid-Nahkampf- und Castergruppen
spielen oder Hybrid-Gruppen spielen.
Es geht beides.
Aber Savage ist insofern ähnlich wie Bersi
und das trifft die ähnlichen Sachen
zu, die ich gesagt habe zum Bersi.
Reiner Nahkämpfer
mit ein bisschen mehr Gimmicks als
der Bersi. Du hast ein paar Self-Buffs
und kannst
ordentlich Damage machen.
I'm playing on
Eden Season 2
3 Shards.
Jo.
Also Savage ist keine gute
Einstiegsklasse. Find ich
nicht gut. Allein schon,
weil es reiner Nahkämpfer ist.
Valkyrie, very strong.
I think it
depends. It's one
of the least interesting
Classes for me.
I usually don't play much
Melee Classes.
But it's nice that they
have the Catacombs Classes.
I'm missing the Warlock.
Warlock
would be very POC.
But maybe they
have the Warlock in Season 3.
Because
on one of the
earlier
iterations from Eden
it was called
Celestials, they had the Warlock.
So it looks like they have
already Warlocks
implemented, but didn't
want it in Season 2.
I would really like
to have Warlocks in it.
Okay, Leute.
Also, wie gesagt, Savage
keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Reiner Nahkampf-Char, gleiche Problem
wie immer. So, nächstes
Shadowplate, Stelzer, vergesst's.
Auch keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Shami! Gute Einstiegsklasse.
Wenn ihr Bock drauf habt,
einen Heiler zu spielen, der
auch super nervig für die Gegner
sein kann, dann ist, und wie das
passt, ich hab sogar einen Shami am
Start, um euch was zu zeigen.
Weil ich ja irgendwie
einen krassen PvE-Grind gemacht hab die ganze Zeit.
Ich kann euch auch noch einen Shami
zeigen, wenn es jetzt mal auslockt.
So, Shami.
Wenn ihr Bock habt drauf, einen Heiler zu spielen,
aber euch ein Heiler
so mit Buff-Heal
ein bisschen zu sehr Support
ist, dann ist vielleicht der
Shami was für euch. Der finde ich jetzt
auch eine super Einstiegsklasse, weil
jeder braucht einen Shami in der Gruppe.
Weil
der hat einen Buffer in Midgard.
Main Buffer
in Midgard, aber
als Shami kannst du enorm
nervig sein.
Porten wir mal wieder hier hin.
Als Shami kannst
du enorm nervig sein. Du hast ordentliche
Kettenrüstung, das heißt, du hältst ein bisschen was aus.
Du kannst ganz passabel
heilen als Shami.
Du kannst super
buffen.
Also du hast einen ganz brauchbaren Single-Target
Heal hier. Das ist, ja, siehst du hier.
Punkte geheilt. Das ist schon ganz okay.
Aber, was den Shami ausmacht
ist, du hast
richtig gute Buffs. Deswegen
braucht jeder in der Gruppe einen Shami.
Du hast richtig gute Buffs.
Du hast wichtige Resis.
Also, dass man
mehr Resistenzen hat hier gegen Hitze,
Kälte und Meta-Damage ist es, glaube ich.
Braucht auch jede Gruppe. Und du hast
Endu, dass die ganzen Nahkämpfer mehr Ausdauer
haben. Sehr wichtig.
Das sind die Dinger,
jeder will einen Shami haben. Und
das Schöne am Shami ist, im Vergleich zum
Heiler, du hast noch ein
bisschen, bisschen Damage
und du hast vor allem
einen, den krassesten
Nervfaktoren im ganzen Spiel.
Du hast einen Bolt, wo du ein bisschen, oh, ich hab die
Effekte aus, kann das sein?
Effekts all.
Du hast einen Bolt, macht natürlich
nicht so viel wie der Huni.
Hast einen Bolt, kannst du Damage machen.
Du hast einen Dot, kannst du Damage machen drauf.
Und mit CL,
mit CL hast du sogar noch ein bisschen Nahkampfschaden.
Also du kannst, du kannst
als Shami auch ein bisschen was killen.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt die primäre Aufgabe des
Shamis, was zu killen.
Die primäre Aufgabe vom Shami ist
Support, also quasi Sekundärheiler,
Buffen und
Nerven. Und ich glaube,
es gibt wenig, wenige
Charakter, also wenige Klassen in dem
in dem Spiel, die so krass nerven können
wie ein Shami. Du kannst
Buffs entfernen von Gegnern.
Kannst Gegner,
wie heißt, wie soll man das auf
Deutsch nennen, verseuchen oder so.
Dann sind 50%
weniger effektive Heals aufsehen.
Du kannst Dotten, du kannst,
du hast eine E dort, du hast eine E solche.
Du bist einfach mega, mega nervig
als Shami.
Also wenn man so einen Hybrid haben will,
aus Heiler,
primär Buffer und ein bisschen
DPS und
Nerven, ist Shami richtig gut.
Und ich finde, Shami ist eines der
besten Einstiegsklassen in Midgard.
Shami ist super.
Alle brauchen Shamis
und
ich finde, er macht auch mega Bock zu spielen.
Haben wir DF?
Oh, wir haben DF!
Leute, ich erzähl euch weiter.
Ich sticke mal kurz.
Ich geh mal kurz in DF rein.
Und
ja, wir haben DF.
Ich geh mal kurz in DF rein und greif ein paar
Siegel ab, während ich hier eh nur
rumstehe und am Schwätzen bin.
Äh, Moment, was mach ich denn hier überhaupt?
Ja, DF.
Nein.
So, ähm, dann machen wir weiter.
Skalde,
wenn ihr unbedingt
einen Nahkampfcharakter als euren ersten
Held spielen willst,
bist du gerade im BG, wenn ich richtig
nein, bin ich nicht. Ich bin gerade in SI gewesen.
Jetzt bin ich
zurückgeportet in unsere Grenzfestung
und
geh nach DF.
Dann warte ich bis, äh,
oder falls die
irgendwie raiden wollen oder so.
Dann kann ich ein bisschen Currency abgreifen,
während ich eh nur am Schwätzen bin.
Ja.
Echt, nach welchem BG sah's aus?
Vielleicht, vielleicht ein bisschen Kartal Valley
an der, an der,
auf der
Mid-Seite vielleicht.
Aber
die Textur plops.
Also Shami kann ich euch wirklich nur wärmstens empfehlen.
Es hat auch einen riesen Vorteil,
Shami zu sein, ja.
Wenn ihr Gruppen sucht, ich bin gerade in die
Battlegroup gejoint. Leute,
BG Count, wie viel, wie viel haben wir?
29 sind nicht so viele.
Ich, ich, ich warte mal. Passt mal auf,
bis wir, ich zeig euch
das gleich. Ihr müsst in ne Battlegroup gehen
und schreiben, Shami looking for
Group. Es dauert 5 Sekunden,
dann habt ihr 5 Group, dann habt ihr 5
Group-Invites.
So, der ist noch in Upland.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bleib mal kurz, ich bleib mal kurz
in DF, bis es, bis es losgeht.
Ja, also
dementsprechend kann man Shami super empfehlen
als Einstiegsklasse. So, Skalde,
wenn ihr unbedingt nen Nahkämpfer spielen wollt,
also wenn ihr euch jetzt selbst von
meinem Gelaber hier nicht
habt ausreden lassen,
eine Nahkampfklasse als euren ersten
als euren, als eure erste Klasse
zu spielen und ihr unbedingt Mid-Guard
spielt, dann spielt in Skalde. Skalde ist easy.
Skalde ist gebraucht,
weil Speed
und
Skalde ist zwar Nahkämpfer, aber hat immer
noch ganz gute so Escape-Options,
dadurch, dass du Speed hast.
Ich würde es euch trotzdem nicht unbedingt als
allererste, als allererste
Klasse empfehlen, aber wenn ihr
einen Nahkampfheld, also
eine Nahkampfklasse spielen wollt,
dann nehmt Skalde in Mid.
So, Spiritmaster,
ich persönlich finde
Spiritmaster eigentlich
nie sonderlich geil, ist überhaupt nicht meine
Klasse. Ist ein Caster
mit nem Pet, der ziemlich gut
Close-Range-Damage
machen kann,
oder auch Range-Damage,
der im BG ziemlich stark ist,
gerade weil du Kobold
wählen kannst als Rasse
und in Richtung
K-Speed auch kriegst ohne gescheite Items.
Also,
wenn man eine Pet-Klasse spielen will
zum Start in Mid-Guard,
gibt es ja nicht viel zur Auswahl, ja?
Bone-Dancer und Spiritmaster.
Dann würde ich immer Bone-Dancer vorziehen als
Spiritmaster vs. Spiritmaster.
Spiritmaster ist nicht schlecht,
es gibt Leute, die schwören total auf Spiritmaster
und gerade im größeren PvP
gibt es immer ein paar
Groups, die sich in Türme hocken
mit Spiritmaster und die verteidigen wollen.
Ich bin kein Spiritmaster-Fan.
Ich sage es euch ganz ehrlich,
wenn ihr diesen Style mögt
von Spiritmaster, dann
würde ich
eher nen End spielen in Hip.
Aber
es ist auf jeden Fall keine
komplizierte und miese Einstellung.
Ich mag Spiritmaster nicht.
Ich werde eingeladen.
Guck mal, ich habe noch nicht mal
gefragt
Ich habe noch nicht mal
nach Gruppe
und ich werde schon eingeladen.
Aber ich will jetzt eigentlich noch gar keine Group.
So.
Den größten Fehler, den ganz viele
Dark-Noobs machen
ist
sie fangen mit Donnerkrieger an.
Weil
Donnerkrieger
so Tor und Hammer und Blitze
und das finden alle total geil.
Und alle Dark-Noobs, die in Midgard
anfangen, die
So, ich gehe wieder aus Coop raus.
Also, ich warte jetzt
bis sie DF gehen, während ich hier am Labern bin.
So, ich stelle mich auch mal
auf AFK. Also viele
Leute, die neu in dem Spiel sind und Midgard anfangen,
die wollen Donnerkrieger spielen. Warum?
Hammer, Tor, Blitze und so
ganz furchtbar geil.
Ich finde nicht, dass Donnerkrieger
eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist.
Manche werden sagen, ey
von allen Tanks und so ist es auch die beste
Einstiegsklasse. Donnerkrieger ist
ein Nahkampf
Casting Hybrid.
Der beides braucht.
Der aber
vor allem auch ein bisschen Feingefühl
für die jeweilige Gamesituation
braucht. Donnerkrieger sind
wahrscheinlich die noobigste
Klasse.
Den ganz Midgard,
die auch am meisten gehasst wird,
weil Donnerkrieger dazu neigen
jegliches CC
mit nicht Damage machenden
Hämmern wieder zu brechen.
Also,
wenn ihr beispielsweise Hexe spielt oder Heiler
spielt, könnt ihr ja Gegner
sleepen.
Und das Problem ist,
das wird gebrochen durch Damage.
Und Donnerkrieger
haben einen
Charplan Akaya.
Jetzt geht es aber los.
Dankeschön.
Übertreib mich Akaya.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oder für die 10 Subs.
Dankeschön, da hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Nice.
Sehr nice.
Donnerkrieger haben
sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Direct Damage, AE und
sind das hier die
Hämmer?
Ja, ich glaub das sind die Hämmer.
Zumindest ist das Problem an dem
Damage von Donnerkrieger,
es macht nicht viel Damage,
bricht jegliches CC und ist einfach nur Abfuck.
Das heißt, als Donnerkrieger ist es
sehr sinnvoll,
wenn man ein bisschen Gefühl für das
Game hat, weil man muss
casten, man kann,
man ist gar kein schlechter Caster,
man ist quasi ein Tank mit
Caster-Fähigkeiten, das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich,
mir fällt glaube ich
keinem anderen MMO ein,
so ein Hybrid wie Donnerkrieger,
aber es ist keine Noob-Klasse.
Leider spielen ihn fast alle Leute,
die neu in Midgard sind, machen sie als erste Klasse
Donnerkrieger, aber ich finde, es ist keine gute
Einstiegsklasse, weil man gewisse,
gewisses Gespür dafür
haben muss in dem Game, wann man was macht
mit Donnerkrieger und das hast du nicht, wenn du neu
bist. Wenn du neu bist, hast du Tunnelblick,
Gegner gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm, Gruppe Gegner,
Hämmer rein, Hämmer rein und im Zweifelsfall,
wenn kein Mana oder man
nicht richtig casten kann, dann reinrennen und sterben.
Ich finde, Donnerkrieger ist
keine gute Einstiegsklasse.
Valkyrie
ist neu,
gab es in Eden Season 1 nicht,
ist ein
heiler Tank
oder nee, sagen wir mal eher ein
heiler
heiler Melee
DPS
Hybrid, ziemlich
cool, gerade
für größere Fights, du hast
Nahkampfangriffe, die aber Flächen
machen, also kannst du da super
beispielsweise in einem Turm Leute unterbrechen
beim Zaubern und sowas. Valk ist
aber auch so eine Klasse,
du hast ziemliche Mana-Probleme als
Valkyrie, ist eine super
Klasse, wenn man Duo spielen will,
beispielsweise Skald, Valkyrie und sowas, super
Duo, das macht aber niemand
Neues in dem Spiel. Also ich würde auch
sagen, Valkyrie keine
allzu geile Einstiegsklasse,
weil hauptsächlich Nahkampf
und auch
von den
Sachen drum herum, die man wissen muss,
auch nicht das aller einfachste, also würde ich sagen
ist nicht gut. Warlock gibt es nicht,
Warrior, Warrior ist die
stumpfste Nahkampfklasse im ganzen Spiel,
Warrior kann nichts
außer drauf kloppen. Warrior ist glaube ich
so ziemlich die einzige Klasse im ganzen
Spiel, die keine
irgendwie geartete Spezialität
hat. Ich
warte bis DF losgeht.
Jede andere Klasse hat
irgendwie irgendeine
Spezialität, ja. Der Armsman,
der hat eine Armbrust und
hat, okay die Scheiße, die verwendet keiner, die muss
ich nicht erwähnen. Der Armsman hat die
Möglichkeit, ähm,
äh, so helle Baden,
wie heißt, was heißt denn Polearm auf
Deutsch? Polearm.
Was?
Hä? Ostfriesisch?
Stangenwaffe, Stangenwaffe, genau.
Ja, Armsman kann als einziges
Stangenwaffe tragen und sowas,
aber der Krieger, der hat
nichts. Krieger ist die langweiligste
Nahkampfklasse im ganzen Spiel.
Der kann,
Moment, wo hab ich denn meinen Scharplaner hier?
Es ist eine
Nahkampfklasse, deswegen fällt die schon mal für mich als
Einsteigerklasse raus, aber
der Krieger,
der kann nichts. Ihr seht's, der hat, der hat,
ähm,
kann Exosbecken, Hammersbecken, Schwertersbecken,
Schildsbecken parieren und Throwing Weapons,
was niemand verwendet. Nichts.
Der hat nichts. Das ist die,
wenn du so willst, die langweiligste
Klasse, die es gibt, aber
gleichermaßen einer der besten
Tanks im Spiel.
Und dadurch, und das haben sich die,
das haben sich die Hersteller auch schon, das hat sich der Hersteller
auch schon gedacht, der Krieger hat,
das wissen auch nicht alle,
der Krieger hat den höchsten Damage-Modifikator
im ganzen Game.
Mit 2,3.
Der Hersteller hat sich
gedacht, die Klasse
hat ja gar nichts.
Der, der, der müssen wir
irgendwas Spezielles geben.
Also haben sie dem Krieger
den höchsten Damage-Modifikator gegeben.
Das rettet den Krieger meiner Meinung nach
aber auch nicht. Also wenn ihr
einen ganz stumpfen Full-Tank
spielen wollt, der aber mit 2
Hand auch gut draufhauen kann, der aber sonst
gar nichts kann und
super langweilig ist, meiner Meinung nach,
dann Krieger, aber
allein schon, weil es Nahkampf ist, keine gute
Einstiegsklasse. Akaya, Dankeschön, dass
du so viele Subs gegiftet
hast und dass du deinen Weg
gefunden hast. Weiß nicht, hast du Twitch Empfehlungen?
Oder über YouTube? Heute ein bisschen was anderes.
Heute spiele ich ein bisschen Oldschool MMO.
Weil ich das eh gemacht hätte.
Und...
Okay, ich glaube, die gehen echt nicht
DF. Ich, ich mach, ich gehe die Klassen hier
fertig durch und dann logge ich wieder um und dann machen wir was.
Machen wir was anderes.
Jo. Wobei, ha, ich
logge jetzt schon um. Die gehen nicht
DF. Ich logge auf den Runi um.
Weil ich muss, ich muss die Runi-Epic
weitermachen. FVR, FVR,
BGFVR, das
mache ich heute Abend.
Wenn die anderen Leute am Start sind.
Jetzt werde ich meinen
Runi equippen. Eigentlich wollte ich
noch ein Template,
noch ein Template
für meinen Runi
austüfteln heute oder irgendein fertiges
nehmen. Ich möchte
jetzt nochmal, bevor wir mit Midgard durch sind.
Und nochmal
Subscribed. Pok.
Sehr nice.
Dankeschön für die 11 Subs.
Bevor
wir jetzt mit den, mit den Midgard-Klassen
durch sind, möchte ich nochmal
kurz zurückgehen auf
Heiler.
Und euch das mal kurz im, im
Char-Planer zeigen.
Oder bei der Gelegenheit einfach auf meinen Heiler
switchen. Damit ich euch das mal kurz
zeigen kann, was ich meine.
Dass Heiler
eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist oder
die schlechteste, die es gibt. Je nachdem, was man speckt.
Ich hab's ganz am Anfang des Streams
schon mal, schon mal kurz erzählt.
Der Heiler, das ist noch nicht die finale Speck.
Das ist übrigens, der bleibt 49 für immer.
Der Heiler, das ist für mich
Money, Money Make Char und
Battleground, Battleground
Charakter.
Der ist noch ein bisschen falsch gespeckt.
Der wird, der wird noch umgespeckt. Das gibt noch
3 Punkte mehr, das gibt ein bisschen weniger und
dafür gibt's hier 18 dann. Egal, ich zeige
euch das gleich. Also das Ding ist,
als Heiler, wenn du ihn
so speckst wie ich. Nehme ich eben nicht als
rein Buff-Heal. Ich hab nichts in Buffen.
Ja, ich hab 9, 9
39 heilen, 36
pack. Auf Deutsch heißt diese
Skill-Linie Befriedung.
Wer auch immer sich das so ausgedacht hat.
Du bist nicht nur
Main Heiler, du bist
Main Damage Vermeider
als Heiler. Und wenn ihr auf diese,
wenn ihr auf diese Skill-Linie geht,
dann ist das der
meiner Meinung nach schwierigste Char im Spiel
und definitiv kein Einstiegs-Char.
Ihr habt dafür alles, was es an CC
gibt. Ihr habt Single Target Sleep,
Single Target Stun,
ähm, Area Stun,
Single Target Root,
äh, sorry, ähm, Single Target
Sleep, Single Target Stun,
Area Stun,
Area Sleep, Single Target
Root und wenn das noch nicht
genug war, Instant Area
Sleep, Instant
Single Sleep, Instant
Stun, also ihr habt
alles, was es an CC gibt in diesem
Spiel als Heiler. Das sinnvoll
anzuwenden, sich sinnvoll
zu positionieren und
neben diesem ganzen Shit noch
zu heilen
ist mega anspruchsvoll
und wahrscheinlich der schwierigste
Char im ganzen Game.
Dazu kommt ja noch, ihr müsst ja auch noch
nebenbei könnt ihr noch Attack Speed debuffen,
ihr könnt noch Seuche heilen, Gift
heilen, äh, Leute
wiederbeleben, äh,
Sleep heilen, ihr könnt
Near-Sight heilen, ihr könnt Gegner
den Zauber vergessen lassen, den sie gerade
und nebenbei, und nebenbei könnt
ihr auch noch ganz gut heilen.
Ihr könnt quasi alles, außer Damage machen.
Aber das
zu...
auf die Reihe zu bekommen in nem Fight
braucht da auch Kenntnisse.
Das geht nicht als
Einsteiger, meiner Meinung nach.
Was geht, was ihr machen könnt
ist, diese Skill-Linie hier
komplett weglassen, so wie das auch viele machen,
weil denen ist das einfach zu stressig
und zu anstrengend,
die gehen bei Heiler nämlich nicht auf
äh, Pack, sondern
die gehen auf so ne Mischung aus
sagen wir mal mindestens
40 Heal und
wobei ich ja persönlich fast sogar schon
bisschen höher gehen würde, wenn man hauptsächlich
BG spielt, kann man, wenn man BG spielt
kann man theoretisch
ja, kann man
kann man theoretisch auf
46 Heal gehen, wenn man BG
spielt, dann hat man noch, äh, Groob
Seuche Heal und den Rest steckt man
steckt man in Aug
zum Eingeschmack reichen 40 Heilen
aber, ja, wenn man nur BG
wenn man nur BG spielt, könnte man sowas hier spielen
ähm
das ist durchaus, durchaus okay
oder ihr geht halt mit Heilen ein bisschen runter, dass ihr die
die höheren Resis
bekommt, was sehr sinnvoll ist, weil die niedrigen
Resis braucht kein Mensch, da sind CL Resis
besser, die gelben werden schon
ganz sinnig, ja, aber sowas
könnt ihr zum Beispiel machen
oder sagen wir mal, 40
wie hoch kriegen wir das hier, on, off
36, ja, das ist schon
ein bisschen besser, ja, aber
wie dem auch sei, was ich, was ich eigentlich sagen
will ist, also sowas, sowas für reines
reines BG RvR, könnte man sowas hier schon
spielen, dann ist der Heiler wiederum easy
zu spielen, weil dann seid ihr wirklich Heiler
ihr seid, ihr seid dann einfach primär Heiler
ihr habt im Prinzip eure ganzen Heal Spells, eure
die ihr übrigens
auch habt, hier
aber nicht die beste Version davon, das heißt hier
müsst ihr die gesamte Crowd Control Geschichte
machen, plus das Heilen
was ihr hier machen müsst
und dann bekommt ihr noch einen weiteren Spell
der auch sehr nice ist, ihr bekommt
Celerity
das kann ich nicht aussprechen, Celerity ist ein
Attack Speed Debuff für eure Tanks
immer sehr beliebt
aber im Prinzip ist das ziemlich simpel zu
spielen, ihr müsst gucken, dass
eure Gruppe am Leben bleibt
ihr müsst die heilen, ihr könnt
Seuche, Nierseiten und sowas heilen
und ihr werft ab und zu mal ein
Group Attack Speed Buff fertig
damit habt ihr so euren
Heal Orc Heiler
abgedeckt, also das ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse
Puck Heiler ist wahrscheinlich
die schlechteste Einstiegsklasse, die es gibt in dem Spiel
so
so viel zu den Midgard
Klassen, also um das nochmal
zusammenzufassen, wer Bock hat auf Midgard
Bonedancer, super Einstiegsklasse
Heiler, wenn es nur um
Heilen und Buffen geht, auch
gute Einstiegsklasse, Rune Master
wer auf Range DPS S-Fuck
steht, super Einstiegsklasse
Schamane, wie ich finde
eigentlich, ich
stelle es mir zumindest vor als Einsteiger
die etwas spannendere
Einstiegssupport, Einstiegsklasse
in Midgard als Heiler, also auch eine super
Einstiegsklasse, für meinen Geschmack sogar
noch ein bisschen besser als Heiler
und als letztes
was war es eigentlich, Spiritmaster mag ich nicht
ja und wenn ihr unbedingt einen Tank spielen wollt, oder unbedingt
keinen Tank Nahkampf spielen wollt, dann spielt Skalde
aber das war es
das würde ich in Midgard empfehlen
so, jetzt kommen wir zu Hip, Hip ist das Reich, was ich
am wenigsten gespielt habe insgesamt
und auch am wenigsten Ahnung davon habe, aber ich weiß trotzdem was die
Klassen machen, weil
man spielt ja, spielt ja dagegen
übrigens, was euch jetzt vielleicht schon aufgefallen
ist, wir haben uns jetzt zwei von
drei Reichen angeguckt, und euch
ist vielleicht aufgefallen, dass keine
der Klassen doppelt, ah doch Mauler
Mauler, aber gibt es auf Eden eh nicht
dass keine der Klassen doppelt vorkommt
und das ist auch eines der großen
nicen Sachen von Daok
Daok hat drei Reiche und
komplett unterschiedliche Klassen
du hast ganz vereinzelt
ein paar Klassen, die gewisse
Schneidungen haben, ja zum Beispiel
ein Feuer Wizard und ein Rune Master
die sind schon relativ ähnlich
aber sind trotzdem auch
ansonsten komplett unterschiedliche
Klassen
und dementsprechend spielen sich auch alle drei
Reiche schon auf ihre
eigene Art
Hip fühlt sich anders an im
Gameplay als Alp, und Alp fühlt sich anders
an im Gameplay als Mid, das ist einfach
so, und das ist halt was
das kenne ich aus keinem anderen Game
aber kommen wir mal zu den Hip Klassen
wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt Hibernia spielen
weil ihr auf grüne Wiesen
und Bäume und sowas steht
oder euch vielleicht, was wahrscheinlich
die bessere Variante ist, eine
der Klassen aus Hibernia am besten
gefällt, dann werde ich erstmal
meinen Senf zugeben, was ich für gute Einstiegsklassen halte
also fangen wir gleich mal mit an, Animist
dürfte wahrscheinlich
Chat mal die Frage an euch
wer von euch Daok spielt
gibt es eine Klasse, die mehr gehasst ist als Anis
ich glaube Anis sind die meisten
meistgehasste Klasse im Spiel
niemand mag Anis
außer Anis Spieler selbst
ok, und andere Leute aus
Hip, aber sonst mag keiner Animisten
Anis mag niemand
und das liegt daran, weil das
ist eine, ich muss nur gucken, ob jetzt irgendwie wirklich
nicht noch irgendwie DF oder so anfängt
ne, ist nicht
und das liegt daran
weil Animisten
eine, ich zeig's euch mal
ich zeig's euch mal im Chatplaner
eine Sache können, die
niemand sonst in dem Spiel kann, und das ist
Pilzen
klingt jetzt erstmal dumm
aber es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
Pilzen können die
die haben eine Skill
das hier, die haben eine Skill-Linie
da kann man Pilze, ne Moment
ne, das
ach Quatsch, das ist immer wie wenig Ahnung
ich von Anis habe, ich hasse Anis
du bekommst Pilze
Animistpads, das sind Pilze
du kannst quasi
Dark Shrooms
guck hier
das ist ein Ani
du pilzt, du stehst rum
und fucking pilzt den ganzen Tag
das ist das Ani-Gameplay
du pilzt
und ab und zu machst du mal
ein bisschen Damage noch auf Gegner
so, und dann rennst du
zurück in deine Pilze
und deine Pilze killen alle Gegner
pass mal auf, das werden wir wahrscheinlich, hier, guckt's euch an
Ani-Gameplay, Alter
das ist so eine Cancer-Class, Alter
guck
sobald was auf ihn drauf geht
rennt er zurück zu seinen hässlichen Pilzen
und die Pilze killen das alles für ihn
also Ani, ich weiß nicht
Ani ist
jetzt mal, guckt's euch an
guckt's euch an
der muss nichts machen, der steht einfach nur da und die Pilze killen alles
guckt euch das an
das ist doch ein Witz, oder?
guckt's euch an, der steht einfach in seinen fucking Pilzen
und alles stirbt
Ani, Alter
okay, ähm
also, ich glaube
Animus ist die meistgehasste Klasse
in dem gesamten Game
aber es ist
wenn man auf diesen Spielstil steht
also sehr
so Summonermäßig
ohne dass man die Pets jetzt
großartig kontrolliert steuern könnte
wenn man so
Fire and Forget Summonermäßig spielen will
ist Ani eigentlich
eine coole Klasse
ich hasse Animisten, ich würde
den nicht spielen, aber
realistisch betrachtet, wenn man auf den Spielstil
steht, ist das glaube ich
eine echt gute Einstiegsklasse
aber nur, wenn man den Spielstil mag
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wer diesen Spielstil mag
aber
aber Ani, aber Ani ist
Ani, ey, wenn euch das
gefällt, spielt Animus, ist eine gute
Einstiegsklasse auf jeden Fall
Benji, finde ich, ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse
Benji ist ein
ist eine der vielen Casterklassen
in Hip, ich glaube Hip hat
die meisten Casterklassen
ist eine Casterklasse, die hauptsächlich
sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass
sie viele Area Damage
Spelleffekte
hat und Benji ist die
einzige Genderlocked Klasse
im Spiel
alle anderen Klassen können
sowohl männlich als auch weiblich sein, Benji ist
die einzige Klasse, die nur weiblich
sein darf, man verwandelt sich da auch
in irgend so was Gespenstermäßiges
wenn man Benji ist
wierde Klasse
eigentlich ganz cool von den Fähigkeiten her
aber ich finde, keine Einstiegsklasse
ja
steht ja auch hier, Ranged Area
Effekt, also hat hauptsächlich
Ranged Damage
ähm, Area Damage
Effekte, meiner Meinung
nach hauptsächlich eine Klasse für
Zerg, beziehungsweise
Battlegroup
PvP, FVR
da siehst du auch jede Menge Benjis
aber ich finde den nicht
gerade, ich finde die zum Einstieg
jetzt nicht so dolle
ehrlich gesagt, Bade
definitiv
keine Einstiegsklasse
Bade ist so ne Mischung
aus, nachdem ich euch
das andere jetzt ja erklärt hab, Bade ist
so ne Mischung aus Heiler
und Hexe
du bist quasi der Main Crowdcontroller
in Hipp, du musst
aber auch gefühlt alles machen
brauch sehr tiefgreifende
Kenntnisse der Dark Mechanics
und ist quasi
ein
Healer Crowdcontrol
Hybrid
so ein bisschen wie Heiler, aber nicht wirklich Heiler
also
eher so ne Mischung aus
Hexe und
aus Heiler und Minne oder sowas
vielleicht, also
kann man schwer klassifizieren, ihr seht die Klassen
sind alle unterschiedlich, ist
sehr schwierig gut zu spielen
und von den Mechanics her
und allem ist sicherlich nichts
für Einsteiger
den würde ich in die ähnliche Kategorie wie
Packheiler schieben, eines der Einsteiger
unfreundlichsten Klassen überhaupt
zumal es als Bade auch sehr oft nicht
ankommt in Gruppen
wenn du es verkackst, ist die Gruppe meistens im Arsch
dementsprechend würde ich sagen
Bade ist eindeutig was für fortgeschrittene Spieler
gar nichts für Einsteiger
Blademaster
sind wir wieder beim Thema
reine Nahkampf DPS Klasse
Dual Wield Nahkampf
DPS Klasse, also ihr merkt es vielleicht, jeder
jedes Reich hat
eine Main Tank Klasse
und eine Off Tank
Dual Wield DPS Klasse
falls euch das aufgefallen ist, also es gibt beispielsweise
außer Alp, außer Alp, die haben zwei
Alp hat Armsman und Pala
als Main Tank und
Mercenary als Dual Wield Off Tank Klasse
Midgard hat
Warrior als Main Tank
und Savage
und Bersie als
Dual Wield Off Tank Klasse
und Hip hat
Hero als Main Tank
und Blademaster als
Dual Wield Off Tank Klasse
nachdem ich ja schon
gesagt habe, ich finde Tanks generell
nicht gut für einen Einstieg, würde ich das
beim Blademaster nochmal unterstreichen
Blademaster ist reine Nahkampf Klasse
du hast nichts was irgendwie ranged ist
das heißt, wenn du Fights falsch einschätzt
und so und auf einmal zwischen
5 Castern stehst, weil du das nicht gecheckt hast
weil du den
Flow von Fights in Dark nicht kennst
bist du einfach tot und du bist als Nahkampf Klasse
prinzipiell, wenn du Loot bist in dem Game
immer tot
wenn du einfach nur Tunnelblick mäßig rein rennst
deswegen, du kannst viel ausrichten als
Nahkampf Klasse, aber du musst ein bisschen wissen
wann und wie und wo
also das ist auf jeden Fall nichts
für Einsteiger
Blademaster ist tatsächlich noch relativ ähnlich
zu einem Söldner und zu einem
Mercenary in Alp
man denkt jetzt, das muss ich vielleicht auch
noch dazu sagen, man denkt jetzt bei
Blademaster und bei
Mercenary vielleicht so eine klassische
klassische Dual Wield
Nahkampf DPS Klassen
das ist so, aber
die haben beide, deswegen reicht es
wenn ich hier jetzt mal Blademaster
zeige, die haben eine Spezialität
sowohl Söldner als auch Blademaster
die können nicht nur
Waffen specken und
Dual Wield specken, nein
die können auch Schild specken
und gute
Off-Tanks
haben immer Schild gespeckt
und die haben nicht etwa Schild, das ist wieder
so ein typisches Ding, wo man Dark kennen muss
weil das niemand checkt, der neu ist
es ist so, dass
alle Off-Tanks, die Schild specken können
Schild specken, aber die specken nicht
Schild, also die skillen nicht Schild
damit sie
blocken können oder mehr aushalten
oder sagen wir mal in den seltensten Fällen, damit sie blocken können und mehr aushalten
nein, die specken Schild dafür
du bekommst auf Level 42
für den Schild einen 9 Sekunden
Nahkampf Stun
dann haust du dem Gegner quasi dein Schild
von Latz und er ist 9 Sekunden betäubt
und da das ein
Nahkampf Stun ist, zählen dort auch
keine Resistenzen rein, auch so ein
Dark Ding, was keiner weiß, wenn es nicht
weiß, ja, Casted
Stunts zählen Resistenzen rein
Melee Stunts zählen keine Resistenzen
rein, das heißt, wenn ich einen Heiler Stunt
stehst du vielleicht 5 Sekunden
stunt ich einen mit dem Schild, stehst du
die vollen 9 Sekunden und in
9 Sekunden Stun, wenn der
Tengesho an dir dran ist, bist du
futsch
zumal das meistens noch nicht der einzige ist, der auf dich
draufhaut oder auf dich draufcastet
9 Sekunden Stun, du bist eigentlich in
99%, äh 7 Sekunden
Stun, ne 9 Sekunden, 9 Sekunden Stun
ähm, du bist
eigentlich immer tot
also was gute Off-Tanks machen
ist, die specken Schild
auf 42, slammen dich
switchen zurück
auf Dual Wield
und rasieren dich weg, wie Gillette Abdi
und deswegen
muss man da auch halt ein bisschen
die Einzelheiten kennen, dass man auf sowas kommt
und bei Blademaster trotzdem keine
keine gute Einstiegsklasse
das war doch mal vor 20 Jahren populär
ja, aber es sind immer noch viele Spieler auf dem
Freeshard
äh, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich wollte eigentlich meine
Epic mit dem
ja, ich habe euch jetzt die Heiler Sache gezeigt
äh, ich wollte eigentlich meine Epic machen
mit dem
Runi, dass ich das bis heute Abend noch irgendwie
durchkriege, ich bin ja schon 5 Stunden am
Start, alter Leute, lul
so viel am schwätzen gewesen
nehmen die noch Geld damit ein, keine Ahnung
ich spiele auf dem Freeshard, ich spiele, oh fuck
wenn ich jetzt rausgehe, dann ist es
bestes Game
ich spiele auf dem Freeshard, also wenn du auch spielen willst
kannst du kostenlos spielen
eben
musst du offiziell, ja, haben ja auch eine Anleitung
wie es geht, es ist easy, kriegt jeder hin
kannst du kostenlos spielen
ist äh, seasonal
das heißt, es wird so ungefähr alle 10 Monate
resetet, aber nicht alles, du behältst
manche Sachen, ich finde die haben das sehr gut gemacht
und wenn du mich fragst, ist Eden Season 2
der beste Dark Server, der es hier gegeben hat
so, gehen wir zurück auf den Runi
so,
Klassenübersicht, weiter, machen wir mal schnell fertig
also, keine gute Einstiegsklasse
Champion, ehrlich
gesagt
Schrott, aus meiner Sicht
egal, ob für
erfahrene oder neue Spieler, Schrott
neue Spieler neigen vielleicht noch dazu das zu spielen
weil sie denken, oh cooles Konzept
ich glaube, ich glaube Champion ist
eines der am wenigst gespielten Klassen
im Game, ich glaube die meisten
anderen, die werden noch so
du kannst ja auch fast alles irgendwie
gebrauchen, ja, aber
Champion ist eines der
tja
wenigst gespielten und auch
finde ich, unsinnigsten Klassen
im Spiel, Champion ist
gedacht vom Hersteller
als
Off-Tank
der nicht primär
nur DPS macht
sondern Gegner debuffen kann
aber nachdem Champion zwar richtig krasse
Debuffs hat, aber nur Single Target Debuffs
ist Champion
eigentlich ziemlich useless
ich mag Champion nicht
und ich bin nicht der einzige, weil Champion ist
eines der am wenigsten gespielten Klassen im ganzen Spiel
würde ich als Einsteiger definitiv
nicht empfehlen und würde ich auch als Fortgeschrittener
definitiv nicht empfehlen, ich glaube niemand spielt Champion
gute Klasse, aber bis jetzt
noch nicht balanced worden
so dass man sagt, ey, den will ich unbedingt
haben
Truide, sehr gute Einstiegsklasse
als noch am Cryon, ja
Truide ist der
Haupt
der Main Healer aus der
Primary Healer aus Hip
und der primär Buffer
aus Hip
Truide ist
ein bisschen mit Clary zu vergleichen
in der Rolle als Main Buffer
Main Healer
allerdings hast du noch ein Pet
Truide kannst du
Truide ist eine super Einstiegsklasse
ich habe auch eine Weile Truide gespielt
macht auch mega Bock
würde ich sagen, gilt das gleiche wie beim Clary
wenn man wirklich auf Supportklassen steht
also so dass man sagt, ey, ich komme damit klar
dass
ich selbst nichts kille
sondern ich meine Gruppe supporte
und die killt was für mich, dann ist
Truide super klasse und auch super rewarding
zu spielen
als Truide kannst du heilen
du kannst buffen
und du kannst ein Pet
beschwören, je nachdem wieviel du da
reinsetzt, ein mehr oder weniger gutes Pet
aber ganz ehrlich
die Truiden Pets sind alle nicht so geil
ich weiß, es gibt auf jeden
einen Truide, der spielt immer Solo
und der hat das höchste Pet
und der spielt auch recht erfolgreich
Solo
aber die wenigsten Leute werden Truide Solo spielen
und ein hoher
ein hoher Truide mit
45 Pet, der kann weder heilen
noch buffen, sondern nicht gut specken
den will in Gruppe keiner haben, also insofern
ich würde Abstand von der
Petlinie nehmen, als Einstieg
mit Truide, ich würde mich da drauf
fokussieren, dass ich ordentlich heilen kann
ordentlich buffen kann, also quasi
im Prinzip mindestens
schnellen
Near-Side-Heal und die
und
gelben Decks
gelben
also mindestens
ach das geht gar nicht
das ist ja kacke
wie das funktioniert?
siehst du mal, wie wenig Plan ich von Hip-Klassen habe
du brauchst 39
brauchst für den gelben
Tatsache
ok, dann kannst du gar nicht den hohen Near-Side specken
ok, was ist denn da eine sinnvolle
sinnvolle Truiden Speckung
ja, das braucht keiner
den
ja, hier kann man tatsächlich
dann ein bisschen variieren, ob man noch
ein bisschen mehr Pet haben will oder ein bisschen weniger Pet
aber, sag mal
das ist das, was den Truiden halt auszeichnet, dass du nicht nur
Main Buffer, Main Healer bist, du hast
zusätzlich noch ein Pet, du kannst also quasi
weil, ja, die Hips sind ja alle sehr
naturverbunden, du kannst quasi
einen Luchs beschwören, einen Löwe
beschwören, einen Wolf
beschwören und so komisches Zeug
einen Baum beschwören, warum auch immer man Bäume beschwören kann
in Dark
und du hast noch ein bisschen CC Root
und Instant Root
und das grenzt sich so ein bisschen
vom Clary aus Alp ab, ist aber
trotzdem eine super Einstiegsklasse
wenn man gerne Support spielt
und zwar Full Support, ohne da
irgendwelche komischen Damage-Ambitionen
ist Truide, und wenn ihr Hips spielen wollt
ist Truide euer Ding
Main Buffer, Main Healer, mit ein bisschen
Utility, was Root und Pet angeht
kann man
sehr viel Spaß dran haben, macht mir persönlich auch ultra Spaß
und ist eine super Einstiegsklasse
nächstes Eldritch
ja, jetzt kommen wir
in die Hip-Spezialitäten
ich muss immer mal gucken, dass die nicht
DF starten hier ohne mich
also, jetzt kommen wir in die Hip-Spezialitäten
was Caster angeht
also
ich finde Eldritch ist keine gute Einstiegsklasse
weil, dass quasi
der, nennen wir es mal
mit dem Menta zusammen, mehr der
der Damage-
Utility Caster in Hip ist
du hast Nearsight
du hast solche, du hast, ok
Singles, Targets, dann haben sie alle
du hast ganz guten Nuke
du kannst ganz gut Damage machen
aber, dadurch, dass du
nicht nur in reiner Damage, Damage, Damage
eine Taste, eine Taste, Damage, Damage, Damage
bist, musst du ein bisschen wissen
was du machst
und man sieht es ja auch hier an der
hier sieht man es ja auch
du kannst
ok, Void, du kannst Voids backen
ich glaube nicht, dass Void, sondern nicht beliebt ist
Void ist quasi die Fire Wizard
Variante in Hip
Damage und Nuke, Nuke, Nuke, Nuke, Nuke
aber
das ist sehr ähnlich zum
Runi auch, aber da spielen glaube ich kaum
welche, also
ich finde es ist keine so gute
Einstiegsklasse, weil du hast einige
Möglichkeiten, was du machen kannst, wo du gerade auch
hier mit solchen schon wissen musst
was du machst, außerdem bist du jetzt nicht
so, dass jede Gruppe unbedingt einen Eldritch
haben will, weil in BG ist das kein Ding
ja und auch viele Hip-Hybrid-
Gruppen haben einen, gerade wegen
der Seuche und sowas, aber
die Welt
schreit nicht unbedingt jetzt nach
komm in meine Gruppe, komm in die Gruppe
ja, ja, fliegen die Geldscheine
Ange
ähnlich gelagert, nur dass ich finde, dass
Ange noch eine ziemlich gute Einstiegsklasse ist, weil
Ange ist simpel, Ange macht
zwei Sachen, hat ein Pet und macht Damage
Ange ist eine gute Klasse
du kannst, also das hier
speckt niemand, das ist Buffs
fürs Pet, da machst du
äh, restliche, restliche Punkte rein
ansonsten speckt das keiner, die meisten
Leute specken
Mana beim Ange und dann
ist das super straight forward, du speckst
Mana, speckst den Rest in deinem
Lightning Nuke
und äh, was so noch, also so
ungefähr, ich bin mir jetzt mit Ange Specks aus dem
Kopf auch dazu ganz, Rest packst du noch in Pet
und dann ist fertig, so, Ange
Skill fertig, und das ist
eine super Klasse zum Einstieg, weil die ziemlich
straight forward als Pet
Damage Caster zu spielen
ist, es ist nicht ganz so simpel,
One Button, wie, es ist eigentlich eine ziemlich
coole Einstiegsklasse, ja
ähm, es ist, es ist, es ist ein Caster
der sich ein bisschen anders spielt als der Rest
den wir, den wir bisher als Einstiegskasten
äh, als Einstiegsklasse hatten, es ist nicht so wie beim
Fire, Fire Wizard oder beim
Huni, 1, 2, dann dddddddd
ne, also
Ange musst du ein bisschen anders spielen, du hast
ähm, zwei Varianten, deswegen finde ich
auch, es ist ne wirklich coole, coole ähm
Einstiegsklasse, erstens bist du
in Gruppen begehrt
für PvE und äh, in
GBG und sowas
gib ihm, obwohl du kein Range
AE Damage hast, das ist vielleicht so der einzige Nachteil
da dran, aber Ange ist beliebt
und das coole an Ange ist
du kannst, also Enchanter
jeder sagt nur Ange, äh
das coole daran ist, du hast ein Pet, du hast drei
verschiedene Pets, du hast irgendwie einen Nahkraftpet, einen Casterpet
mit, mit Snare und sowas
aber, du kannst mega
gut, ähm, ja
Close Range Damage machen
wo man normalerweise denkt, hä
Caster sind doch für Range DPS, ne
nicht so, Enchanter können Range
DPS, Single Target, mega krassen
Range Target DPS äh, machen
und Close Range Damage
weil du bekommst hier, ups, ich hab übrigens
Mist geskillt hier bei meinem Ange, seh ich gerade
muss natürlich mal mindestens
auf 48
das brauchste net
du bekommst hier, äh, Direct Damage
PvE, du machst
ah, das ist, das ist, das ist heftig, guck mal
du, das ist ein
Spell
mit nem Radius von 300
der allerdings
um dich drum herum
ist, also du musst dort
stehen, wo du willst, dass Damage
reinkommt, das heißt, du musst in die
Gegner rennen, um
Damage zu machen, wenn du aber in den Gegnern stehst
und zwei Casts, zwei, drei Casts rausbekommst
ist alles tot
und das ist gerade gegen Monster gut, Spieler
die aufpassen, geht das so
geht das so semi gut, wobei es, äh
viele Gruppen gibt, die versuchen das immer noch
ja, also es gibt, äh, im, im großen
PvP gibt es viele Gruppen, die laufen
mit, äh, äh, Bomben
nennt sich das in Dark rum und versuchen
äh, 50, 60 Mann
Battle, mit 8 Leuten versuchen die 50
Mann wegzubomben, ja, da wird reingerannt
versucht 2, 3 Mal
zu Bomben mit 2, 3 Leuten und dann
fällt alles um, also kannst mit
Eng sowohl super krassen
Close Range Damage machen, als
auch, und das ist gerade das, was ich in
Verbindung mit dem Pet cool finde, als
auch ziemlich guten Range
Damage, weil als Eng bekommst
du nämlich ein 50
% Debuff
und Eng ist eines der
wenigen Klassen in ganz Dark, die
ihren eigenen Damage debuffen
können, du bekommst hier, wie ihr seht, ihr
bekommst ein Damage, du bekommst ein
Resistenz Debuff für Energie
weil, ist das wirklich nur
Energie, ich dachte es mir, hä
ist doch, ist das nicht Hitze
äh, das stimmt nicht, oder
ich glaube die Anzeige
stimmt nicht in dem, in dem
in dem Charplaner
weil Eng Debuff ist
Hit, genauso wie sein Single Target Nuke
und deswegen ist es ein guter Einstiegs
deswegen ist es eine gute Einstiegsklasse, ah ja
Kavu, muss sein, deswegen
ist es eine gute Einstiegsklasse, du kannst deinen eigenen Damage
debuffen und übelst damit, du kannst super krassen
Nahkampfdamage machen und du kannst Range Damage
machen, indem du den Gegner
Resistenzen debuffst und dann
hier oben mit dem Nuke drauf hältst
also deswegen, ich finde Eng ist eine tolle
Einstiegsklasse, äh, ja
Main Tank aus Hip
langweilig, wie ich finde, hat einen kleinen
Twist, kann, ähm
Speere und Zweihandwaffen
verwenden, inklusive Schilder und Einhandwaffen
kann sich in, kann sich in den Elch verwandeln
wo du ein bisschen mehr Leben hast, aber
wo wir beim Thema sind, kann ich, kann ich
eigentlich skippen, kann ich mir sparen, starten wir
irgendwann nochmal mit DF heute
wenn nicht, mach ich jetzt, wo mach ich, muss ich meinen Epic
weitermachen, ok, muss er Hagal
porten, alles klar, so
äh, wo wir dabei waren, also
wie gesagt, Nahkampf, Nahkampf
ähm, Klassen finde ich
allgemein nicht gut geeignet, als Einsteiger
deswegen würde ich den auch nicht empfehlen
genauso wenig wie Armsman oder Krieger
oder Palla
Morla gibt's nicht, Menta ist
eine super Klasse, finde ich
aber auch zu kompliziert für den Einstieg
äh, du kannst hier einen Patch haben
du kannst, äh, ein bisschen heilen
und richtig gut DPS
casten, plus ein paar Utility Spells casten
Menta ist, glaube
ich, bei den Castern
und du hast auch einen ziemlich guten AE dort, um
äh, im PvP Punkte zu
farmen
ist eine mega Klasse
spielen auch viele, ich glaube aber
zum Einstieg vielleicht ein bisschen
zu
zu viel auf einmal
was du machen kannst als Menta
du musst dich um dein Pet kümmern, du musst, ich meine
du kannst Menta auch einfach AE dort spammen und die
und halt die, halt die Klappe, ja
ich glaube aber Ange ist der bessere Einstiegscharakter
kann man sich hier nicht drüber schreien, Menta ist
super stark, eines der besten Caster
die es gibt vielleicht in dem Spiel, aber zum Einstieg
eher nicht so das
darf man fragen auf welchem Server du spielst, Eden
ja auf dem hier, nicht auf live
ne, ach auf, ach Moment
ich habs nicht gelesen, sorry
äh, du hast gefragt auf welchem Server ich auf live
gespielt habe, kannst du fragen, ich habe auf mehreren Servern gespielt
ähm, also hauptsächlich
habe ich gespielt auf Stonehenge Albion
bisschen Lioness Hip
äh, Classic Server mit und
EU Classic Server mit und
US Classic Server mit
ein ganz kleines bisschen noch
Dartmoor mit und Logres Albion
aber das
hauptsächlich meine Zeit habe ich tatsächlich
in Stonehenge Albion verbracht
um das abzuschließen
Menta super Klasse
gerade auch auf Eden eines der beliebtesten
Caster in Hip
und eines der besten Caster im Game
aber als Einstieg finde ich nicht so gut
Nightshade Schleicher Klasse nix zum Einstieg
Ranger Schleicher Bogen Klasse nix zum Einstieg
Veil Walker
vielleicht eines der
uniksten Nahkampfklassen die es gibt in dem Spiel
ist eine
ist eine Nahkampfklasse mit
Sense aber nur Stoffrüstung
Hustle Mauler Pufftisch Affa
Beste
Mann
Hahaha
Dass ich das nochmal lieben kann
Dass ich das nochmal lesen darf
Hustle Mauler Pufftisch Affa
Das sind so die Dark Memes
was, da gab es das Wort
Meme damals noch nicht
Also Veil Walker
auf Deutsch hieß diese Klasse glaube ich
Schnitter
Du hast eine Sense
Du hast aber selbst nur Stoff an
Das heißt du bist nicht die allertankigste
Nahkampfklasse
Du kriegst noch ein bisschen Absorb Buffs
und so das du mehr aushältst
Aber man muss generell sagen Schnitter ist eine Nahkampfklasse
die wohl mit am fragilsten ist
von allen Nahkampfklassen
Aber Veil Walker macht
Ultra Damage
Positional Styles
Das ist eine ziemlich Unique Klasse
in dem gesamten Game
Du bist nicht sonderlich tanky
aber Nahkampf
Du bist super krass Nahkampf
DPS
Aber nicht in jeder Lage
Also du musst als Schnitter wirklich spielen können
Und nachdem ich sage
dass Nahkampfklassen
Du kannst ein bisschen casten noch als Schnitter
als Veil Walker aber das ist nicht der Rede wert
Ähm
Ja aber nachdem ich schon bei allen
anderen Nahkampfklassen gesagt habe
nehmt als Einsteiger lieber Abstand davon
sage ich das als Schnitter doppelt
Also Veil Walker
als Einstiegsklasse ist glaube ich
echt mega frustrierend
Du bist wahrscheinlich
immer tot
Das würde ich nicht anfangen
Ansonsten ist das eine coole Klasse
Vampir gibt es nicht
Warden
So letzte Klasse hierbei
Kann ich ja schon mal ein bisschen weitererzählen
Und gucken wo muss ich jetzt hin für meine Epic
Lass mal kurz die Eier einreichen
Was machen eigentlich die Mids
Ist immer noch kein DF Raid
Ich glaube DF ist nicht ab
Kann das sein
Oh hier
Hier Kollege
Kriegst du meine Eier
Nice
Go
Und jetzt
Oh jetzt muss ich den Frontier Step machen
Da muss ich mal aufs Klo vorher
Bevor ich den mache
Dass die ganzen Leute abends schon online sind
Und jetzt wäre ich wahrscheinlich bei dem Frontier
Bei dem RVR PvP Gebiet
Step meiner Epic abgefarmt
So
Wahrscheinlich wäre ich gestream sniped
Jetzt gleich
Ja um
Die letzte Klasse ist
Secret
OPS
Fuck
Wenn ihr mich fragt
Wird kaum drüber diskutiert
Aber ich finde
Dankeschön für den Sub
Frd
Raider
Weiß nicht wie man es richtig ausspricht
Aber trotzdem Dankeschön für den Prime Sub
Excellent
Ich finde eines der OPsten
Klassen im Spiel
Nicht universell
Ja
Aber wenn man
Richtung Smallman und Gruppen
Fights guckt
One ist mega auf
Auf ihn
Weil
Ich zeige euch jetzt den großen Unterschied
Zu Warden auf Eden
Zu Warden woanders
Wo ist er denn?
Hier
Das ist alles normal
Hüter hieß das Ding übrigens auf Deutsch
Aber
Warden hat Shields Back
Das hat er auf Live nicht gehabt
Und dadurch das er Shields Back hat
Hat er auch wie alle mit Shields Back
Stun
Und das gepaart mit dem Rest
Macht in
Gruppen Fights oder Smallman Fights
Hüter finde ich zu einem der besten
Klassen im ganzen Spiel
Du hast Shields
Das heißt du kannst für andere Leute blocken
Hüter kann in Live nicht Shields Back
Never
Okay vielleicht mittlerweile
Lelo
Miltopass Raiding
Dankeschön
Sag mal Lelo du hast doch
Du hast so einen Charakter auf mit
Der fast genau so heißt oder?
Ich weiß nicht ob du Deutsch verstehst
Lelo du hast einen Charakter auf Eden mit
Der hat fast den gleichen Namen
Ich denke ich habe dich ein paar mal gesehen
Und ich denke wir
Du spielst
Okay
Ich glaube wir waren
Zusammen mal in Sobe
Mit so einem komischen Typ der dann keinen Bock hatte
Nach dem zweiten Wildmeer
Wo sie sich drüber beschwert haben dass du die Gegner
Das warst bist du nicht gewesen
Okay
Dann wundert es mich weil es gibt immer
Fast mit genau dem gleichen Namen rum
Ja
Dann habe ich
Das jetzt durcheinander gebracht
Nun gut
So ich muss jetzt mein Frontier Epic
Step machen das wird was ey ich sag es euch
Ich werde jetzt so krass gefarmt gleich
Weil das
So
Ich versuch Boot zu fahren
Oder
Ich dachte da steht ein Lurie man
Keck wait
Ich werde jetzt so hart abgefarmt
Weil jetzt sind schon relativ viele Leute am Start
Und hier wird immer so heftig gecampt
Und
Und als Runi mit Level Ausrüstung und allem
Dann gibts richtig gerade
Das ist übrigens der besagte Solo Porter hier
Ähh Albion Coast
Okay wir haben es ins Boot geschafft
Immerhin
Mich würde es nicht wundern wenn mich jetzt irgendeiner
Stream Snipe gibt der Leute die brauchen das
Ich mein das ist nicht schlimm
Ich kann die Epic auch neu machen
Zumindest
Um diese Sache mit Hütern mal abzuschließen
Wir gucken mal kurz
A Dark Warden
Was der für Skilllinien hat Off-Life
Bin mir ziemlich sicher der hat kein Schild
Sieht man das irgendwo
Ähh sieht man nicht wirklich nicht so richtig aus
Irgendwie was der für Skilllinien hat
Das ist ja die Wiki Seite ist ja absolut Pepega
Mann Dark
Charm Planer
Gucken wir mal
Irgendwie einen
Live Server
Ist das Live Server
Okay gucken wir mal hier
Ähh Warden
Guck Warden hat
Oh oh what
Seit wann hat Warden auf Live denn Schilde
Nun gut
War zumindest zur damaligen Zeit in Dauern nicht so
Und das haben die
Für den Patch dann auf jeden Fall
Customized
Sekunde
Das haben die auf jeden Fall Customized
Und das ist mega nice
Du bist nämlich als Hüter
Hast du
Nicht nur richtig gute Resis
Die wichtig sind sondern du hast alles
Was du sonst als Hüter hast plus Shields dann
Was dich im Endeffekt zu einem
Nah zu vollwertigen
Heiler und
Tank macht
Und das ist super krass
Also ich find Hüter ist mega mega nice
Ich weiß nicht
Ob es eine gute Einstiegsklasse ist das kann ich persönlich
Ehrlich gesagt fast mit am schlechtesten
Ja genau das meinte ich ja
Mit allem was du sonst noch mit Hüter hast
Ich kann es ehrlich gesagt relativ schlecht beurteilen
Ich hab Hüter nie großartig gespielt
Ich würde sagen prinzipiell ist
Hüter eine gute Einstiegsklasse weil du musst
Nicht viel machen du musst auch nicht viel aktiv
Machen Hüter ist da eigentlich
Relativ simpel
Du slamst ein paar Targets mit deinem
Shield du machst dein
Bubblechant an buffst
Ab und zu mal Resis und heilst die Leute
Wenn es sein muss also Hüter
Ich würde tatsächlich sagen Hüter ist eine gute
Einstiegsklasse ja Hüter ist eine gute Einstiegsklasse
Ich könne mir aber vorstellen
Wenn ihr hauptsächlich und das werden die meisten
Neulinge machen hauptsächlich in
Random Gruppen spielt hauptsächlich
BG RVR spielt
Bin ich mir nicht sicher wie rewarding
Hüter ist weil Hüter macht weder
AE Damage noch kannst du sonderlich
Gut deine komplette Gruppe heilen
Ich weiß hat ein Hüter überhaupt eine
Groove Heal hat einen ziemlich guten Single Heal
Aber ob der einen Groove Heal hat
Bin ich mir da gar nicht mal so sicher
Doch du kriegst sogar
Du kriegst sogar den guten
Groove Heal das ist ja da ist der Hüter
Ist ja noch besser als ich dachte
Du kriegst zwar keinen Spread Heal aber
Die meisten heilen eh nicht dauerhaft
Mit Spread du kriegst sogar den
Schnellen großen guten
Groove Heal
Also Hüter ist echt krass
Du bist
Okay dann sagen wir mal so
Du kriegst noch den Hot und alles ja
Wobei weiß ich nicht wie gut der in den Fall ist
Also sagen wir es mal so
Du bist 95% Healer
Main Healer
Dir fehlt ja eigentlich nur das Spread Heal
Dir fehlt ja wirklich nur das Spread Heal im Endeffekt
Also Near Side Heal
Du hast fucking Near Side und Groove Deceased Cure auch noch
Alter Hüter ist ja noch mehr OP
Als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
The fuck
Okay
Ich nehme das nicht zurück
Was ich gesagt habe
Dass ich denke das Hüter eines der OPsten Klassen ist
In dem Spiel zur Zeit gerade auf Eden
Das ist noch mehr OP als ich mir das
Im Vorfeld schon gedacht habe
Da oben stellsten
Irgendwelche Leute rum ich verpiss mich mal ganz schnell
Ab nach Hip
Ich hab noch ein Bade gelevelt aber ich hab keinen Bock
Hip zu spielen
Ich stells mich jetzt hier unten lang
Also wenn mich hier einer findet
Dann call ich Stream Snipe
Anzeige ist raus
Denn niemand guckt hier unten normalerweise
Also okay
Das heißt du bist
95% Main Healer
Gleichwertig als One
Du hast super nice Resis
Instant Red
Ey
Okay ich nehme das zurück
Das ist nicht wahrscheinlich die OPste Klasse
Die es zumindest für Smallman und Groove RvR gibt
Das ist die OPste Klasse
Die es für Smallman und Groove RvR gibt
Du meinst du kannst hier als Hüter alles
Außer
Leute killen
Okay da komme ich
Ich komme gleich noch darauf zurück
In der Hoffnung ich werde jetzt nicht abgefarmt
Und kann meine
Kann meine Quest machen
Quest
Krass alter
Jetzt ergibt das für mich auch Sinn
Ich mein mir war
Die Hip Group Setups schon eine Zeit lang klar gewesen
Warum wie was gespielt wird
Jetzt verstehe ich aber
Noch eine Stufe mehr
Warum
Fünfer Support Gruppen
Tank Gruppen in Hip so beliebt sind
Du hast
Fünf Heiler inklusive
Alter das ist ja mega krass
Du kannst ja in Hip kannst du ja theoretisch spielen
Doppel Bade
Doppel Druid
Hüter
Blade Master
Und du hast noch einen Platz frei für X
Alter
Das ist ja so krass
Du kriegst es nicht tot und du hast super Damage
Geil Alter
Ach guck mal da ist das Viech
Ich wurde nicht abgefarmt
Ich call es mal nicht zu früh
Okay
Geh down please einfach sterben
Okay wir haben die Quest geschafft
Ich wurde nicht gestream sniped
Also das ist wirklich schon heftig
Also
Du bist 95
Und wenn ich mal ehrlich ist
Du bist besser im heilen
Als der Main Healer
Das einzige was du nicht hast ist der Spread Heal
Aber du hast einen Krupp Desease Cure
Den sich die meisten
Truinen nicht erlauben können
Zu holen
Wenn sie buffen müssen
Heißt im Endeffekt
Ja auf kill mich
Du bist eigentlich der bessere Heiler
Als Warne
Dann hast du noch deine ganzen
Anderen
Utility Sachen
Plus Shield Speck
Okay was speckt man denn als Warne
Das muss ich mir jetzt tatsächlich machen
Das ist ja noch krasser als ich mir das gedacht habe
Also brauchst du auf jeden Fall Cure
Krupp Desease
Und du willst 42 Shield
Und du willst
Tja
So viel wie geht hier rein
Da geht jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viel oder
Kann ja mal so übel
Ne
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie ein wirklich
Gute Warne Speck aussieht aber irgendwas
In der Richtung wahrscheinlich nicht exakt
Ja du machst alles
Du machst alles außer Damage
Und es reicht sogar noch für den Schwerttaut
Ne Leute töten kann er nicht gut
Also der Hüter
Okay wenn ich mir das so angucke
Ich bin ja auch 59
Also
Mega Alter die Klasse ist so heftig
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
Das ist wirklich mega
Ich muss noch ein bisschen Parry rein hauen
Das geht sogar von Null auf
Wahnsinn
Also ganz ehrlich ich hab keine Ahnung ob das eine gute Hüter Speck ist
Aber sowas in der Richtung wird man wahrscheinlich specken
Du bist
Du bist ein besserer Heiler als der Main Heiler
Du hast dein ganzes Bubble Utility Zeug
Du hast ein Nahkampf
9 Sekunden Anytime Stun
Gibt es irgendwas
Was sie nicht können
I don't want to play a Warne
I'm just surprised
How
How great the Warne is on Eden
Because they can do everything
Except Damage
I have no clue about Warne
I just looked up
What you might
Could have specked
It looks really OP
I knew it is
It was OP
But after I looked it up
In the character planner
I realized it is fucking OP
You are a better Healer
Than the Druid
You are only missing Spread Heal
But you have
Group Disease Cure
And you can
Speck higher than Druid
In healing
You are a better Healer than the Druid
You have all the Utilities from Plate Turn
And what not
You got the Anytime 9 seconds
Oh you are missing Instant Heal
You got the
9 seconds Anytime Melee Stun
You are basically
You are 95%
Main Healer
Really good
Tank
For
Stunning and
Removing enemy Melees
From the fight
You can do everything
You can even Instant Res
Only Damage
You are not great in doing Damage
I wasn't prepared
To see it that OP
And
Now that I have seen this
I realize why
So many Hipps
Playing Tank Group
So you can go
5 Supports
2 Blademasters
And plus X
It's
Really nice
But I don't play on Hipps
I have leveled
Bard
Not even to 50
I am playing
Mainly Mid and a bit of Alp
So my epic
Is finished
I have to go to Hagal
35 Shield Max
Why not
Anytime Slam
You get 35 Backstun
Is it
Enough
I can imagine Solo now
It's Side
It's Side Stun
But I mean
Who should beat
What you should play to beat 5 Support Hipp Group
Maybe
Maybe you can
Maybe you should go
2 Scales in Mid
I don't know
It looks really
Solid and
Quite hard to beat
On Paper
Okay
Oh no
Now comes the Skull Step
I don't feel like it
I ask in the guild chat
Three Wizard's Sorg
So with 3 Wizard's Sorg
It's just kill the first target
Before the fight starts
On live
I played
The most fights I did
The most 8 man fights
I did on live
Was Stonehenge Alp
And classic server mid
And on mid
We played
Maybe it's outdated now
And even
Can't be played on Eden
Because there is no Warlock
We played with
Two healers
Shaman Warlock
Bone Dancer Warrior
And I think
Savage or Berserker
As the last slot
And we killed everything
But I don't know
If this is
Will be possible in the future
Because no Warlocks
And now people have gotten better in the game
So maybe
It is more kiting
And wouldn't work this well
By the way
Warum fliege ich eigentlich nicht
Hm
Hi it's joey
Dankeschön für den Sub
Berserker isn't really that popular anymore
Notice this
I never liked to play
Pure DPS
Melee Characters
Paper Dark is nice
It was E-Sport
Before the term
E-Sport existed
Okay Leute
Wir machen jetzt den gleichen Step
Den wir eben schon gemacht haben
In Moderna mit dem
Ding auf dem Berg
Wo wir die ganze Zeit diseased und
Vergiftet und geseucht und alles wurden
Okay
Und jetzt haben wir
Ein bisschen mehr
Verstärkung für Skull Step
Ich muss mal kurz gucken ob irgendjemand
Ah ah
Kannst du mir kurz bei Skull helfen
Ich frag mal kurz im Discord
Ob irgendjemand kann
Anyone could help my AM
With Skull and was Rem
Kurz im Discord fragen
Wo renne ich denn hier eigentlich lang
Mann
Okay Leute
Ich weiß nicht was ich empfehlen würde
Zum starten
Hat das irgendjemand was gebracht
Oder habe ich einfach nur
Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg gemacht
Ein paar Leute haben ja geschrieben
Sie wollen sich runterladen und mal ausprobieren
Wie gesagt
Ich kann es euch nur empfehlen mal runterzuladen
Und auszuprobieren
Auf der Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg
Ja gut ist halt so
Aber ihr müsst ein bisschen gerade am Anfang
Echt dem Spiel ein bisschen Zeit geben
Und dann habt ihr dann sichtlich
Und tutorial gespickt
Wie man das von neueren Games erwartet ist
Soll ich mal probieren ob ich das alleine hinkriege
Den Step
Ich glaube das funzt nicht
Ich frag mal im Discord
Also ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Leute angeschrieben
Ob die mir helfen können mit dem Step
Aber ich frag mal
Im LFG
Anyone Skull Step
FTP up
Ich ess mal kurz was
Während ich warte dass ich vielleicht noch 1-2 Leute finde
Also ein Heiler wäre halt optimal
Im Heiler Duo kannst du das machen
It's really hard for new players
Because there is so many magic going on
For example
If you are a noob
You don't realize
That you need dexterity
For cast speed and not quickness
I mean
Why it's called quickness
Because it's only for melee quickness
I don't know
The European
Dark didn't know this
In 2001
A friend of mine has played Friar
And the
The hoster of the European
Dark said
You should spec
I think piety
And
Const strength
Or something like that
No quickness and no dexterity
Dark hat jede Menge Magic im Hintergrund
Hab ich euch ja heute auch schon erzählt
Ah okay
Der eine kocht gerade
Ey ich kann den Step nicht alleine machen als Huni
Das sagt man
Ich mein ich hab nen TP auf
Ich kanns ja mal probieren
Mal gucken wie weit ich komme
Ich glaube aber nicht das es funktioniert
Wir gucken mal wie weit wir kommen
Aber ich glaube ich bin dead
Even the tutorial isn't really a tutorial
It's just a
Boost your character to level 10
What do you learn in the tutorial
It's the rest of the game
And you
You learn how to
Buy a boat ticket
So you learn nothing about the game
I think a lot of new players
Could really enjoy
The game
But it's
Oh shit it's just so different
From
More modern games
Okay I'm dead
I love fucking shit
Hehehe
Er ist
Wo hab ich denn mein
Mein TP
Moment ich hab quickcast noch da
Hab ich nicht
Hab ich nicht quickcastet
Bin ich total dumm
Okay das wird alleine nix
Als Huni dieser Step
Gucken wir mal
Wir machen kleine
Kleine Schritte
Ich muss auch unbedingt
Nebenbei was futtern
So hier das Portal ist gut
Machen wir jetzt noch eins hin
Also ich bekomme gleich Hilfe
Der ist grad noch
Am Essen kochen
Der kann mir danach helfen
Ansonsten
Guck mal im
Im Discord ist auch keiner da
Ich glaub die sind alle noch auf der Arbeit
Okay okay das sieht doch schon besser aus hier
Das Problem ist die Viecher haben halt
Einen super krassen Dot
Was mich killt
Oh oh oh da machen welche Skull
Da machen welche Skull
Leute Leute Leute
Okay okay
Pass auf ich mach jetzt Asi Asi
Richtig Asi mach ich jetzt
Ja please please please
Ja
Hahaha
Jetzt kann ich sterben es ist egal
Leached
Jawoll
Hahaha
Nice
Einfach die Quest mal abgeleacht
Von dem Typ
Wobei ich glaub der hat es auch gekriegt
Ich glaub der hat es auch gekriegt
Oder ich hatte einfach nur mega Glück
Das er reingerannt ist und alle Mobs auf sich gezogen hat
Und ich konnte rein rennen
Und grabben
Sehr nice
Der ist eh gestorben
Also dass der gestorben ist kann ich nichts für
Der ist reingerannt und wurde halt gekillt von den Mobs
Du bist reiner PvPler
Nö nicht wirklich
Mir macht alles Bock an der Ork
Ich hab sogar man glaubt es kaum
Ich hab sogar Bock dran
Mich ab und zu mal auf so einen TG Raid
Zu sticken
Und da durch zu rennen
Wo ich auch mal richtig Bock drauf hätte
Ist ähm hier
Mit ner ordentlichen Group
Zu machen
Ihr weiß was ihr macht
Ich mein Chars dafür hab ich
Können den
BD nehmen wir können den Runemaster nehmen
Wir können den Skalde nehmen wobei Skalde braucht in Sobek keiner
Oder den Shammy nehmen Shammy ist wahrscheinlich
Der beste dafür oder den Heiler nehmen
Wobei der ist 49 das wird nix
Ja
Das würde ich gerne mal mit ein paar gescheiten Leuten machen
Weil mit allen denen ich das bisher gemacht hab
War echt übelst nervig
Okay
Was Remkillen
Also ich spiel meistens mit ein paar Leuten zusammen
Wir sind auch wild
Gemischt ähm Franzosen bei
Italiener dabei Polen dabei
Zum Glück alle EU
Also das heißt Zeitzonen mäßig passt das
Wobei wir eigentlich
So gut wie nie 8 Mann spielen
Da bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt zu noob für
Mittlerweile
Ist mir auch zu stressig geworden
Ähm wir rennen meistens Smallman rum
Oder eben
Maximumes Leeching in der BG
Das ist auch
Der Grund warum ich mir noch einen Runemaster gemacht hab
Kann ich nämlich einfach füllen
Entweder Shammy Skalde oder Runemaster
Da hast du immer was dabei was für die BG gebraucht wird
Da wird einfach
Reine Range DPS
Für BG gespielt
Und 18k die Stunde
Da wurde einfach nur Aegisweb
Den ganzen Tag
So
Der Grund warum ich
Ungern 8 Mann
Spiele ist
Du kannst das vielleicht vormittags spielen
Wenn es hauptsächlich sagen wir mal
Random Gruppen mit
Kerlen
Die sich kennen sind
Aber es ist ein riesen Unterschied
Das hab ich früher auch gemerkt
Es ist ein riesen Unterschied ob du mit ner
Guten Random Gruppe
8 vs 8 spielst
Oder 8 Mann wie man das heutzutage nennt
Spielst selbst wenn das gute Spieler sind
Versus
Du spielst
Mit den 8 gleichen Leuten
Jeden Tag oder vielleicht mal
Phil irgendwie
Mit ähm
Ja damals Teamspeak heute Discord
Du kommst einfach nicht
Du kommst einfach nicht mit
Selbst wenn du mit guten Leuten ne Gruppe baust
Selbst mit Discord und allem
Da auch
Man unterschätzt das schnell
Wie unglaublich
Eingespielt man sein kann
In ner 8er Gruppe
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
Gerade auf dem
Classic Server in mid
Ich konnte im Endeffekt schon
Die Waffe wegstecken
Weil ich wusste
Dass mein Heiler hinter mir
Gerade äh keine Ahnung war
Irgendein Sleep castet
Ohne das ich den gesehen hab
Also ich hab kein Game bisher so
Eine Synergie zwischen Spielern
Erlebt wie dort
So
Was ist jetzt Wasram Enjoyers
Frag mal den Typ ob der
Bock hat Wasram zu machen
Machen wir uns mal
Speed
Ah guck mal der Invited mich sogar
Sehr sehr nice
Warte mal dahin
Ähm man muss aber dazu sagen
So cool
So cool das RVR war
In ner 8er Gruppe
Die hatten echt nervige Leute dabei
Und
Da hatte ich irgendwann auch keinen Bock mehr drauf
Also die hatten dann Leute dabei
Die sich wirklich über jeden Scheiß aufgeregt haben
Ich meine als Galde
Konnte mir das egal sein
Da warst ja nix Schuld
Gewinnst 99,9% der Fights
Verlierst mal gegen irgendwie 2 Gruppen
Oder so
Und dann sind die Leute gleich schlecht drauf gewesen
Das war sehr weird irgendwie keine Ahnung
Aber das war halt auch der Zeit wo alle 24 7
Gespielt haben
You already there
Wo ist der Typ denn
Oh ok
Alter es ist keiner von den Leuten die
Helfen könnten mit dem Step
Ok ich hab nen Krieger der kommt
Ah die haben alle
Keinen Bock
Äh ist unser
Krieger eigentlich schon da
Äh der läuft da gerade hin
Ja
Ich war jetzt bisschen abgelenkt
Ich warte jetzt nur drauf bis Krieger einloggt
Ich nen Heiler am Start hab und der
Der Hunter
Am Spot ist
Ich hoffe
Ich hoffe das der Bossmob überhaupt ab ist
Nicht das ich jetzt hier die Leute kehre
Und am Ende ist der Boss gar nicht da Alter
Das wär natürlich
Doof
Ich bilde mir ein
Die haben den Respawn bisschen runter gedreht in Season 2
Ich hab irgendwas im Hinterkopf
Ich hab nen Heiler
Ok
Ja man
Äh wo ist das TP hier
Ok
Ich mein ein bisschen
Ein bisschen
Bisschen heilen kann ich ja auch mit dem Runi
Ich mein ich kann nicht wirklich heilen
Aber
Ich kann dem
Der ist doch komplett falsch hier
Wo rennt denn der rum
Wo ist denn der komische Dinosaurier jetzt
Ich mach mal kurz nen TP
So und Leute sind organisiert
Ich fürchte das Viech ist nicht da
Wenn das Viech nicht da ist
Wenn ich jetzt umsonst die Leute organisiert hab
Dann dreh ich durch
Der ist doch hier immer irgendwo oder
Da ist er doch
Ich sag doch der steht falsch der Typ
Hahaha
Klar dass das ne falsche Pose ist da unten man
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind
Die Leute spielen 20 Jahre da
Und finden die Mobs nicht
Ich hab doch nen Tank
Ich hab nen
Ich hab nen Savage
Einen R7 Savage oder R8 Savage
Reicht doch easy
Eden Eden
Pass mal auf der Savage der rockt
Alter
Hahaha
Der Heiler ist nicht mal da
Hab ich nicht eben noch nen
Hab ich nicht eben noch nen Tinder gesetzt hier
Oh hier Tinder
Ich hab das Ding sogar schon
Mit Skalde getankt
Das ist kein Ding
Wenn du ordentliches Equip hast und so ist es nicht so wild
So ich muss eigentlich gar nichts machen
Ob ich auch bei Wassern bin
Ja
Das ist das was ich vorhin gemeint hab
Der Unterschied zwischen
50er mit ordentlichem Equipment
Ordentlichen passiven Fähigkeiten
Alles
Der Char ist dann einfach 50% besser
Als ein 49,5er mit Levelgear
Okay ich muss kurz ranken
Ey auf Level
Der TwoShotted Leute in Levelgear
Ein Bersih in Levelgear ist TwoShot
Ein Treffer 70%
Große Herausforderung ist die nicht
Ich mein das ist Dark PvE
Okay wir haben es geschafft
Ja
Wie gesagt
Ich hab das sogar schon mit Skalde getankt
Das Ding
Was bekommt man als Belohnung wenn man den besiegt
Wirst du jetzt gleich sehen
Richtig nice Rüstung bekommt man dafür
Weil es der letzte Step
Von der Epic Rüstung
Quest Chain ist
Die dauert ungefähr so
Ah ne Stunde
Wenn man sie mit Speed und
Gescheiten Leuten macht
Und
Jetzt kann ich endlich meine gescheite
Runi Rüstung abholen
Damals lohnt es sich das Ding zu zerlegen für Platz
Macht es immer noch
Es lohnt sich hier enorm
Deswegen habe ich auch ein Battle
Jetzt verrate ich einen
High IQ Dark Freeshot Trick
Es lohnt sich richtig einen
Battleground Charakter zu haben
Und dort also einen Chain Battle
Also einen Battleground Charakter
Der
Kettenrüstung anhat
Dann geht man in den Battleground
Und
Farmt die Captains
Für die Captains Quest ab
Die droppen richtig krass Zeug
Und dann salvagest du
Und da kriegst du so krass
Kohle
Dann machst du innerhalb von ein paar Stunden
Innerhalb von einer Stunde
Machst du 5 Platin
Das ist super heftig
Ich gehe davon aus das nerven die auch noch
So jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an
Ich seh noob aus
Und jetzt seh ich gleich
Hoffentlich besser aus
Nice Hut am Start
Okay
Zack schonmal viel besser
Zack
Das sieht doch schonmal
Oh meine ganze Rüstung
Hoffentlich habe ich alles bekommen
Ja
Hat gerade so ins Inf gepasst
Alter
Okay Hero of Molvik kann weg
Kann weg
Ähm Hero of Molvik kann weg
Im Prinzip ist es nur
Der Hut den ich nicht anhab
Mhh
Lass mal kurz die Stats gucken
Ja das ist doch schon besser
Das ist doch schon besser
Das hier mit den Buffs aus
Okay damit kriegt man jetzt
Zumindest halbwegs was hin
Was ist besser der Epic Hut
Das Epic Circlet
Oder
Hä
Achso ja
Mit Casting Speed plus 2
Und das hier ist der Hut hat
Casting Speed plus 2
Und Magic Damage
Und Dex Cap
Okay der Hut ist auf jeden Fall besser
Jetzt brauche ich nur ein ordentliches Template für den Runi
Ich muss sagen ehrlich gesagt
Stats
Naja
Constitution ist so geil
Ich hatte schon deutlich schlechteres
Leveling Gear an als das hier
Aber es fehlt natürlich immer noch
Casting Speed Dex Cap
Und Resi Pierce
Und alles also ein ordentliches Runi Template
Muss an den Start
Ist das ein Boomer Game
Ja
Kann man so sagen
Kann man so sagen dass das ein Boomer Game ist
Würde ich
Würde ich mitgehen
Oh Fuck
Ich hab den Stängel mitgegessen
Gerade Katschibas
Gut
Ganz essenziell Leute
Ich muss
Etwas
Etwas besser aussehen als ich jetzt schon
So
Bin ich verwirrt
Genau
Ich muss ja was gescheitem aussehen
Das heißt ich log jetzt den Heiler ein
Und zieh ein Skin
Von meinem Heiler Umhang
Und geb dem Runi
Dass der Runi so aussieht
So aussieht als ist er Pro
Er hat zwar kein gutes Template an
Aber muss so aussehen als er ein gutes Template hat
Das heißt wir gehen jetzt
Zum Skin
Oder Pattern
Pattern Merchant oder wie das Ding heißt
Und fertigen uns
Mal ein Skin vom Umhang an
Weil dann
Dann seh ich zumindest schon nach Toa und Artefakten
Richtig pro aus
Ich mag das nicht mit Level 50
So komplett nubig auszuschauen
23 Jahre
Und best game ever so sieht es aus
Fragt mal Polemo was best game ever ist
Der wird ja schon erzählen
Dass es Starhawk ist
Best game ever
Wo ist der Pattern Dude
Da ist der Pattern Dude
Pattern
Ah Pattern
Und jetzt gehen wir gleich in den Vault
Schmeißen das Pattern da rein
Und dann sieht mein Runi wenigstens so
Semiprofessionell aus
Gothic Online
Gothic Online ist ja auch nur ein Mod
Das ist ein richtig echtes MMO
Habe ich irgendwo Platz hier noch drinnen
Ne geil
Was habe ich da für ein Shit überhaupt noch drinnen liegen
Lull ein 41er
Utility Ring Decks Stärke ja am besten
Den wir nicht für super viel Geld verkaufen können
Der kann weg
Und jetzt
Oh nein Game crashed
Ich habe vergessen Reshade auszuschalten
Moment habe ich den
Sekunde habe ich den Oma reingeschmissen
Jetzt in den Vault
Oder habe ich den Skin in den Vault
Reingeschmissen ich Kack Noob
Vielleicht Stamp
Ja
Ich hoffe
Ich habe den Skin reingeschmissen
Jetzt was futter nebenbei
Das Pattern
So
Wo ist mein Umhang
Level 25 Grauer Umhang
Bestes Equip hier
Wo habe ich denn meinen Epic Umhang
Hier Runemanzer Cloak
Casting Speed
Ja genau
Komm her
101 Decks
Bisschen wenig Con
Aber Scheiß drauf
Äh Pattern
Jaja except
Jetzt jetzt sehe ich pro aus hier
Guckt euch das mal an
Massive Highly Professional
Runemaster
So jetzt brauchen wir noch ein paar andere
Dinger
Wie voll ist denn eigentlich mein Vault
Nix
Alter
Das kommt da rein
Was sind das da
Kann ich irgendwie
Spirit Hits brauche ich nicht
Rove Molvik brauche ich auch nicht
Kann ein bisschen aufräumen
Adept Belt
Ähm
Den heben wir auf
Schnetz
Brauche ich auch nicht
Mana Trank brauche ich noch
Das können wir alles löschen
Das heben wir auch
Ups das heben wir auch auf
Das ganze Molvik Zeug
Das kann ich löschen
Das braucht kein Mensch
Das kann man eh nicht traden
Den Belt kann man verkaufen
Hero of Molvik brauche man nicht
Ich brauche noch nen Stab
Hab ich auch
Ich brauche noch ein bisschen was mit Con
Falls ich was finde
Gibt es anscheinend nicht
Das heben wir auch auf
Und die Pages stecken wir in den Vault
Gibt es hier noch BGs
Jede Menge BGs?
Battlecrowns
Auf Eden haben die das sogar richtig cool gemacht
Es gibt auch XP Off
Mein Heiler ist XP Off
Und er bleibt für immer 49,5
Das ist nämlich mein
Money Maker
Katal Valley Charme
So ich muss jetzt nur kurz gucken
Dass ich kein Mist verkaufe
Übrigens auch
Ein cooles Feature
Man kann
Items Recovern
Wenn man aus versehen Sachen verkauft hat
Das kann man auch nicht
Mega Pock
Was die Leute von Eden hier fabriziert haben
Last Name
Epiga
Wenn schon dann richtig
Ich muss mal die Sachen sellen
Ok das brauche ich auf jeden Fall
Nicht
Kann ich nicht sellen?
Wait
Nimmt keine Items
Dann muss ich zu der hier
Sell
Ich brauche
Mana Tränke
Und ansonsten alles
Gut
So ich brauche 2 Sachen
Ich zeig euch was
Können wir was lernen jetzt?
Passt mal auf.
Da auch Tricks.
Ich sollte das vielleicht jetzt nicht zeigen.
Dann machen das noch mehr Leute.
Die Items sind weg.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ich habe zumindest für einen Char noch mehr als genug Items.
Aber ich gucke jetzt mal.
Also.
Man kann sich selbst buffen.
Ihr seht, ich habe jetzt 312 Decks.
Das ist nicht richtig krass.
Mit richtigen Buffs geht das auf jeden Fall besser.
Aber.
Buff Bonus.
Wirkt auf Buff Tränke.
Das heißt.
Ihr könnt in den Market Explorer gehen.
Geht hier auf Any.
Sucht nach Buff Bonus.
Und dann sucht ihr euch gute Items.
Die ihr temporär rein swappen könnt.
Wenn ihr buffen wollt.
Ja, das ist egal.
Das kann ein Umhang sein.
Ja, 7 ist nix.
Das kann.
Wobei, den habe ich doch sogar schon an, oder?
Es ist Buff Bonus.
Plus 6 ist auch nicht so geil.
Buff Bonus.
Plus 7 ist auch nicht so geil.
Buff Bonus 6 auch nicht so tolle.
9.
Das ist schon besser.
Schon besser, schon besser.
Aber es sollte schon ein bisschen mehr sein.
Was ist denn gerade die Sache im Chat?
Habe ich irgendwas nicht aufgepasst?
Dicke Elfmannschaule 2.
Ne, ne, ne.
Das klappt nicht mehr.
Ey, du machst richtig gut.
Richtig gut Damage mit SB.
Ich würde aber sagen.
SB.
Ich bin kein großer Schleicherspieler, aber ich würde sagen SB von allen von den von den Schleichern der schlechteste.
Aber es nimmt sich nicht viel.
Ich würde sagen, Nightshade ist der beste.
Zaugt jetzt nicht so wirklich.
7 Buff.
Schild kann ich nicht sehen.
Ah.
Yes.
Das ist gut.
14% Buff.
Exzellent.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Hier auf Seite 2.
Okay.
Der Ring.
9.
Ich brauche noch mal mindestens 11.
Wenn ich noch mal 11 bekomme, das ist mir zu teuer.
Wenn ich mindestens 11 bekomme.
7.
6.
8.
Nochmal einen Umhang kann ich nicht gebrauchen.
10.
Ja.
Den kaufe ich doch glatt für einen P.
Hallo?
What the fuck?
Was jetzt?
Es buggt.
Buggt wiederum.
Wobei, wir gucken.
Wir gucken mal weiter.
Ein P ist ein P.
Muss ja nicht sein.
5 ist nicht so geil.
7 ist nicht so geil.
9.
10.
11 bräuchte ich.
11.
7.
9.
12.
Alles gut.
Jawohl.
Bye.
Alter.
Was ist mit deinem fucking Markt?
Denk's.
Explorer los, ey.
What the fuck?
Der will nicht.
Der ist broken.
Reset.
Buff-Bonus.
3.
Okay, jetzt.
Enhancing Supreme Ring.
Plus 12 Buff.
See.
Okay.
Und jetzt pass mal auf.
Ich hab jetzt 312 Decks.
Jetzt zieh ich meine Buff-Items an.
Und buff mich nochmal.
Dann switch ich wieder zurück.
Und jetzt hab ich gerade 35 Decks.
Exzellent.
So.
Und wenn man jetzt ganz abgedrehter Dude ist, dann baut man sich irgendwas mit Auto-Hotkey.
Was das switcht.
Da gibt's bestimmt Leute, die schon irgendwelche Magic-Auto-Hotkey-Geschiss gebaut haben zum
Item-Switchen fürs Buffen.
So.
Und jetzt vergleichen wir nochmal.
Pass mal auf.
Also ich hab jetzt 50 Cast-Speed jetzt.
Mit 50.
Und, äh, gescheiten Items.
Also mit 50 realistisch hab ich eh nen Decks-Charge, ja.
Ach stimmt, hab ich in Mysterium-Arlen noch den Mana-Save-Ding.
Okay.
Vergleichen wir doch mal meinen Damage auf so ne 0815-Fliege, die ich da vorhin versucht
hab zu bashen, jetzt mit 50.
Das dürfte ne ganze Ecke besser sein.
Vor allem der Cast-Speed dürfte deutlich besser sein.
Also und Farben brauch ich noch.
Ohne Farben kann ich ja nicht aus dem Haus, ja.
Sieht ja aus wie frisch, frisch 50 gelevelt.
So, Mücke, du musst dran glauben.
Alter, der Cast-Speed ist so viel besser, man!
Und das Ding ist...
909 Damage, okay, das Ding platzt einfach.
Jetzt resiste das.
Das Ding platzt einfach.
Ja, das macht echt nen Unterschied.
50 gescheites Equipment, gescheite Buffs.
Ich mein, die Buffs, das geht noch mehr, Decks, ne?
Mit Charmy-Buffs und sowas, aber...
Das ist jetzt schon ganz okay.
Das ist wirklich okay.
Es ist capped Decks.
Ich bekomme maximal, glaube ich, noch...
Ich kann maximal noch 40 Decks mehr bekommen.
Weil ich glaube, 100, 105, 150 oder irgendwie sowas ist.
Oder 100...
Was ist Decks-Cap 153?
Äh, nicht Decks-Cap, äh, Buff, Speck-Buff-Cap.
Weiß ich gar nicht aus dem Kopf, gar nicht.
Alter!
Wie die, alter, wie die platzen nur noch!
155.
155, ne?
Wie die platzen jetzt, die Viecher, Mann!
Purge is overrated, outdated.
Ja.
Ich mein, ich bin 2L2.
Da gibt's...
Hab ich...
Moment, was hab ich denn jetzt eigentlich schon gekauft von der Ars?
Nix.
Großartig, ne?
Äh, bisschen Decks, weil das preis-leistungs-mäßig gut ist.
Weil Power, weil das preis-leistungs-mäßig gut ist.
Longwind und, äh, TBF.
Ja.
Ja, als nächstes mal zumindest, äh, beim minimalsten Purge.
Ey, die Dinger platzen einfach nur noch jetzt.
Die platzen einfach.
Ich glaub, ich kann die jetzt sogar...
Ich könnte...
Können die Viecher sogar komplett ohne Bowls killen.
Okay, das war jetzt nur ein Blauer.
Aber die platzen jetzt einfach.
Guckt's euch an.
Bam.
Einfach deadge.
Hat Rudi nicht den Baseline?
Wir sind doch nicht in hip.
Wir sind nicht in hip.
Gibt keinen Baseline-Stun.
Ich mein, Rudi mit Baseline-Stun.
Immer her damit, ja?
Ich würd es...
Ich würd's sofort nehmen.
Ey, Moment, was?
Geb, geb nur her damit, ja?
Warum hab ich eigentlich kein Speedlaufen?
Was ist das?
Warum bin ich so dumm?
Guck mal, wie schnell er jetzt castet, ey.
Macht eigentlich irgendjemand DF zur Abwechslung?
Nö, keiner Bock, DF zu machen.
Okay.
Äh, Farben kaufen.
Und...
Mana-Pots kaufen.
Die hab ich noch vergessen.
Die ganzen Hips haben Baseline-Stun.
Ench hat Baseline-Stun.
Ellen hat Baseline-Stun.
Menta hat...
Menta ist richtig krass mit Baseline-Stun.
Mit dem 209er Nuke.
Ja.
Mana-Dränke kaufen.
Power.
Strong Trout of Power.
Jawoll, komm her.
90, jawoll.
Zack.
So, ich...
Ich stacke gerne meine Usables von unten.
Und, ähm...
Manche Sachen von oben.
Ich weiß nicht nach welchem System ich das mach, aber so wie ich's irgendwie am besten
finde.
Okay.
Jetzt porten wir...
Jetzt brauchen wir...
Hier nach...
Jetzt porten wir Agir.
Und jetzt brauch ich noch ein paar Farben.
Ja, Menta sind auch richtig krass.
Früher war die Klasse ja so semi-nice.
Haben auch nicht viele gespielt, aber seitdem ich ein paar Buffs gekriegt hab ist die richtig
gut.
Okay.
Also.
Farben!
Ich brauch...
Kappa-Brite-Ferbung.
Jawoll.
Violet.
Black.
P acLC.
Um-...
Alle meine Charts sehen so aus.
Deswegen werden die hier auch so gefilmt.
Moment.
Ich hab mich verklickt.
Alter. Jawoll.
So, der Hut. Was wird der Hut?
Chat?
Frage an euch.
Gleiche wie beim Heiler.
Cappy?
Oder Hut?
Und wenn Hut, welche Farbe?
Schwarz oder Violett?
Rot. Komplett random Farbe.
Grün. Grüner Hut.
Gut. Umhang macht
Gilden Logo drauf, klar.
Ein Redhead. Okay, Chat.
Ich seh, man kann euch ja nicht fragen.
Guck mal mal, wie das Violett aussieht.
Oh.
Okay, in Schwarz gefällt's mir besser
als in Violett.
Eventuell, eventuell
mach ich auch Hütchen auf.
Und noch unschlüssig. Hütchen oder
Hut.
Zumindest muss ich erstmal Gilden Logo auf den Umhang drauf machen.
Und, oh, Waffenfarbe.
Waffenfarbe.
Darf ja auch nicht vergessen werden.
Aber mach mal erstmal Gilden Logo drauf.
Your time.
Ups.
Ich versuch immer noch die ganze Zeit, mein Abendessen zu essen.
Seit einer Stunde.
Hey, wo ist der Gilden Logo-Typ?
Na.
Gilden Logo-Dude.
Yes.
Excellent. Hä? Das sieht doch richtig gut passend aus.
Jetzt müsst ihr zugeben.
War doch was, oder?
Passt von der Farbe?
Das sieht wirklich ganz gut aus jetzt.
Okay, und jetzt?
Eine Waffenfarbe noch als letztes.
Äh, ne, wie heißt das?
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben könnte.
Äh, das Laster?
Ja.
Grey, Blue, Crimson,
Pride, Rosé,
Weapon Laster.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob Pride, Rosé das richtige ist.
Ähm, Crimson, Crimson,
Pride, Rosé, Weapon Laster.
Okay.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, okay.
Jetzt sieht das auch ganz gut aus.
Bisschen, bisschen Kappa, Kappa-Pride-Farbe.
Nice.
Okay, gut.
So, lassen wir das.
Jetzt macht der Runi ein bisschen was her.
Jetzt sieht er nicht total Level 50.
Ich mein, ich hab immer noch Shit-Ausrüstung.
Wenn ihr das hier anguckt von den, von den Dingern und so.
Aber ich mein, ich hab halt auch noch null Sachen an, äh,
Template, geschweige denn SC-Sachen hier auf dem Runi.
Aber,
insgesamt für ein bisschen BG-Gezergel.
Reicht das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, in Rot wird meine Mütze so aussehen.
So, Leute.
Ich bin jetzt 6,5 Stunden on.
Jetzt noch eine Sache nach.
Gut.
Ähm,
ich geh jetzt ins, ich mach jetzt eine Runde BG-RVR.
Kann ich euch leider nicht mitnehmen gerade,
weil ich ohne
Delay-Streamer
und das ist für die 100 anderen Leute unfair,
wenn direkt gesehen wird, wo wir hingehen.
Äh, Name, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Nameplate-Standards sind.
Äh,
ja.
1200.
Achso, ne, sieht man gar nicht, was man hat, oder?
Ne, 1200 ist die Fall-Trend.
Ich hab nix umgestellt, ich hab nix umgestellt.
Aber irgendwie gilt n Gruppe-Technik was am Start für,
für BG.
Nicht wirklich.
Gut.
Chat-Game.
Das war's für heut.
Schön, dass so viele dabei waren.
Erstaunlich viele wieder.
Für so n olles Kack-Game.
Best Game ever.
Da bin ich überzeugt von, hab ich heut, glaub ich, heut oft genug erzählt, warum ich denke, dass das so gut ist.
Weil es irgendwie das beste Game ever ist.
Falls irgendjemand Bock hat, auszuprobieren, wie gesagt, da auch Eden,
klickt die Anleitung durch, das ist super easy, darauf zu spielen.
Ihr müsst im Endeffekt nur den offiziellen Client runterladen.
Und dann den Eden-Launcher starten und fertig.
Das war's.
Das heißt,
ich geh jetzt ne Runde BG-RVR spielen.
Da könnt ihr das nächste Mal mit, wenn ihr wollt.
Da kann ich das nächste Mal streamen, wenn's euch gefallen hat.
99-Store-Not-Patch.
Aber da starten sie einfach nochmal, dann patcht er das ja, dafür ist der Patcher ja da.
Und wenn's euch gefallen hat, sagt mir Bescheid.
Dann kann ich demnächst auch nochmal ne Runde...
Dann machen wir auch mal ne Runde BG-RVR zusammen.
Aber dann muss ich neu starten mit...
Delay.
Sonst wird das nix.
Alles klar.
Sehr schön, dass so viele dabei gewesen sind.
Wir gucken jetzt mal ganz kurz hier noch, wer streamt denn noch Dark.
Und dann hosten wir den einfach.
Und Dark streamt so untereinander.
Okay.
Es streamt genau...
Seh ich das richtig?
Einer.
Neben mir noch Dark.
Eden-Dark-Scale running around.
Zwei Zuschauer.
Pandamans-Häus ist am Start.
Pandamans-Häus ist abgewünscht.
Pilz.
Okay.
Okay. Seriously.
Ein Hip-Pilz-Zerger.
Den host ich net.
Und hier haben wir nen...
Eden-Software.
Eden-Solo-Skalde.
Der in der ollen Dings...
Da Festung rumläuft.
In dem Trelle-Trelleburg.
Genau.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das so spannend ist.
Da gibt's einen schlicht und ergreifend keinen.
Ich bin der einzige von drei Leuten, die da auch gestreamt haben.
Ja, das ist normal.
Michael-5-Spilian.
Das erwarte ich auch net.
Das ist ein olles...
MMO.
Was, wer es nicht gespielt hat, wahrscheinlich die wenigsten reinfinden.
Außer man steht auf so alte Sachen.
Aber Kreisel-Crime hätte es heute eh stattgefunden.
Ob online oder offline.
Wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.